foreign
you're running a business and you want
to reach more customers online
you have a great website but it's not
showing up on the first page of Google
search results what do you do this is
where
like a group of superheroes working
behind the scenes to improve your
website's search engine ranking now you
might wonder how much do these
superheroes make well it varies
depending on their job titles experience
and location but on an average an SEO
Specialist or an SEO analyst can make
anywhere between 48 000 to 72 000 per
year so if you are interested in
pursuing the career in SEO if you are
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below now let's check out what we have
in store for you for this SEO boot camp
we will begin this boot camp with a 5
minute segment on SEO then we will have
a brief discussion on SEO after that we
will learn exactly what SEO is following
that we will talk about on page SEO and
off-page SEO post that we will learn how
to build backlinks then we will explore
how to become an SEO expert in 2023 and
Google search console next we will learn
about local SEO
post that we will learn the art of
increasing website traffic and how to
rank number one on Google
following that we will learn about
measuring SEO performance and how to
report SEO campaign Matrix
then we will learn everything as you
need to know about Google Analytics 4.
after that we will check out some
interesting topics like domain Authority
in SEO and Page rank algorithm post that
we will learn how to incorporate chat
GPD for SEO then we will check out top
free SEO tools following that we will
explore various shops and companies
hiring for SEO professionals finally we
will wrap up this SEO bootcamp with some
tips and interview questions on SEO but
before we begin but before we begin
let's check out what one of our Learners
has to say about our courses
foreign
towards it and maintain a positive
attitude well I focused on my passion of
becoming a digital marketer and with the
help of Simply learn I was even able to
crack a job with 30 hike in my salary
hi I'm Karthik srinivas currently living
in Bangalore and working as a key
account manager at Green honchos I was
working as a BPO executor for almost two
years after my graduation and during the
lockdown one of my friend introduced me
to digital marketing and after that I
got really interested towards it I
learned basic digital marketing courses
online then I joined a mid-size digital
marketing agency in coimbatore as an
intern and after eventually completing
my intern I learned to run ads and I was
promoted as a Performance Marketing
executor in the same agency but I felt
that like I lack knowledge somewhere the
knowledge that I had was like bits and
pieces so I really felt that I need a
proper certification course to
understand in depths of like digital
marketing after my basic research online
I decided to go with professional
certificate program in digital marketing
with Purdue University I think it was a
great decision I was able to learn the
fundamentals of digital marketing from
basic level to the advanced level the
course was divided into six modules and
each modules explained about different
aspects of digital marketing and it was
what just I needed so after completing
the course I was able to perform well in
my company and I got promoted as a team
lead yeah after few months I got a
better job opportunity in Bangalore as a
assistant manager for account management
at green honchos with a decent 30 hike
in my salary I really feel happy with
the trajectory of my life and the career
so far I feel that like everyone should
keep learning and improving their skills
on a regular basis following that
philosophy I am taking another course
with simply learn I advise every
professional out there to keep looking
for ways to upskill themselves
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly
however even after regularly posting on
the blog there were barely any visitors
showing up deciding not to give up
Rachel began searching for a solution on
the internet that's when she came across
SEO or search engine optimization a term
she's never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having to spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO on-page and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle on-page
SEO and get that sorted on-page SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema meta Tags and More
she started off by using tools like
Google AdWords allref and semrush to
identify popular Search terms associated
with the recipes she planned to publish
on her blog she began to look for Search
terms related to the broader area of
baking cooking and related topics once
she found these Search terms she began
to incorporate them into her recipes she
started off by providing an introduction
to the recipe with this she could
provide an engaging beginning to her
story like how the dish reminded her of
her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website metacontent that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results
optimize The Meta tax alt tags header
Tags and More this completed the on-page
aspect of SEO thanks to this she saw a
significant increase in the number of
visitors coming to her page having done
all she could on her webpage she now
decides to explore what could be done
off page to improve her Page's
visibility on search engines off-page
SEO involved Rachel doing things outside
her site page to help increase its
search engine rankings making
optimizations outside the site would
improve the site's popularity relevance
trustworthiness and Authority this is
possible with the help of reputable
websites vouching for your content with
backlinks social media marketing guest
blogging linked unlinked brand mentions
influencer marketing and much more
Rachel also understood that for her
content to reach people she would have
to promote it on social media platforms
like Facebook Twitter and Instagram as
well as Niche platforms like quora
Reddit and medium these could help her
achieve greater reach for her website by
sending stronger social signals to
search engines
leading to the page being shown as
highly relevant for related searches and
audiences and even after understanding
and implementing all of this Rachel had
just scratched the surface of what was
possible with SEO if interested
in simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below around 1991 the world's first
website site was launched in the coming
years one turned into hundreds and
hundreds into thousands ultimately
crowding the internet necessity is the
mother of invention so this was a time
to structure and make the information on
the Internet is accessible which led to
the birth of search engines search
engines help people to find information
on the internet so now the question
arises how are search engines able to
identify the information people are
searching for this happens with the help
of Search terms users enter to search
for the information search engines
identify the web content containing
those phrases thereby displaying it into
the search engine result pages also
known as serps so to break users or
search engine traffic to your website
you will need to optimize your web
content with the Search terms or
relevant keywords which users are
actually looking for say if you have a
shoe website then it should have
keywords like sneakers sport shoes and
some phrases like best nickels for men
which will help you to gain more use
attraction and for this search engine
optimization plays an important role so
the process of getting good quality and
quantity of traffic on your website or a
web page through search engines is
called search engine optimization or SEO
in short search engine optimization
practices involved on-page SEO of page
SEO and Technical SEO each of these is
directly or indirectly responsible for
getting organic traffic to your website
with the growth of SEO industry and
Rising demand for SEO experts leading
companies like Microsoft udemy Deloitte
and Siemens are already hiring SEO
expert with salaries going as high as as
hundred thousand dollars per hour so
we're gonna use a basic example and
let's just say you have a Blog you're a
food blogger you're passionate about
food and your Niche is ice cream and
let's just say you have a lot of ice
cream recipes you want to get traffic to
your blog you want people to read your
blog and you're curious why am I not
ranking for my blog why when people type
in ice cream recipes and say Google my
blog posts don't appear at the top of
organic rankings and there's a number of
reasons why you wouldn't be ranked for
your blog post or your ice cream recipes
and the main reason would be your
competitors so there could be somebody
else out there who is also passionate
about ice cream and has been blogging
along longer than you and they have more
content and more blog posts and more
pages for Google to rank so that's
usually the number one reason the other
reason is improper use of keywords and
we're going to talk a little bit or it's
actually a lot more about you know
keyword usage in your content so what
kind of keywords do you want to rank for
that's really what we're talking about
when we talk about usage of keywords
what keywords do you want to rank for
and how do we work those keywords into
the content another reason is poor link
building practices and really that means
our other blog posts or other websites
linking to you also are you linking to
other pages on your website and so it's
all about link building and with link
building it's internal linking so are we
linking from one blog post to another
and it's external linking our other
websites of high quality linking to us
and so that's what we talk about when we
talk about link building and then
another reason is web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say WordPress for example and your blog
post isn't loading fast enough well if
you look at it this way think about it
if you're Google would you really want
to rank a website or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
go Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's a hundred students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay
competition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just mentioned about structure
logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well they basically follow
links you might have heard the term
spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index So based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then you're not going to show up
for Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one way in 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are one million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword slimply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the one million 10 000 results
and so that's a whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available for crawling
and indexing and so when a user types a
query on search Google search the most
relevant websites that are in Google's
index are going to pair in the search
results so in the example I gave was
simply learn well simply learn is the
brand name of the company simply learned
so there's a lot of relevancy there so
that's why you see simply learn show up
here organically number one like we
mentioned about what is SEO and why SEO
we talked about that user experience so
there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so location is important
language is important and relevancy is
important along with user experience so
all those are important factors in how
Google ranks websites okay so we're
going to talk about the types of SEO now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on Google we're going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off-page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page and our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can can do for SEO
and why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keyword you want then you can
go and apply on pages SEO you can change
the title tag The Meta descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition there is for
that keyword and of course relevancy
okay you need to be able to choose a
keyword that's relevant to the web page
you're trying to rank for and so let me
show you example how to go through this
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google's going to do is
they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I can
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on Google dot com and
so Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can say the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume and competition so in this case
we have volume from Google planner
Google's Keyword Planner and I have
competition from Google's Keyword
Planner and so if I go into a
spreadsheet and I put all that
information in here I'm going to be able
to see the volume and competition and so
that's important however one thing to
note here is that Google's Keyword
Planner if I go back just gives us low
medium and high and if I want to compare
numbers to numbers maybe I want to be
able to get exactly the competition
number for the keyword how to become a
digital marketing specialist what I can
do is go into Google and I can type in
that keyword so if I type in the keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist I can see there's 76 Million
results so I could see 76 million in
results 76.1 actually and for the
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO
it's okay you want to
great content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk candidate meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because one we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link you need to remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing Specialists and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building and internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end you
user experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key or
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of testing on the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap and XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml just as
an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and all
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page SEO we used internal
linking for off-page SEO we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our
websites recognize Mission or relevancy
or credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have have
basically links to other web pages
pointing back to us then basically our
domain Authority is going to improve and
when our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website then other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are incredibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they
might type in our brand name in this
case simply learn and so these are all
the benefits to off-page SEO so it's
nothing more than having links on other
websites that are pointing back to ours
and again there's lots of benefits its
drives helps Drive traffic and increases
our Authority so those are things that
we want to take advantage of when we
want to rank and the key behind off page
SEO or link building is always going to
be content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream cream blog and ice cream recipes
well it probably wouldn't be a bad idea
to say spend some time on other blogs
related to desserts related to cakes
related to food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you could share your content
with them they can share their content
with you and generally that's how it
works naturally anyway in the web sphere
if somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content somewhat of yours so that
you can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind having external
links pointing back to your website is
social media so social media is not just
Facebook or Twitter but it fans beyond
that there's there's core there's media
there's all sorts of content generated
websites like Reddit so the list goes on
and on you just need to find what's
relevant for your content if it's
relevant for your content then it's
worth putting or trying to get the
external link on that social media
platform and then again going back to my
ice cream blog recipes blog post yeah if
you find a particular blog that you want
to have an external link on there's
nothing wrong with reaching out to that
particular blogger you know in some
cases very flattering but in other cases
if the content is relevant then why not
it's only going to help your end user
experience if you add somebody who has a
say a Blog about cakes having their link
on your blog post so there's nothing
wrong with it because it also adds to
the user experience and if you're going
to ask somebody to put an external link
on theirs you might want to be
open-minded and make sure that you're
are able and willing to put an external
link on your blog post or website
pointing to their content that's how the
web Works especially if the contents of
quality relevant and of good nature okay
so let's move on and finish up with the
do's and don'ts of SEO so we talked a
lot about why SEO what is SEO how do we
rank for SEO what is on page SEO what is
off-page SEO and so let's just wrap up
with some of the things you again want
to do to rank your page for a particular
keyword and some of the things you don't
want to do so the first thing on the
list is optimize for white hat
techniques and what I mean for opting in
for white hat techniques is basically
everything I just mentioned today you
want to do keyword research you want to
choose a natural language processing
form format so you could choose keywords
that are going to be relevant natural to
the content and you don't want to opt
for black hat techniques and black hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so that's
probably not something you want to do
because again it's not going to be good
for the end user so stay away from black
hat and focus on some of the techniques
we talked about in today's presentation
the other do we want to do is get
backlinks from relevant sites so that's
off page SEO again it's what I mentioned
earlier it's about linking your quality
content to another person's website that
also has quality content we don't want
to have a backlink from an irrelevant
site why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if if you were on a quality website
we do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one or two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
or two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keywords that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly if you are
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below on-page optimization as the name
suggests is the practice of optimizing
web pages to rank higher and get
relevant traffic from the search engine
on-page optimization includes both
content and HTML source code
optimization
search engine optimization can be very
complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it very easy just to break it up into
general concepts that you might already
have an understanding of when you look
at the hundreds of signals that go into
SEO they can be broken up into either
relevancy or because sometimes it's both
popularity so relevancy and popularity
out of all these signals they fit into
one of these two things we're going to
break all the signals we have into these
two areas in this section we're going to
talk about the on-page factors that's
because these are the factors that you
have direct impact upon and you can make
a small tweak and have a big impact with
Organic traffic with your on-page
relevancy factors the primary on-page
relevancy factors that I'll cover in
this lesson are title tags and meta
descriptions header tags which are used
for headlines and subheadings website
URLs and URL structure in image alt text
internal links keyword usage and
sitemaps
let's start with one of my favorites and
that is the title tag this is also
called a page title the page title is
not shown on the page now rather it is
displayed on the browser Tab and this is
what makes it highly important is that
in addition to being displayed on the
browser tab it is also the title tag or
the page title that is shown on the text
in the Google search results as the link
to the page
the page title influences both the
click-through rates and people's first
impressions of our website next up we
have the meta description
Now The Meta description can be a bit
confusing
The Meta description is in the code and
it does not influence rankings
but it does influence clicks
people will see your snippet or your
page information in the search engine
results
that gray text is the meta description
if you don't have a meta description
then it may pull information from the
page
you can affect this and improve the
chances of your meta description
appearing if you write a short
descriptive phrase of the content or the
purpose of the page
and just because we edit these elements
does not guarantee that they will show
up
I often say that we affect the change
but we cannot control it
this is because the search engine May
override your changes and show different
content in these areas
sometimes it may help and it might be a
better description but many times it's
not
now let's go to the next element the
header tags these are also referred to
as the heading and subheading
and this is how HTML was built when the
web was first created
it enables a logical hierarchy of
content
so starting with the headline then
displaying a subheading and then
subheadings after that
the idea here is that you're
establishing a hierarchy of information
so you start with the H1 like a
newspaper there's only one main headline
per page
it describes the main purpose of the
page
then a subheading the H2 this is how you
break the sub content into sub
categories obviously you'll want to use
a keyword in there as well
you see by describing the purpose of the
page in the headline and then again in a
subheading you're naturally going to use
your primary and secondary keywords
because you're going to associate them
with the product or the purpose and the
benefit
the key is to keep it short
you see after the headline are the
subcategories the H2S and then your H3
is typically used as a paragraph heading
now putting the keyword in these
headings alone does not make your page
optimized
remember the purpose is to provide a
quick reference for people to find the
content they need within seconds
so short explanatory heading and
subheadings paragraph headings are very
effective
and naturally you'll be using keywords
to help people locate the information
that is most important to them
now if we go back to the search engine
results page the serp there is another
element in that listing the page title
is the large Blue text The Meta
description is the gray text now the
green text is the URL of the page that
is listed this is the address of the
page just like the address for your home
the internet knows that the URL is the
address for that page this is extremely
important for SEO for a variety of
reasons the most important though is
your keyword usage I like to make sure
that I have at least one Relevant Word
in the URL now also here keep it short
one of the worst things you can do is
have a URL full of keywords or even
worse hyphenate them all remember people
use these urls
they provide context for the page people
also copy and paste URLs into Mobile
messages emails and Social Links so it
is extremely important to keep these
short succinct and I like to say
readable
now I've just briefly touched about the
importance of the URL and now let's look
at the URL structure
first let's start with the primary core
of the URL the domain name
in the example with the URL I have here
example.com that's the domain name so
this is the first thing that people see
with your online business
now
be on the internet this is going to be
what's in all of your ads emails
brochures business cards and online your
social profiles all of your marketing
efforts are going to drive people to
this domain there's a lot of advice
about buying or using domains that have
your keywords in them and unfortunately
domains have been being sold for decades
so there's less chance of finding a
domain with the keywords you want now
the search engines don't make the
keyword used in the domain a primary
ranking signal so that's good however
the domain is your business it needs to
be memorable if you have a very I call
it a spammy looking domain name with
multiple words and hyphens or one that's
hard to spell or confusing people are
going to make an initial impression off
of that so make sure you have something
that's going to make a great first
impression here's the rule for a domain
name something that's easy to spell and
easy to pronounce ideally sure it's
something you can type and share
something thing you're going to be able
to put on a business card and be proud
of not something that you bought
primarily because you want it for SEO
reasons and you think with that you're
going to succeed as an example just
think about Amazon their domain name
says nothing about books and yet it grew
to be one of the largest e-commerce
companies in the world the same with
Alibaba or Google their domain names
were not the keyword but their marketing
and branding built their company now
everything after the domain is a
subdirectory this is based on your
website organization as an example if
you have a website selling shoes then
the subdirectory can be called shoes
it's easy right the subdirectory is the
folder that contains the relevant files
or Pages for that group think of a file
folder with documents inside the file
folder is usually based on a major
category of content or products now
inside the folder are individual
documents or Pages these files or Pages
usually come after the subdirectory in
this example you see the file.html the
next step in optimizing the URL is to
name the page in a way that explains the
content of the page to use our eCommerce
shoe website a page name would usually
be a specific product name this way you
would end up with domain name forward
slash shoes as the category forward
slash brand name running shoe insert
that here
if you've ever looked at the HTML that
make up the instructions of the page
you'll understand a bit more of how
search engines get the information from
the page the text on the page and the
markup such as the headings provide
instructions as to where the text is
located the importance and prominence of
the text in addition to the arrangement
of the overall page HTML is a set of
instructions for a browser to assemble
the page and the search engines use that
as well now the search engines spiders
cannot see images as the internet
developed many attributes were added to
provide for accessibility and additional
features users that are site impaired
cannot see images
and the alternative text tag describes
the image
further there are many times when our
bandwidth isn't strong and not all of
the images will load in that case we
need the alt text description to provide
the context of the image and its purpose
search engines use this alt text
description to gain additional context
about the page the content of the image
and its purpose now we have an entire
section on links but at this point I
just want to cover internal links an
internal link is a link from one page on
your website to another page of your own
website now this is important from a
relevancy perspective you'll see
internal links in your main navigation
you'll likely have a link that says home
one that says contact us or about our
company
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section if
you click on this link is about our
company or this is where you find our
contact information
you see these links are not votes like
external links
however they provide relevance and
context to the information on your own
website
let's dive in a little more on keywords
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of specific
keywords
it's a lot more complex than that
it's using a technology called natural
language processing
natural language processing uses
algorithms to try to understand the
meaning of text
you see search engine processing is
attempting to be human
this is the same way that people see and
hear the words and we're using the words
to find the meaning expressed in the
words
similarly when a search engine goes to
your website it may see keywords but
it's looking for the context of those
words
you may say football but just having the
word football repeated throughout your
website isn't going to help you rank
specifically for football
what you need to do and what is more
common in actual human conversation
happens very naturally
when we talk about football we use
naturally additional words such as goal
and referee and World Cup you see Google
and the other search engines are going
to take these into account by usage of
other synonyms and other common words
you present the context of a bigger
broader idea for your website
the next site signal that we have is
site Maps now there are two kinds of
site Maps there's the site map that is
for humans and there is the site map
that are for search engine robots
crawlers or spiders
the one that is for human is called an
HTML sitemap you've probably seen these
before the link is generally in the
footer of a website if you click on it
it shows you the major sections of the
website provide some search
functionality but looking at it as a
human it shows you the hierarchy of the
website and where to find important
information
it shows how everything fits together
now there's something else that exists
called an XML sitemap
it's not linked from any page of your
website but exists as an independent
file on your server
now this is something you can see but it
is formatted for search engine spiders
using a programming language called XML
it shows the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs of the website every
page every document every image and it
also shows the date that each page was
last updated or changed
so at this point we've covered a lot of
things that are important and things
that you should be doing when optimizing
your on-page content
now let's go a different direction and
cover things that you should not be
doing keyword stuffing hidden text
repetitive anchor text and cloaking the
first one is keyword stuffing now back
in the early days of search engine
optimization the people used to increase
the instances of words on the page
now this is well before natural language
processing at that time search engines
were looking for occurrences of specific
words well search engines they're very
smart about this
what may have worked 20 years ago or 10
years ago keyword stuffing does not work
you're not going to rank better for any
given phrase by including it a dozen or
more times on the page in fact you might
get an over optimization penalty by
constantly repeating the same word over
and over focus on writing content that
engages with your visitors and uses
language naturally now the next one is
hidden text unfortunately I still see
this this is when you write content that
is solely for search engines and not for
people now typically it is attempted by
writing a lot of repetitive keywords as
text coloring it white and placing it
against a white background
see this was developed as another way to
add more keyword stuff text without the
user seeing the overuse of keywords now
it didn't work too well in the past and
it definitely does not work today this
tactic backfires in two ways first
search engines can tell when it's white
text on a white background it's easy to
tell from a computer science point of
view
search engines read the HTML and in the
HTML are the instructions for colors
when you hide text modern search engines
are smart enough to figure it out
probably better than a human now
secondly it's done to hide repetitive
keyword stuff text which is the second
thing against you these outdated
unprofessional tactics will most likely
get a website penalized by the search
engines the next one is repetitive
anchor text
you may have followed a link to a page
when looking for a business or
information and instead of the
information you want you get a page that
doesn't feel like it was written for
people
every sentence is redundant repetitive
and almost every keyword is linked even
when there doesn't need to be a link
it confuses the flow of the information
on the page now again this used to be a
tactic that sometimes would work but
it's no longer helpful
search engines and their natural
language processing algorithms have
advanced significantly they can tell
when something's not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and rankings but not for people
search engines will figure it out please
don't waste time on redundant links
trying to inflate the relevance of your
links and Pages the last thing to cover
here is cloaking cloaking is the idea of
showing one thing to the search engines
and something entirely different to
humans now this is related to the rest
of the tactics I just covered it's
something that used to work but it was
expressly against the search engine
guidelines while it may have worked if
the search engine is discovered it on
your website you could have been
penalized or dropped from the search
engine results entirely now we've
covered all of the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretically
perfectly optimized page would look like
in this example we can see many of these
elements being used together you can
also see that the base key phrase
digital camera is being repeated but
always included with a specific contact
next first at the top of the page is the
URL which has digital cameras in the
address
the page title follows using the context
of the information and adding the word
reviews you can also see at the top of
the page that the main navigation and
secondary navigation also called the
breadcrumb navigation provides context
of the Page's location within the entire
website and natural keyword usage
the H1 headline is the key phrase but
also happens to simply be the best title
for the content of the page
the subsequent subheadings provide
additional information such as ratings
recommendations and features
the links provide relevant ways to
access additional content
the image utilizes alt text there are
also clear calls to action which provide
relevant offers to visitors
as you can see the context of all of the
content is very strong and sends a clear
relevancy signal to both search engines
and readers
to conclude this section I'd like to
cover the top influencing factors now
sometimes you may find these as lists
but I found it a bit more practical to
separate them into categories
typically every year you'll find these
collections of lists from surveys
experts or speculation
some are from testing but honestly you
can't ever truly test a search engine as
they change a little bit with every
algorithm
so the best thing is to take from these
lists these factors that are the tried
and true factors over the years that
have worked consistently
also those tactics that not only make
your website more effective with users
they tend to do well with search engines
so if a tactic serves that Dual Purpose
it's a good tactic
so these are not exclusive and have to
lists for every situation but guides and
indicators for you to use the top
on-page factors from surveys opinions
and data are these
a relevant page title page headings
anchor text links a keyword-based URL
a keyword or contextual file name such
as page name image name or PDF file name
alt text and images and finally what you
do with the content on a page to make it
more readable lists bullet points and
bolded text
the top factors for off-page linking
tend to contain these items
the total number of domains linking to
you
the number of Highly influential domains
linking to you
the number of unique domain IP addresses
the total backlinks without no follow
limits
the total relevant anchor text in links
to you
and finally the types and context of
keywords in Anchor text links
the domain also contributes factors to
your overall rankings such as the age of
the domain which would include ownership
information such as the length of time
owned and operated by a company
the real business information tied to
that domain such as the business address
being the same as the business
registration address for the domain
in addition the signals from social
accounts driving visits to the domain
functionally the search engines also
utilize some attribution based on the
quality of programming of the website
for instance taking care of the basic
search engine Protocols of the
robots.txt file XML sitemap and https
protocol
websites that Implement these features
have shown that they are familiar with
search engine guidelines and protocol
now one of the changes over the past few
years has been the implementation of
page speed as an increasing ranking
Factor
slow loading pages with a lot of
extraneous code that slow the delivery
of the page will be penalized as they
take away from the user experience
optimizing the page code speeding up the
load time of the page can directly
impact your rankings and this is closely
related to the mobile friendliness of
your website
if your website is not mobile friendly
it will be limited in visibility as
Google's primary index is focused on
mobile devices and mobile delivery
behavioral factors are the newest
factors and with the Advent of
artificial intelligence it is making
determining the intent and the is making
determinings easier
for a search engine to derive a judgment
of relevancy based on interaction
while the extent of these signals is not
fully known it is suspected that they
are minor but growing in importance
these include the amount of users that
search for a brand name business name
and go to that result showing brand
awareness
also the amount of direct visits
bypassing search
time on page pages per session which is
also called the depth of visit
and lastly the behavior of a Searcher
from the results page how many results
are clicked how many times do they
return to the results this evaluation is
looking to judge if the results
presented were satisfactory or deficient
for that query search engine
optimization or SEO has proven to be one
of the most important factors in getting
higher rankings in the search results
strategies like image optimization page
optimization backlink building
keyword research
Etc are responsible for getting higher
rankings in search results however
keyword research has its own importance
in both the ways that is for organic
search as well as for the paid search
thereby becoming an important part of
search engine optimization
in this video we are going to put a
light and learn in depth about keyword
research for search engine optimization
but before we begin please consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn
now let's have an overview of what we
are going to learn in this video first
let's understand what do we mean by
keyword research
next we will know about the importance
of keyword research
before going in depth about the topic it
is necessary to know what is long tail
keywords and short tail keywords
moving ahead we will check the list of
keyword research tools
further we will understand how to
perform keyword research next we will
understand how to do keyword research
with the help of various tools
next we will see how keyword research is
important in grabbing the job
opportunities where we are going to
cover all the roles and responsibilities
and finally we will end this discussion
by knowing the scope of keyword research
in the coming years
dear Learners if you want to get
certified as a skill SEO professional
that 243
do have a look at the advanced search
engine optimization skill up course by
simply learn check the link in the
description box below
so let's begin this interesting session
by knowing what keyword research is yes
we are definitely going to know what is
keyword research but before this it is
important to understand what is a
keyword
keywords are the ideas or topics that
clearly describe what your content is
about
say for example here the title of the
slide is what is keyword research
so this is the keyword which suggests
that this slide contains the content
about keyword research
so basically
keyword research is a process of
identifying keywords or popular Search
terms that people tends to search for
when you identify relevant keywords all
you need to do is include these keywords
smartly into your content and this will
help your content to get higher rankings
and search results now the question
arises why does keyword research has so
much of importance in search engine
optimization
let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to your
website or your content
how does this exactly happens
when you select the most appropriate
keyword for your content there is an
opportunity where you can rank high in
search results by ranking higher there
are more chances that audience can
discover your content and reach to your
website
thus you get more and more consistent
traffic growth for your website
thereby indirectly promoting your
products and services
now that you are aware of how keyword
research holds importance
let's now see some essential types of
keywords that is long tail keywords and
short tail keywords so first we will
start with long tail keywords long tail
keywords are the keywords that are
mostly used to get more specific results
long tail keywords include keywords with
three or more words
for example shoes for a black dress now
coming to short tail keywords short tail
keywords are the general keywords or
more specifically General Search terms
short tail keywords include one or two
words in the keyword
for example shoes
now let's see the difference between
both the long tail and short tail
keywords by demonstrating let's go to
google.com
so now we are here to check the
difference between long tail keywords
and short tail keywords
so first we will check for the short
tail keyword
now suppose I am looking for the shoes
that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress
so here I add shoes
and see how the results are appearing
okay if you see the recommendations here
we get shoes for men shoes for women
shoes images shoe size chart
shows for rainy season
etc etc
and if I enter here
only shoes what are the results here I
get number of results from the shopping
websites
uh
with the very number of shoes
with number of Brands and somewhere
locations of the shops
but none of the result is relevant
to what I am expecting that is the shoes
for my black dress okay so now
I'll just change
my search query I'll add a long tail
keyword here
and I will search your more specifically
for what I wanted
so here I'll add shoes for
black
dress
okay
so here I am getting number of ideas the
image ideas in the search result that
what kind of shoes are going to go best
with my black dress
and here I'm getting several
combinations which I can wear with my
black dress so 12 best color shoes
here again I'm getting if we observe
clearly then all these results are
completely aligned to what exactly I am
looking for okay
and if I again change this query
more specific like shoes for black dress
for women
let's see what I get
so here I am getting more specific
results
in terms of movements
we will definitely understand how to use
long tail keywords or short tail
keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video Let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword research
here I have got a small list of tools
that you will need to perform effective
keyword research so first we will begin
with Keyword Planner
Keyword Planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by Google some of
the important features of Keyword
Planner in clothes discovery of new
keywords
estimate monthly searches for a keyword
get the average cost of ads for the
keyword you are looking for and help to
organize keywords the next tool that we
have in our bucket is sem Rush
some important features of sem Rush
includes
helps to get competitor keywords data
it helps to get competitor backlinks
data finds competitors top performing
content
helps in getting competitors campaign
data
Etc
let me bring it to you notice that sem
Rush is one of the best platforms that
fulfill all your SEO needs
so do visit to semrush.com you can find
the link in the description box below
next tool that we have in our bucket is
RFS the free keyword generator tool by
RFS helps to discovered keyword ideas
helps in identifying the search volume
estimations
identify easy keywords for which you can
possibly rank for
helps you to get a list of long tail
keywords
and however it is not limited to Google
searches only Yes you heard it right
you can get keyword ideas for Google
Bing
YouTube
Yahoo
Etc now let's check another tool which
is Google Trends
Google Trend will come into action
during your keyword research when you
are looking for the top search queries
by users that is the most trending query
moreover you can check these details of
search queries
for your country for any other country
or even worldwide
not only this but you can also choose a
type of search for this query like web
search email search YouTube search
Etc
the next tool that we have is answer the
public tool
answer the public tool has free as well
as paid versions
this tool can prove a magic wand for
your business as it suggests the
questions that are asked by people in
your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet and the last tool
in our today's list is keyword tool dot
IO keyword tool dot IO has free as well
as paid versions keyword 2.io helps to
get keyword ideas from various sources
like Google YouTube Bing Amazon eBay
Instagram Twitter Pinterest
Etc we will definitely understand how to
use these tools in the upcoming part of
the video
to make use of these tools it is
necessary to understand how to perform a
keyword research
as we have already seen why keyword
research is important let's now see how
to perform keyword research here are the
top 5 ways to perform keyword research
to perform keyword research it is
important to understand the domain and
who the audience is understanding the
correct audience will help you to get
more correct keyword during the research
for example if you are performing
keyword research for healthcare website
the audience would be a patient or
anyone who wants to know about Health
Center or a disease so with this tip
let's try our hands on the first keyword
research technique which is keyword
discovery to get a list of keywords use
keyword research tools like Google
Keyword Planner
Etc now all you need to do is go to the
keyword research tool and search for the
required keyword idea here sugar-free
ice cream is what I have searched for
now if you see at the bottom you will
see the relevant keywords for sugar-free
ice cream with their average monthly
searches
change
year on ear change competition
ads impression share bidding with high
and low
Etc so let me bring it to you notice
that from all the keywords in the list
not every keyword will be important or
will be useful for your industry so
while choosing a keyword please be
careful so always choose a keyword with
a good search volume higher search
volumes are always good so by choosing
keyword make sure that monthly search
volume is at least between 1K to 10K or
above so with monthly search volumes you
can see another metric which is
competition
it is a helpful metric during a keyword
research if keyword will either have a
high competition a low competition or a
medium competition this metric helps the
user to understand the keyword
difficulty or how hard it is to rank for
your website for this particular keyword
a keyword with high competition has more
number of bidders high competition
keywords are mostly taken up by the
advertisers who are willing to put up
their ad campaigns now talking about how
to choose keywords for organic rankings
dear Learners competition metrics will
also be helpful here you will understand
this in the upcoming part of the video
we have already learned about long tail
keywords and short tail keywords so now
with the help of keyword type and
various metrics learned earlier let's
understand how to choose keywords to get
organic rankings suppose you have a new
business
so initially it will be difficult to get
relevant audience for your site in such
a situation try getting a long tail
keyword with good search volume and low
competition
long tail keywords are helpful in
getting more accurate results if the
keyword is long tail
the chances of ranking it higher in the
search engine result Pages increases
however we are also choosing low
competition which suggests that
competition for keyword is low and the
chosen keyword can take a strong
position in the search results this can
help you to get more of the relevant
audience once you started getting more
and more traffic you can experiment with
short tail keywords with low medium and
high competition
now considering your business has a very
strong hold over a market in such a
situation you can simply choose long
tail keywords with good search volume
and medium or high competition this will
help you to attract audiences
organically or through paid campaigns
next we will see search for trending
keywords to get an instant spike in the
traffic trending keywords are the best
ones to be targeted
all you need to do is keep an eye on
what's the recent news or the trending
topic in your industry now create the
content targeting those keywords for
your website
for this you can make use of Google
Trends which will help you to identify
the trending keywords also you can
choose the search platforms like web
search YouTube search Etc or select the
geographical location as per your
requirement
well if you have great content then the
next strategy will be 100 effective for
your business which is competitor
keyword research it is said that don't
work hard work smart so let's try to do
some smart work here gather the list of
competitors who are doing well in your
industry
now keep an eye on the keywords that
they are using to represent their
products and services
if those keywords benefit your
competitors then they will definitely
prove fruitful for your business as well
to find competitor keywords you can use
various competitor research tools check
the video on top 10 free SEO tools to
get the best knowledge about competitor
research tools you can get the link from
the description box below the strategy
of using competitor keywords works best
for new as well as strong businesses
next let me put a light on another
important keyword research strategy
which is
to identify Search terms people are
looking for this is the best and
quickest way to attract audiences for
example I have an ice cream business
nowadays people are more health
conscious so there is a possibility that
a person suffering from diabetes is
likely to search for sugar-free ice
creams near me or how to make a
sugar-free ice cream
here I get one of the important keywords
with respect to my ice cream business
again if I say I have a tourism business
then I will look for the keywords around
travel and tourism now suppose a person
is looking for best location to spend
holidays here I will get an important
keyword to highlight my tourism business
in a travel blog website
so now the question arises how to get
these keywords dear Learners to get such
keyword ideas just go to google.com and
use Auto suggest features from Google
all you need to do is simply type
whatever query you require and you will
get a list of recommendation below
recommendations are the easiest way to
understand what the audience is actually
looking for now all you need to do is
pen down all these keywords and choose
the relevant one for your domain this
strategy is completely fair with new or
any business which has hold over a
market
if you are interested in creating your
content then try checking answer the
public tool which will give you the
keyword ideas in your industry that
audience are actually searching next we
have is reverse keyword mining with this
strategy we will try to dig the keywords
for which your website appears in the
search results but may not get clicked
let's see how it is done check the
performance reports in the Google search
console here you will get list of
keywords for which your site appears
it is possible that your site may not
have accurate content and so may not get
clicks and thereby gaining no traffic
from that keyword however these keyword
ideas are the indications that search
engines somewhere finds your content
relevant to these keywords and that is
the reason your website is getting
several impressions for that keyword
you can choose keywords and create
accurate content which will thereby
result in gaining a great audience for
your website
now that you are aware of how to do
keyword research let's try to understand
how to use keyword research tools and
implement the above strategies for
various scenarios
so we are going to demonstrate
few keyword research tools here the
number one is Keyword Planner next is
Google Trends and next we have is sem
Rush choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more so
now first we will start with Keyword
Planner
let's go to Keyword Planner
planner
so here we are in the Keyword Planner
for those who are new to Keyword Planner
go to tools and settings and just click
on Keyword Planner
and there you come up with the Keyword
Planner tool now let's consider that you
have a blogging site
and you are on a way to create a very
amazing and creative content on how to
make a sugar-free ice cream
so if you see here Keyword Planner Works
in both ways you can directly input your
keyword and get the list of keywords
or get the list of relevant keywords or
you can just add a CSV file and you can
get the search volume for already
researched keywords so now here I'll
just input
how to make
a
sugar
free
ice cream
and just hit enter you can add here
number of keywords to check so for now
I'm just adding one
and just click on get results
over here
you can see a large number of results
now you can see here none of the keyword
is having monthly search volume in
between 1K to 10K
so let's find another relevant keyword
so suppose we choose your sugar-free ice
cream
and click on get results
so now here we got our main keyword as
sugar free ice cream which has 1K to 10k
of monthly searches and yes definitely
the competition is high means there are
a lot of competitors and it is somewhat
uh difficult to rank with this keyword
but
we can take a trial for here
to choose this keyword as a main title
for our blog
again we have here sugar-free ice cream
near me so again this is somewhat
location based query so someone who is
looking for the ice cream centers near
them so there is a possibility that
those audiences will be adding this
query to get the appropriate results but
this won't be accurate for our blogging
site to make a sugar-free ice cream so
let's check what is there in the list
okay every keyword is high has a high
competition
so let's choose here sugar-free ice
cream for a Blog followed by some other
secondary keywords like sugar-free ice
cream making or how to make sugar-free
ice cream or low sugar ice cream as
their secondary keywords also there is a
setting to get the relevant keyword
ideas as per the location so here it is
India so you can choose a location
as per any country say this is China
you can choose for China as well
like here if you added China
there's a
okay so you will get the relevant result
as per China and India if you are not
selecting any of the country then we
will be targeting all the countries in
the world for that particular keyword
now let's take another example to find
now let's search for best
jogging shoes
so let's see all the relevant ideas what
the planners suggests
so yes we got here best jogging shoes
maybe most of the audiences adding this
query to get the results so the
competition is quite High
in this case we can we can just select
the best jogging shoes and if you want
more specific then we can go with best
jogging shoes for men or women also I
would like to bring it to you notice
that please remember to choose the
relevant keywords as per your
requirement
there will be lots of results which
won't be uh so relevant to your topic or
to your content
so make sure you're choosing the correct
keyword as per your content
after taking this keyword idea as best
joking shoes you can just create a very
good content uh either it may be a blog
or an article or a video
or a website content a text for the
website or anything you want to create
for best jogging shoes and make sure
that you are adding the this keyword
inside your content to make it more
accurate for the search engines
now next we move towards our another
keyword research tool which is Google
Trends
so go to google.com
and search for
Google
trends
okay so we are here
so uh just to remind you Google Trend
will provide us with all the trending
topics or trending Search terms which
can lead to a better ranking or instant
spike in your traffic so suppose you're
looking for the latest Trend in your
industry
in that case
let's take again take an example of a
sugar-free ice cream so I'll add here
sugar
free
ice cream okay I I just got the term in
the recommendations
it is from the food industry so just to
bring it to your notice from here we can
select the worldwide or any country
whatever we want to select or check for
this search query
then again we have a data for whatever
time duration we want the data for
that's a particular search query
here we have a number of categories like
food industry entertainment etc etc
if you want to select you can just
choose it for now I'm not choosing here
anything and of course the web search
the image search new search Google and
YouTube search so let's see let's select
Here YouTube search
and let's let's select here worldwide
so here we can get the insights
uh the interest over the time
so if you see here from
June 12th
to 19 June there was a certain drop in
this keyword people were not searching
this keyword and again from 19 to 25
there is an increase in this keyword
like people are more searching for this
keyword again you can see here the data
like interest by region so it is mostly
search in Australia
Then followed by Canada Pakistan United
States United Kingdom Etc
and it also suggests you other related
queries here
now suppose we want to compare it to
another search term say
ice cream
maker let's see
the comparison between these two
search queries
okay
so if you can see here
from
July
this keyword ice cream maker is showing
a consistent small growth
whereas
the sugar-free ice cream is
very much consistent there is not growth
or not much drop both the graphs are
showing us these insights
so I hope you got a good knowledge about
Google Trends
how to use Google Trends so let's see
how to get some of the competitor
keywords
so for this we will go to sem Rush
so here we are
to a CM Rush tool so sem Rush is a
all-in-one platform which satisfies all
the basic needs of search engine
optimization practices we get a lot of
like keyword research tool is there
competitor analysis tools is there then
we can identify the backlinks the
content Gap the backlink gaps and a lot
of like an organic traffic for your
website and many more so please do check
out uh sem rush you can find the link in
the description box below and also it
has a free as well as paid version some
of the searches are free after which you
can check on with the paid plans also so
we highly recommend you to take a walk
through through this tool now let's go
to
the keyword Gap
from here you can get the ideas about
you
and your competitor
so suppose
I'm adding here
okay let's select the country region
here
and we are doing for
we were using for the ice cream so let's
let's take
a mole company
which is a mole.com
okay
dot com
and uh
another
can be
mother
Theory ice cream
it's www.motherdary.com
so www dot mother
dairy.com
okay so let's do the check for India
only let's not
put it for USA
compare
okay so here you can see a lot of
opportunities
keyword overlap
there are almost 1.7 K like 1700 shared
keywords
you can see the search volumes as well
and all the related data for both the
companies their products
and comparison
for
Mother Dairy and amul
so here I'm using a free plan for sem
rush so I won't be able to show the
complete report here
but yes definitely we can export the all
the related data from the competitor
analysis
let's check for mobile
yes you can see here the large
difference between the overlap keywords
you can also get the data for the
organic keywords paid keywords
mainly those keywords which are used for
advertising purposes
you can change the date here
and all the data to get whatever kind of
results or data or insights you want
I hope now you have mastered the keyword
research techniques let us now see how
keyword research is important as a job
role
now coming to the job opportunities
keyword research is the most important
part of any role in search engine
optimization or digital marketing the
job descriptions in SEO and digital
marketing are likely to include keyword
research under the job requirements like
performing keyword research including
Discovery and expansion of keyword
opportunities or
perform keyword research in coordination
with client business objectives to
optimize existing content and discover
new opportunities or to conduct keyword
research using various tools
following is the basic template for the
job description for SEO analyst
here you can see the first job
responsibility is to perform keyword
research using various keyword research
tools like Keyword Planner so this
itself suggests that how keyword
research is very much important in
search engine optimization or digital
marketing jobs
here are some of the companies which are
hiring for SEO profiles so the companies
includes Microsoft Disney Siemens
udemy Deloitte
Etc however every online business
requires SEO strategies to grow and so
the company is hiring for SEO profiles
are not restricted to these five
companies so moving ahead let's see what
the future of keyword research holds
performing keyword research in a Smart
Way can bring you all the golden traffic
for your website gaining a relevant
audience is always fruitful for any
business
however it is recommended not to stay
limited to keyword research
you also need to keep an eye on how
keywords are actually performing are
they really driving the relevant traffic
if not then recheck the content and
align keywords identify the gaps and
update the content accordingly are you
tired of your website which is buried on
the 10th page of Google search want to
improve your online visibility and
attract more traffic to your website
look no further than SEO by optimizing
your website and online content for SEO
you can improve your search engine
rankings and drive more organic traffic
to your site SEO is not just a buzzword
it is a powerful tool that can help the
business of all sizes and industries
thrive in the competitive Online
Marketplace so if you want to stand out
from the crowd and reach your target
audience it's the time to invest in SEO
and watch your website so to the top of
the search results
as all the online businesses needs SEO a
lot of SEO jobs are flooded in the
market naming a few SEO manager SEO
Specialists are the sum of the
well-known profiles under SEO according
to the data from Glassdoor and pay scale
the average base pay for the SEO manager
in United States is around dollar 76 000
per year however the salaries can range
as low as dollar forty three thousand to
as high as dollar one lakh 20 000 per
year in India the average base pay of an
SEO manager is around 6 lakhs per year
INR however salaries can range from 2
lakh 50 000 inrs to as high as 18 lakhs
per year so if you are looking to grab
such a golden opportunity then you
should definitely look a professional
certificate program in digital marketing
some key features of the program include
master classes by Purdue ask me anything
sessions industry projects and more you
will be benefited from the in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research web management
and optimization URL management keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below listen
to what millions of users are saying
about our courses find simply learned
course reviews Link in the description
box so without any further Ado here is a
question for you what is the purpose of
SEO Option 1 to drive organic traffic
option 2 improving online visibility
option 3 improve search engine rankings
option for all of the above let us know
your answers in the comment section
below and get a heart from Simply learn
also don't forget to subscribe simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from simply learn let's
not procrastinate any longer and see
what we have for you in this video
we will Begin by understanding what are
the different types of SEO followed by
what is off-page SEO the difference
between on page and off-page SEO
importance of of page SEO we will put a
light on link and non-link related of
page SEO factors followed by top 5 of
page optimization techniques also by the
end of this video you will know top 10
best off-page optimization tools and see
the jobs and salaries of this stream so
let's begin with the types of SEO there
are three types of SEO namely on page
SEO of page SEO and Technical SEO so
let's start with on-page seo on-page seo
refers to the optimizing individual
Pages or web pages to improve their
search engine rankings and drive more
traffic to a website this includes
optimizing elements such as title tags
meta descriptions heading content
interlinking and website structure the
next we have is off-page SEO of speech
SEO refers to optimizing a website's
external factors that affects its search
engine rankings such as link building
social media and brand mentions the goal
of off-page SEO is to increase the
authority and relevance of the website
thereby improving its search engine
ranking the next we have is technical
SEO refers to optimizing a website's
technical aspects to improve search
engine ranking this includes optimizing
elements such as website speed mobile
responsiveness site architecture and
structured data technical SEO is
critical for ensuring that search
engines can crawl and index your website
effectively we have already covered some
on-page optimization practices in our
earlier videos in this video we will be
focusing majorly on the off-page
optimization techniques or off-page SEO
so let's understand what is off-page SEO
of page SEO refers to the optimization
of external factors that can affect a
website's search engine ranking but not
directly related to content or structure
of website itself this includes building
high quality backlinks to the website
from the reputable ones engaging your
audience on social media platforms
building your own Brands online
reputation through mentions and reviews
of page SEO is essential for
establishing a website's Authority and
relevance in search engine rankings
search engines use backlinks and other
off-beat signals to determine the
credibility and popularity of website
which in turn can impact its search
engine rankings a strong off-page SEO
strategy can help a website to attract
more organic traffic traffic improve in
search engine ranking and ultimately
increase its visibility and online
repetition now let's understand the
difference between on-page and off-page
SEO the main difference between on-page
and off-page SEO is that on page SEO
involves optimizing the elements on the
website's individual Pages while of page
SEO focuses on optimizing external
factors that can impact a website's
search engine ranking optimizing
elements on website in on-page SEO
includes optimization of title tags meta
descriptions headings content images and
interlinking this improves the relevance
and understandability of websites pages
for search engine however the external
factor in off-page SEO includes link
building social media engagement and
online repetition management so let's
see why off-page SEO is important
off-page SEO is important for improving
the search engine ranking of a website
by establishing its Authority and
relevance search engines use external
factors such as backlinks social media
engagement
influencer Outreach and online
repetition management to determine the
credibility and popularity of a website
getting backlinks from another reputable
websites are critical factor in off-page
SEO as the signals to search engines
that the content on the linked website
is valuable and relevant brand awareness
can be increased with the help of social
media engagement influencer Outreach and
online repetition management so with a
glimpse of its importance let's move
ahead link and non-link related off-page
SEO factors link related factors has a
complete control over the links of the
off-page optimization here are few link
related factors that can affect your
website number and quality of external
links pointing to a website anchor text
used in the external link relevancy of
external link to the content of the
linked website freshness of the external
links diversity of the external links
from different domains Authority and
trustworthiness of the domains linking
to the website non-link related factors
have control over everything else other
than the link a few non-link related
off-page factors includes social media
engagement and activity online
repetition management including reviews
and ratings on directories and review
websites brand mentions and citations on
other websites even if not linked
influencer Outreach and partnership
local SEO strategies such as optimizing
Google my business listings and local
directories content marketing efforts
including guest blogging and sharing
content on social media platforms
anyways we are going to cover many of
them in the upcoming part of the video
now that we have gained enough
understanding of what is off-page SEO
let's discuss top 5 of page optimization
tips so starting with the tip number one
link building
one of the most important of beach SEO
techniques is link building which
involves acquiring high quality
backlinks from the authoritative and
relevant websites this can done through
guest blogging broken link building
influencer Outreach and other link
building techniques the next tip we have
is social media engagement social media
platforms provide a valuable opportunity
to engage with target audience and build
brand awareness
by creating and sharing high quality
content on the social media platform
businesses can increase their online
visibility and improve their search
engine ranking towards the next tip
which is online repetition management
online repetition management involves
monitoring and managing a business's
online repetition by responding to
reviews engaging with customers and
monitoring mentions of the business
online by maintaining a positive online
repetition businesses can improve their
search engine rankings and attract more
customers moving towards the next tip
which is local SEO optimization
local SEO techniques such as optimizing
Google my business listings building
local citations and participating in
local directories can help businesses to
rank higher in local search results next
and the last tip that we have is content
marketing
content marketing involves creating and
sharing valuable content and relevant
content such as blog posts infographics
and videos by creating high quality
content businesses can attract backlinks
social shares and other forms of
Engagement that can improve the search
engine rankings over time now that we
have understood how off-page
optimization can be done effectively
with these five tips let's now move
ahead with this video to know some
helpful tools for off-page SEO so here
is the list of some helpful tools you
may require during off-page SEO
practices so let's see all the tools in
short one by one let's start by knowing
most most is an all-in-one SEO tool that
can help businesses with keyword
research link building online repetition
management and much more it provides a
range of features for tracking rankings
analyzing backlinks and improving
website performance the next tool we
have is majestic Majestic is a link
building tool that provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics it may use to identify New
Link building opportunities and monitor
competitor backlinks next we have is
ahrefs ahrefs is a powerful SEO tool
that can help with link building and
competitor analysis it provides
comprehensive backlink data and other
SEO metrics that can be used to identify
New Link building opportunities next
tool we have in the list is semrush or
formally known as sem Rush semrush is an
all-in-one SEO tool that can help with
keyword research backlink analysis and
social media engagement it provides
valuable insights into websites off-page
SEO performance and can help businesses
to optimize their online presence the
next we have is ninja Outreach ninja
Outreach is a tool that can help
businesses with influencer Outreach and
link building it provides a range of
features for finding influencer in any
Niche managing Outreach campaigns and
tracking results next tool in the list
is pitch box pitch box is a link
building and influencer Outreach tool
that can help businesses with
personalized Outreach campaigns it
provides a range of features for finding
link building opportunities managing
relationships with website owners and
tracking performance to the next tool
which is Buzz stream bus stream is a
link building tool that can help
businesses streamline their Outreach
efforts and manage the relationships
with influencer and other website owners
it provides a range of features for
managing link building campaigns
tracking progress and monitoring
performance the next tool we have is
Google Alerts Google Alerts is a free
tool that can be used to monitor
mentions of a business or brand online
by setting up alerts for Relevant
keywords businesses can stay on the top
of their online repetition and address
any negative comments or reviews in the
timely manner next tool we have is
hootsu HootSuite is a social media
management tool that can help businesses
to manage and schedule their social
media content across multiple platforms
it provides valuable insight into the
social media engagement and can help
businesses to improve their overall
social media strategy and coming to the
last tool in the list is mention mention
is an online repetition management tool
that can help businesses to monitor
their online mentions across social
media new sites and other platforms it
provides real-time alerts and advanced
analytics to help businesses manage
their online repetition so they these
are just a few examples of many off-page
SEO tools available depending on your
specific needs and goals there may be
other tools that are better and suited
to your business now that you know the
roadmap to become a successful Optimizer
these are just a few examples of many
off-page SEO tools available depending
on your specific needs and goals there
may be other tools that are better
suited for your business now that you
know the roadmap to become a successful
Optimizer let's have a look at the jobs
and salaries for off-page optimization
roles off-page SEO jobs can vary
depending on the company industry and
location some common job titles in this
Fields include link building specialist
SEO Outreach coordinator digital
marketing specialist and content
marketing manager salaries of off-page
SEO jobs are widely depending on the
factor us such as experience job title
location and the company size in general
the entry-level positions may start
around 1.35
000 to Dollar forty five thousand per
year while more senior roles such as SEO
manager or director of digital marketing
can earn up to dollar one lakh per year
as in U.S however in India the salaries
of off-page SEO jobs may vary the
entry-level positions in off-page SEO
may start around 2.5 to 4 lakhs per year
in Indian currency INR while more senior
roles such as SEO manager and director
of digital marketing can earn up to 10
lakhs INR per year or even more
concludingly off-page SEO is an
essential component of any successful
digital marketing strategy by building a
strong online repetition and acquiring
high quality backlinks from alternative
websites business can improve their
search engine rankings drive more
organic traffic to their website and
ultimately increase their revenue with
the help of effective off-page SEO
techniques and tools business can stay
ahead of the competition and achieve a
long-term success in the Online
Marketplace with the help of effective
off-page SEO techniques and tools
businesses can stay ahead of the
competition and Achieve long-term
success in the Online Marketplace if you
are interested in pursuing a career in
SEO then simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below every online business isn't the
race to grab the first position in the
search results and hold on to it as far
as possible
to rank higher there are several factors
that we need to consider like
having unique content for audiences
having SEO optimized website
having large number of backlinks
and a good social media presence
in this video we will focus on what
backlinks are what make backlinks an
important ranking Factor moving ahead we
will understand do follow and no follow
back links
attention when we start with white hat
and black hat links
moving forward we will understand how to
build backlinks for your website and
finally we will check backlinks building
tools and future of backlinks
before diving deep into the topic
consider subscribing to our Channel and
press the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn
so let me demonstrate you how this video
will prove a game changer for your
online business
let's go to google.com
how to make pizza
so here you can see there are number of
results
uh these type of results are called red
Snippets and Below you'll get the list
of top 10 search results
on the first page of the serps
so here we are we are going to find the
backlinks for the first and the last
result
so let's copy the link
open it in the new tab
and
copy the link and now we'll go to rf's
backlink Checker
just to add to your information rf's
backlink Checker is a free backing
Checker tool
now here we will be adding the URL
and check backlinks
so here you can see there are 288
backlinks with the 22 percent of do
follow links we are going to learn the
do follow and no follow links in the
coming part of the video so stay tuned
now let's check the backlinks for the
last search result
which is
kill
we'll open the link and
copy the link here
go to rf's Checker
and add the URL and again the same
procedure
so okay so here we can find that number
of backlinks are more as compared to
previous one here there are 346
backlinks with six percent of do follow
links so now there is a question that
though there are there is uh more
backlinks in the last result why it's
not why it's ranking to the last
position so here is the answer that
having more number of backlink is
definitely a ranking Factor but the
backlink should be do follow links
if you have more number of do follow
links then it is more likely to result
high on the search results as compared
to
less number of do follow links that's
why the last that's why here you can see
that this link is at the last of the
search result
whereas this one is at the first
Okay so
now again
let's search for best
jogging
shoes
okay we are not taking the ads we will
check for the organic results which I
hear
so let's click on the first result
copy the link
and go to rf's backlink Checker
add your url and check for backlinks
meanwhile we'll go and check for the
last result
okay this this one is the last
copy the link
go to rf's backlink Checker
and enter the URL
check back links
okay
so here you can see a huge difference
the first first result is having
3395 with 94 of do follow links
but as the last result is having only
183 backlinks with only two percent of
do follow links definitely to rank
higher there are several factors and
backlinks are one of them let's
understand what backlinks are when a web
page receives a hyperlink from another
website it is known as a backlink a
backlink is also known as inbound links
let's understand this more clearly
this is an article on best pizza company
it has a list of pizzas mentioned
here you can see a link attached to each
company
when you click on the link it opens the
website or the company's home page here
the company's home page gets one
backlink from the website on which
article is present
now as we are familiar with what
backlinks are let's understand what make
backlinks an important ranking Factor
when a web page receives more and more
backlinks
this helps search engine understand that
your web pages content is valuable which
makes other websites to link to You
thereby gaining their trust
as search engines loves the unique and
valuable content they consider it to
rank high in the search results
this makes backlinks an important factor
and a symbol of trust as well
however it is not necessary that if you
get lots of backlinks that means you
will rank high for sure
you will rank high only when you get
high quality backlinks
backlinks are said to be high quality
when link juice or authority from one
website is passed to another
and to understand this there is a need
for proper understanding of no follow
and do follow links a website can link
to your page either by do follow
or by no follow links do follow links
are beneficial in terms of SEO when a
website links back to your site by do
follow link it passes The Authority or
the link juice
of their website to yours
this helps to improve the authority of
your website thereby positively
affecting the ranking
coming to no follow links these links do
not pass Authority or link juice to your
website therefore these are not
beneficial in terms of SEO however even
though it directly does not affect the
ranking of your website still no follow
links are good for driving user traffic
from one website to another
now that we have gained knowledge about
do follow and no follow links I would
like to bring your attention to some of
the practices followed by optimizers to
get the backlinks
white hat and black hat techniques to
get backlinks optimizers mostly follow
white hat or black hat techniques
the white hat technique helps to gain
backlinks under search engine guidelines
talking about black hat techniques this
involves spamming methods of gaining
backlinks and one can get penalized by
search engines if search engines detect
the black hat methods so on a serious
note we recommend you to follow white
hat techniques strictly
so without taking a minute let's start
understanding the methods of how to
build backlinks
here we go with our first technique
which is skyscraper technique
this technique is originally said to be
found by Brian Dean the founder of
backlinko publishing a skyscraper
content can help you to bring backlink
from high Authority sites for this you
need to do the basic research and find
the content that is doing well in your
industry
once you find the content create a
better version of this content with
additional unique information
now all you need is to promote your
content
then you can reach out to experts with
similar interest and ask them to add the
URL of your content which will be an
add-on to their existing content
and that's it
another method of building backlinks is
publishing detail guides
detail guides are the form of longer
content studies say that longer contents
tends to gain more backlinks
however remember that publishing longer
content will work only if the content is
unique and informative getting to know
about broken link building
all you need to do is find the
informative Pages which are relevant to
your industry on the web that have
deadlinks or 404 pages
four not four pages have a negative
impact on search engines
if you have relevant content that could
replace this 4 naught per page
do reach out to the owner of the content
and have a humble ask
to replace the dead link with your
content definitely it's difficult but
yes this technique really works
next we can get backlinks by finding
listicles
to add plus to your knowledge listicles
are a piece of writings that has list
included in them
all you need to do is find the content
which has list of relevant topics now
check if it includes your site also if
not you can ask the owner of the content
to include your site with a brief
description of how it is helpful and
relevant to the existing content now
let's talk about another technique
helpful in gaining backlinks which is
guest blogging guest blogging is a
simple and easy way to earn backlinks
first you need to identify blogging site
with high domain Authority
create a blog post relevant to your
industry
with the links of your site and add this
post to the blogging site
do not add too many links as they will
appear spammy in the eyes of search
engines which may prove harmful to your
site
next we move towards
another technique which is link Gap
building
link Gap analysis is the quickest way
from which one can easily discover the
link building opportunities
by carrying out link Gap analysis you
can find the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
so suppose if you find a website that
links to more than one of your
competitors their chances of linking to
you increases as we have seen some of
the effective backlink building methods
now let's see some tools you will need
for building backlinks using the above
methods here we go with our post tool
helpful in backlink building which is
sem rush it is helpful and competitor
analysis and finding link gaps it has
free as well as paid version
next we have RFS
link intersect feature helps to get the
reports on the sites that link to your
competitors but not you
this feature comes under the paid
version
upcoming tool is another interesting
tool which is helpful in building
backlinks which is group High
it helps you to get bloggers reach
this tool is a paid tool
next we have Hunter dot IO
it is an email address finder that helps
you to get email addresses of people
from a particular domain or even their
personal IDs it has free as well as paid
versions
we have learned almost all the aspects
of backlink building now let's have a
quick look at what is in the future of
backlinks backlinks are one of the most
important factors in search engine
ranking as it shows the trust of one
site into another
gaining high quality backlink makes the
search engines understand that the
content on your website is valuable
thereby making it eligible for higher
rankings however due to spammy methods
backlinks are the factor that can be
easily manipulated
as we know that search engine algorithms
are continuously updated backlinks will
continue to be an important ranking
Factor but the unique content and
user-centric content will be more valued
if you are interested in pursuing a
career in SEO then simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you are looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below SEO and growth of businesses are
going hand in hand these days anyone
looking for good growth in their
business tries to grab the attention of
the audiences with the similar interest
on the web for which SEO plays an
important role SEO techniques are
equally impactful for a Google website
or an Instagram post more your content
reaches the Right audience the more
likely you are to get the leads and make
business out of it because of this SEO
experts are in high demand in this video
on how to become an SEO expert we will
share the best tips to become an SEO
expert in a very short period of time
but before we begin consider subscribing
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so here is a question for you when was
SEO first used Option 1 in 1980s option
2 in 1970s option 3 in 1990s and option
4 into 2010s let us know your answer in
the comment section below and if your
answer is correct you will get a heart
from Simply learn so without any further
Ado let's start by understanding what
Market holds for professional SEO
experts nowadays it is very common to
start a business by having a website
with the increase of website there is
always a need of organic growth and
there the SEO comes into picture
it is important to have an SEO expert to
have a well SEO optimized website Market
is flourished with a ton of SEO jobs
from SEO executive to SEO manager all
the SEO job roles have high demand the
salary for various SEO roles is
estimated to reach as high as hundred
thousand dollars giants like coin switch
eBay havelet Packard in the industries
are ready to hire the candidates having
SEO expertise so without taking a minute
let's start with the pro tips on how to
become an SEO expert number one is
understanding the basics of content
creation and content optimization as it
is said content is the king to be an SEO
expert you need to be the best in
content creation search engines value
high quality content and promote it to
be on the top of search results creating
high quality content should be the
must-have quality of an SEO EXP word
although this is not enough once you
create a good content it is necessary
for the content to be well optimized you
should have a great content strategies
to spread the content among the Right
audience let's move to our tip number
two understanding SEO basics
it's really important to understand the
basics to make the right decisions
having technical knowledge of SEO May
prevent you from making mistakes that
may harm your business directly or
indirectly say having right knowledge on
how on-page optimization Works will help
you to optimize your content or web
pages more efficiently thereby allowing
your content or web pages to rank higher
in search result page moving towards our
next tip which is how search engine
works
search engines are responsible for
listing the user search queries due to
which it becomes easier for search
engines to identify the content and
display the relevant results
search engines work on three basic steps
crawling indexing and ranking crawling
also known as web crawling involves
search engine Bots to crawl your web
content and pick up the hints or showing
what the web page is about with these
hints or here we can say important
keywords search engine Bots indexes your
web content into the web index once your
page is indexed it gets easily eligible
to appear in the search results if a
user enters the query and your content
matches the query it appears in the
search results moreover if your content
is really unique then you never know it
can also rank on the first position come
into a tip number four
understanding and implementation of
technical aspects of SEO before moving
into this domain one should be aware of
technical aspects of SEO you should have
a good understanding on how a website
should actually be is the website
structure easy to understand if not then
how one can make it easy website
structure plays an important role for
search engine Bots if search engine Bots
find that the website is not easily
crawlable they will leave your website
and thus you may face a heavy loss in
indexing your pages it is considered to
be a good practice to submit sitemaps to
search engines some other technical
factors include having a less page load
speed meaningful page links having the
keyword with the page targets having
node dead or 40 pages and more let's Now
understand why one should have a good
knowledge of Google analytics and Google
Google search console tools to be an SEO
expert Google analytics and search
console Google analytics is a web
analytics service offered by Google
it was launched by Google back in 2005.
Google analytics generates various type
of reports and helps track bounce rates
identify the best content for your
website record user Behavior flow on
your site and many other mattresses
thereby allowing you to understand and
build your business strategies thereby
growing your business now that we have
understood why Google analytics is
essential let's understand about Google
search console
search console priorly known as Google
webmaster tool monitors the
technicalities of the website so suppose
your website is not visible in search
results so there is a possibility that
search engine crawlers are unable to
crawl your website thus it is not
visible in search results to make
crawlers crawl your website you need to
optimize your website using search
console some other technical aspects
which makes search console more
important includes fixing indexing
problems sending the updated content or
Pages for re-indexing generating page
error reports generating alerts if there
are any indexing or other issues gets
the list of sites linking to your
website keep a track of mobile usability
amp pages and more some other tools
helpful in SEO are screaming frog which
works similar to search engine board sem
Rush is used for competitor analysis RFS
is used for backlink report generation
and more so let us know in the comment
section below out of the above tools
which one you are using for optimizing
your content so moving ahead with the
next Pro tip which is link building link
building helps in getting traffic as
well as trust in the eyes of search
engines getting backlink is one of the
important ranking factors thus getting
more and more backlinks helps the search
engines to understand that the quality
of your content is high and so other
websites are linking to your page which
also helps in getting more traffic and
high rankings having great link building
strategies will boost your career as an
SEO expert if you are not aware of
backlink building strategies watch
videos on how to build backlink by
simply learn you can find the link in
the description box below moving to the
tip number seven follow other SEO
experts for their strategies and stay
connected with SEO forum for recent
updates and discussions
search engines are continuously changing
so it is possible that the things that
are working now won't be working for
your web pages the next day thus it is
important to stay updated with what's
new with search engines following
experts under the same domain helps in
growth of skills so the question arises
how or where can you find these experts
well look for the SEO communities of
Google you can join various SEO Forums
on LinkedIn groups on Facebooks and
other q a and social media platforms
this not only helps in growth of skills
but it also keeps you updated with the
industry now speaking about another Pro
tip for being an excellent SEO
professional which is joining courses to
improve SEO skills there is a lot of
content developing each day on SEO and
so are the courses if you fail to
understand the SEO techniques or any
other SEO related topics by the research
there are a lot lots of free and paid
courses available across the web
certifications in any domain is always a
plus point for the career SEO techniques
may not be that fruitful at the very
first time all you need to do is have
patience observe what works for your
content and what doesn't learn from your
observations find new ways to put the
improved strategies on the table so that
you get the best out of your SEO
practices if you are interested in
pursuing a career in SEO then simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below let's talk then now about how the
Google algorithms work so we'll shift
gears here and we'll talk about how
these algorithms work on Google so
Google uses advanced concepts retrieve
data so what they do is they're
spidering they're spidering they're
collecting web pages and they're taking
all these web pages back to their server
and anytime somebody does a query
they're delivering those web pages
within milliseconds they're delivering
results based on your query so that's in
general how it works so it uses a
combination of different algorithms to
deliver the best results they want the
best results and so some of the most
popular algorithms below are Google
Panda Google penguin and Google rank
brain so these are all things that
Google has done to make sure that
they're constantly tweaking their search
engines to deliver the best results so
let's talk about some of these these
popular algorithms and before we talk
about these popular algorithms so let's
just make one thing clear that Google's
always tweaking their algorithms on
their search engine and so if you want
to get an idea how often they do it well
they do it every day you're constantly
tweaking it but what they do is they
release major changes to their algorithm
a few times a year so if you want to get
a sense of what those changes look like
well you could go to moz.com and you can
go to Google Dash algorithm Dash change
and you can see here that hey Google
changes its search algorithm around 500
to 600 times while most of these are
minor Google again rolls out major
changes like Panda like penguin that
affects search results in significant
ways so you can go here and you can go
all the way back to 2000 and see some of
the algorithm changes that have occurred
over the last few years and you can see
here the last major one was done in
August of of 2018 that was the medic
core update so they're constantly making
changes to their search engine to
deliver a more concise more better
ecosystem for the end user so if it's a
better search engine for the end user
end users are going to come back so the
whole idea is continuing to tweak the
system that the algorithms to better
show more accurate results and so let's
take a look at some of the the major
algorithm changes that they've done in
the past so the first is we'll talk
about Google Panda and Panda was an
algorithm that released back in 2011. so
here we are in 2019 is a few years ago
but still significant in that really
this algorithm emphasized high quality
content because before Panda there was a
there's just a lot of content out there
on the internet and there was a lot of
spam content there are a lot of
duplicate content and so really the idea
behind panda is for Google to really
deliver in their search engine results
Pages high quality content so what it
did was it removed web pages that had
low quality or duplicate content so that
was the whole idea behind you know the
algorithm nickname Panda it removed low
quality and duplicate content and that
kind of cleaned things up a bit where if
you did a search query now you'd
actually see a better better results and
one thing about panda is because there's
so much quality because Google's
indexing so much there on the internet
that it's constantly being updated it's
updated regularly so the next one we're
going to talk about is Google penguin so
penguin was released after Panda and
with that focused in on was low quality
links so remember we talked about link
building we talked about quality links
over quantity so naturally you're going
to have links naturally from all website
sites whether they be high quality or
low quality the whole idea behind this
algorithm is to sever the lengths that
are low quality and so the idea behind
that was they focused on two areas so
they focused in on Links games and
keyword stuffing so that's what penguin
focused on was Lynx games were basically
link almost link farming where you
produced Mass amounts of backlinks and
not all of them were good quality they
weren't natural links links should be
natural from one high quality site or
blog to another high quality cider blog
and by creating lengths games you've
created an ecosystem where links just
went to irrelevant low quality spam
related pages and so Google's Penguins
algorithm update focused in on that
effort to remove or combat pages that
had poor links from being indexed in
their search engine results and then
they also combated keyword stuffing
keyword stuffing is is nothing more than
taking your targeted keyword and
stuffing it into the content of your
page your title tag your meta
description so any sites that were
caught up doing that basically suffer
the consequences because what penguin
did was take care of sites that
basically were accused of keyword
stuffing or had characteristics of
keyword stuffing and they removed sites
that had a lot of links pointing to it
from poor quality sites and vice versa
sites that really had a lot of external
links pointing to other poor quality
sites so that's what penguin did they
took a look at those two areas and so we
talk about link schemes again penguin's
aim was to decrease the ranking of web
pages that created artificially by using
black hat techniques and basically what
I mean by black hat techniques that
artificially creating length that just
didn't make sense just for the sake of
getting the backlink just for the sake
of passing link juice and so that's what
a link game is or was and so Google
basically tweaked their algorithm to
combat those poor link schemes and so
keyword stuffing as I mentioned a minute
ago it's just repetitive usage of the
same keyword and that just basically
suffers the content is the thing that
suffers here and when the content
suffers the end users suffer so Google
is all about quality content and when
you have quality content and that
quality contents indexed and users find
what they're looking for chances are
they're going to go back to the search
engine to continue to find what they're
looking for with the end result being
presented with quality content so
keyword stuffing really dilutes the
quality of the content and then let's
talk about the third algorithm which is
rank brain so rank brain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning and
what that does that machine learning
interprets search queries that users
search on Google so for example well if
rank brain sees a word or phrase that
isn't familiar with basically the
machine can make a guess as to what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning and filter the result
accordingly so basically take these
search engine queries and present them
in a way that's logical so that the end
result can be something that's relevant
to what you're looking for and so for
example if you're searching for online
marketing you will get results related
for digital marketing on search engine
Pages why because rankbrain will
interpret that particular keyword and
they're trying to basically match based
on all the data they collected what
words or phrases might have a similar
meaning so online marketing digital
marketing have similar meaning if you're
interested in
digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below
have you ever wondered what will happen
if the
if the site are not visible in the
search engines
definitely this can be the most scary
thought you ever had
but due to lack of technical knowledge
this is happening in the real world with
the newbies in the SEO industry
well for these beginners this video is
the opportunity and the solution to your
problems
to get your pages searched and appear in
Google search results
it is important that these pages
are indexed in Google
and to get the web pages indexed Google
search console or search console is the
One-Stop solution
Google search console formerly known as
Google webmaster tool is a web service
provided by Google Developers
Google search console is mainly
responsible for optimizing a website for
its visibility
indexing website
detecting crawl errors
Etc
after understanding what is Google
search console
now we need to focus on why search
console is an important part of search
engine optimization
a website's technicalities are directly
or indirectly related to search control
consider you have created a website for
your business
but from past few weeks your website is
not visible in search result Pages here
search console comes into action
there is a possibility that searched
engine crawlers are not able to crawl
your website thus it is not visible in
the search result pages
to make crawlers crawl your website you
will need to optimize your website using
search console
some other technical aspects of search
console includes
fixing indexing problems
sending the updated content or Pages for
indexing generating search traffic
reports generating alerts if there are
any issues related to indexing or any
other issue gets the list of sites
linking to your website keep the track
of mobile usability
amp pages
and more
so now it is the right time to
understand how search console works
but before we begin this topic have a
look at the range of courses of digital
marketing and search engine optimization
from skill up by simply learn you can
get the link in the description box
below so now I have a question for you
what will you do at first
if your web page fails to appear in
search result pages well let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below
stay tuned with this video Even though
if you don't have the answer right now
by the end of this video you will surely
able to answer this question so let's
get started by knowing how search
console works
understand the working of search console
it is necessary to have a detailed
knowledge about how search engine works
search engines mainly Works in three
steps crawling indexing and ranking
let's have a look at each step one by
one
so first let's start with crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send Web spiders or web
crawlers also known as robots or search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content
content can be an image a web page a
video or anything else present on the
web this process is known as crawling
now let's know about indexing
as soon as the crawler discover the
updated content or new content these web
crawlers start storing the URLs of the
content into the search index or web
index this process is known as indexing
once the content is indexed it starts
appearing in the search result pages
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant results are taken from the
index
and displayed in the form of most
relevant to least relevant in the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking now that we have gained
knowledge about how search engine works
here I have a question for you
choose the correct option with respect
to working of search engines
you need to choose the option for all
the steps of how search engines work
option A indexing crawling ranking
option b ranking indexing crawling
option C crawling indexing ranking and
option D crawling ranking and indexing
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
now let's get started by learning how
search console actually works
search console is a primary source of
information that helps search engine
Bots to crawl index and rank the pages
of your website
thereby allowing the website owners to
monitor the health of your website
all you need to do is integrate search
console with your website and get the
ownership
allow the search engine Bots to crawl
your website and index the pages also
don't forget to submit your website
sitemap to search engines submitting
sitemaps helps the crawler to discover
more pages of your website
thereby understanding your site's
architecture
we will know how it is done in the
upcoming part of the video
also you need to keep an eye on the
errors suggested by search console and
solve them else it may harm the ranking
of your website
now let me remind you that all the
reports that are generated in search
console are based on the activity of the
web Crawlers on your website now let's
understand various parameters and
terminologies from search console
to get a complete understanding of this
webmaster tool
so without any further delay let's start
understanding the basic terminologies of
Google search console and how they work
and improve your website's Health
the first one we have is performance
reports
Google search console provides two types
of performance report search reports and
discover reports
let's first understand about search
reports
search reports help to analyze the
search performance of your website
search performance reports include
metrics and dimensions
so let's first focus on metrics
here there are four types of metrics as
you can see in this image
the metrics include the total clicks or
I must say clicks Impressions average
CTR and average position
Impressions provides the data on how
many times your websites appears in the
search results
as you can see here the graph shows the
number of times this website has
appeared in the search results the next
metric we have is clicks
clicks provide the data on the total
number of times users clicked from the
search results and reached your website
the graph below shows the number of
times the users have clicked from search
results and they have arrived on the any
page of my website so suppose if here is
a number 200 so we can definitely get an
idea
for very number of dates number of dates
provided on the x-axis which shows that
how many times the user has clicked and
arrived on the website and the number
where is varies from between like 200
200 uh 250 300 and in between 250 to
300.
and the next metric we have is average
CTR average CTR or click-through rate is
the percentage of Impressions that
results in clicks in the same manner the
graph below shows or the average CTR for
various different dates
the next metric we have is average
position the average position represents
the data about the average position of
the sites in the search results
it is possible that your website is
ranking today at number one position so
it may rank tomorrow at 3 some other day
at four some other day at 9 or 10 and
again it may rank to the one so this
data actually provides the detail about
the average position which your website
frequently ranks at so that is if it is
ranking at one two and three in between
one two and three positions so the
average position may be two
now understanding about the dimensions
dimensions are the data attribute that
defines who did something on your site
or from where
is the list of dimensions on which the
dimension performance reports are
generated that is
the countries Pages queries devices
search appearance and dates
the dimension country suggests the
country from which the search came as
you can see here from the left column
you can get the list of number of
countries from the right side you can
get the idea about the clicks impression
ctrn position that is all the metrics
related to that query
from which the search came from or from
that location
or whatever the activity has happened
from that location next we have is the
dimensions pages
Pages show the pages clicked by user or
a page that is viewed on a search so
this this actually you get the reports
from the search consoled in the form of
the links where you get the link which
is the exact page that is viewed on the
search
if there exists duplicate pages on the
site then only one canonical page or
canonical link will be displayed by the
search engines out of the number of
duplicate pages so basically canonical
links are those links uh like if there
are suppose there is a one original page
and there are two three duplicate page
of the same page so what happens uh the
original page gains the canonical link
and this page has more value than the
duplicate pages
so whenever the search engine will crawl
your website all the duplicate pages may
be ignored and all its link juice or
link Equity or anything will be
completely taken for the original page
moving ahead to queries
queries provide the query string that
users search on the Google search
console
so Suppose there is a website it says
suppose uh let's talk about the simply
learn website so suppose a user may add
as Java course and simply learn websites
appears at second or third position so
this query
say suppose user clicks on the website
and reaches the website this query Java
course on simply learn or Java course
will add in the search console showing
that the user has reached to your
website using this query Java course and
again all the list of the queries
appears towards the left and all the
matrixes for that query like clicks
impression CTR and its average position
is appeared towards the right in the
search console now talking about the
search appearance search appearance
helps in grouping the data as per the
search result type or by the feature so
you can get here the number of search
appearance and again the same metrics as
with respect to the search appearance
criteria next let's move towards the
dates
dates groups of data as per the dates
according to the public time zones now
let's have a look over the Discover
performance report
now here you must be thinking about how
the search is different from discover
yes search and discover follow different
approaches users enter a query to find a
required information with search
whereas discover shows the content based
on what result will be best match for
your query as per the Google's automated
system
now coming to the Discover performance
report as per Google's guidelines
discover performance reports are visible
only if your website has a minimum
threshold of impressions in discover
now moving to another important
parameter of search console which is URL
inspection
URL inspection is an interesting tool in
the search console this tool allows you
to inspect whether the URL is indexable
or not
some main functions of this tool
includes
checking the current status of the URL
inspecting live URLs requesting indexing
for a URL
viewing Pages rendered version viewing
crawl Pages viewing tested Pages
Etc
in order to check the index status of
URL open the URL inspection tool
and add the complete URL
for which we need to know its indexing
status
now to understand the results check the
present status if it shows that URL is
on Google as you can see in the screen
this means that URL qualifies Google's
criteria and is eligible to appear in
search results
if it shows URL is not on Google then
the URL does not qualify the Google's
criteria and is not eligible to appear
in search results
you can check more details like URL
Discovery crawl and indexing information
from the page availability tab
click on the crawl page to see the
information about the HTTP request and
response if you find that the link is
disabled just hover over the page to
check the reason
now coming to the live URL test
it is helpful to test the live URL and
check if it is capable of being indexed
it proves helpful when you update your
page and want to compare it with its
latest indexed version just to bring it
to your notice
a life test will only confirm whether
the Google crawler can access your page
for indexing but it doesn't assure that
your page will be included in the Google
index all together with the help of
index coverage report one can find the
list of URLs which includes the URLs
Google has found on your website the
URLs that have been indexed and identify
if any indexing problem have occurred
next we move ahead to understand about
the site Maps
a site map is the file that contains all
the information of pages on your website
this helps search engine crawlers to
crawl your website and understand your
website structure and helps them to
index the pages more efficiently
more the crawler indexes your pages
higher the chances for the pages of your
website to appear in the search results
with the help of sitemaps you can
provide information about various
contents like Pages videos images
Etc as you can understand a sitemap
plays an important role in indexing
process
you must be curious to know how we can
create and submit a site map to search
engines
before we understand this process make
sure that all pages of your website are
linked in an appropriate manner with
each other thereby maintaining a healthy
site structure
the site map can be created in XML
format RSS format or in text format
it can be auto-generated or created
manually as well
most commonly used sitemap is XML
following is an example of an XML
sitemap
this is the simplest version of the site
map that we are representing here you
can submit a site map to the sitemap
reports in the search console however
sitemaps can also be submitted through
robots.txt file let's understand about
robots.txt file
so let's understand the robots.txt file
in short
robots.txt file notifies the web
Crawlers
about the URLs that they can access on
the website as there are lots of search
engines there exists different web
crawlers thus there is a possibility
that some web crawlers may not obey the
instructions from the robots.txt file it
is necessary to know how to use the
proper syntax as different crawlers
understand syntax differently
thus there are chances that some web
crawlers might fail to understand the
instructions from the robots.txt file
a page can be indexed even if it is
disallowed from the robots.txt file if
it is linked to other site
next let's know what enhancement reports
are
all the rich results status reports are
displayed under the enhancement tab
so let's know more about rich results
these type of results are known as Rich
results in serps so basically Rich
results can be any search results other
than the traditional Blue Links for
example image results carousels
Etc
you can check whether the pages from
your website support Rich results or not
using the rich result test tool provided
by Google Developers
now understanding the rich results
status report the enhancement tab
contains separate reports for Rich
result type
some rich results report types are
listed below that are breadcrumbs
education q a event FAQ fact check
guided recipe how to image license
job posting
learning video
review Snippets
Etc
Rich results status reports consist of
summary page and Details page
the summary page mainly consists of
Errors useful items found on your
website warnings
Etc The Details page consists of the
information about the issues when it was
detected item type when was the page
last crawled
Etc before we understand how to fix
error in search console it is important
to understand the status of each page as
reported by search console
each page has any of the following
status error warning excluded and valid
if the status of the page is valid it
means the page has successfully indexed
the status of the page appears to be
excluded
if one purposefully wants the page not
to be indexed
or a page is blocked by robots.txt file
for example setting the meta tag to no
index warnings majorly appears when the
page of your website is indexed
but there are some issues with the page
which need your attention and have to be
resolved as soon as possible
if the page status is error then there
is a need to pay a detailed attention
over the issues in the page as these
issues prevent the page from getting
indexed
let's discuss about the errors in detail
and how we can fix them
some popular errors from the search
console are listed below
that is the redirect error server error
submitted URLs blocked by robots.txt URL
marked as no index submitted URL is a
soft pore not for 4 Note 4 or page not
found error
so let's first know about the redirect
error
some redirect error
that search console shows up are the
redirect chain that was too long
redirect true
redirect URL that exits maximum URL
length and bat or empty URL in the
redirect chain so all these error means
that the redirections are not working
properly and so there is a need to fix
them so suppose for example you have
added too many redirects from one page
to another
so in this scenario
search engine Bots find it a waste of
time to crawl again and again to the
same redirections and at that time the
search engine crawlers or search engine
boats ignore those URLs or redirections
so in such cases you need to fix those
redirection to a single URL
the next we have is server error
the server returns 5xx error when it
fails to fulfill a valid request this
error mainly conveys that something is
wrong with your website server all you
need to do is reach out to your hosting
services and inform them about the issue
and make sure it gets resolved as soon
as possible
the next one we have is submitted URL
blocked by robots.txt to resolve this
issue you need to remove the line of
code from the robot.txt file that
restricts Google from crawling the
respective page the next we have is URL
marked as no index
when a URL is marked as no index it
sends the signal to crawlers that this
page is not meant to be crawled or this
page is not meant to be indexed if you
want this page to be indexed check the
metadata and remove the no index
attribute to allow the Crawlers to crawl
the URL now let's understand about the
error submitted URL is a soft four not
four and four not four or page not found
error whenever a web page load server
returns a 200 signal showing the success
status code soft4 Note 4 is a condition
in which server returns 200 success
status code and the page not exist error
simultaneously
this is considered to be a bad user
experience
this error can be solved simply by
redirecting this page to any relevant
URL
or the home page of the website
talking about 404 or page not found
error this error mainly occurs
when you delete the page from your
website but the URL of the page still
exists in the site map
this error can be solved by simply
removing the URL or removing the 404 URL
from the site map or redirecting the URL
to a new page
this will help to avoid the further
errors in near future
we will have a detailed look at other
4xx errors in the upcoming videos
now that we are aware of the basics of
search console let's dive deeper to know
some stats regarding the search console
in the SEO industry
when you're thinking of adding a
business online your website should
fulfill all the technical SEO needs
which can be achieved by Google search
console thus there is a huge demand in
SEO industry for the candidates having
strong knowledge of Google search
console
the average salary of an SEO expert
with the Google search console skills in
US is 53 000 dollars
to 78 000 per annum and that in India is
2 lakh 76 000 per annum some biggies in
the SEO industry looking for this skill
sets include Accenture Amazon people
group
Eton Etc
so let me know your dream company to
work as an SEO expert in the comment
section below
if you are interested in pursuing a
career in SEO then simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below the search engines have put
massive resources into developing the
visibility of local and Regional
businesses in the search results
in addition the massive increase and
prevalence of smartphones over the past
few years have made location-based
searches and expected everyday
occurrence people expect to find results
based on where they are immediately
here's the basic idea behind local
now for a long time in the past search
engines wanted to be able to provide
results based on where you were in the
world in a very precise way
they were able to use this somewhat by
using the IP address and they could
approximate where you were but it wasn't
always that accurate what they really
wanted to know is where you exactly were
within feet or meters
now this technology has evolved
considerably and in a very short amount
of time using location technology like
GPS and Wi-Fi
in addition the prevalence of searching
on smartphones accounts for more than 60
percent of searches every day these
factors now enable search engines to
know your location and provide
incredibly accurate and thorough options
for your search
so what's at the core of this well it's
the acronym nap it stands for name
address and phone number
this is the most critical factor for any
business not just in local SEO but for
local it is critically important
all you need to do is on your website
specify one name for your business one
address and one phone number
and then when you put that into
different directories like Yelp or
Yellow Pages or whatever you may be
using
you need to make sure that you have
exactly letter for letter the same name
and the same address and the same phone
number
unfortunately this gets convoluted
because the search engine spiders index
and classify information business
information can be classified separately
all because of the slightest variation
in business name or address making it
look like a separate business
now a human would easily be able to
identify the difference and classify the
variations as a single business
search engines can't do that yet start
on your own website specify one name for
your business one address format and one
phone number and then use that same
identical name and format when you set
up your accounts at different websites
and directories like Yelp or yellow
pages
you need to make sure you have exactly
letter for letter the same name the same
address and the same phone number
unfortunately this can be difficult
there are a lot of different formats for
phone numbers certainly for addresses
and even for names
any inconsistency will cause problems
again a human might be able to figure
this out easily but using the examples a
search engine would consider this two
separate businesses at the same address
or because the address format is
different it may even be considered two
different businesses at two different
addresses do you see how that works
so search engines do not usually know
that they're the same business and this
causes all kinds of problems
so let's pretend that your address is
one two three Happy Street Suite 3.
there's a lot of different ways you
could write this you could spell out
sweet you could use just the
abbreviation for it and there's actually
two abbreviations for sweet
you could also use unit instead of suite
but Suite numbers and abbreviations are
where people lose their consistency
even with Road Street Parkway or Avenue
you need to pick just one version spell
It And format it exactly the same and
use it consistently then find all the
instances of different variations you
have online and go fix them
the last part of this is directories
so directories for a while now has been
a bit of a bad word
it used to be a great way of doing SEO
until it got abused
in fact it got abused and overused and
abuse was that people would charge a lot
of money so that you could be listed in
a directory and now in modern days
directories are not like they used to be
and they're not that useful
getting links that way and doing link
building through directories is not
going to be greatly helpful however the
big exception to this is with local SEO
there are important iyps internet Yellow
Pages there are also things like Yelp or
Urban Spoon where people go and submit
their local businesses
real human beings pick up their phone
and they go to the Yelp app and look for
businesses and because real human beings
are using these unlike the directories
of the past this means that you want to
have your business there so in some ways
directories at least in the local space
have returned a great example of this
are local or even National Business
associations
Chambers of Commerce business
associations industry associations and
other directories can be good places now
after all that let's move on to some
other local signals
so the first most important signal is
This Acronym again an AP name address
and phone number the key here is that
consistency
the next thing is keywords and titles
this is extremely convenient because
it's something you should be doing for
SEO anyway
this is particular for title tags which
is something we've covered in the other
videos
the next one is domain Authority
so if you have an important domain an
important business Google is going to
use this as a signal when they're doing
a traditional local search
so when someone's on their mobile and
they're looking for a good restaurant
if you are an important restaurant in
the city you're going to be more popular
in both local search and traditional
search
that's domain Authority the next one is
inbound link signals this again might
sound familiar the things that help you
for traditional SEO do the same for
local the first one is Anchor text
so this is one of the most important
if you're a great restaurant hopefully
you're going to have lots of bloggers
lots of magazines and local online
entities that are writing about you and
linking to you
they're naturally going to use your name
and the name of your business in the
review about you
these are the kinds of things that
Google is looking for because these are
what is effective online
the last one is reviews and citations
but in this context these have very
specific definitions it's not just
reviews in general like the ones I've
talked about it's reviews on specific
local directories or business listings
and it's both the quality of them are
you getting five stars and the quantity
of them do you have a hundred reviews do
100 people care enough about your
business to review you now the next one
is a bit more complex as it does require
some programming on your website this is
called schema microdata or structured
data schema is an agreed upon
programming standard by search engines
browsers and device manufacturers that
directs the markup and display of
specific content
it's typically content that is
repetitive by nature and therefore if
it's displayed in a consistent manner
for all devices browsers and operating
systems to know the content then they
can display it properly you'll find it
in addresses contact cards dates
e-commerce products reviews people
places creative works and more
what we're most concerned with here is
the address and phone number by using
schema when you add your address or
phone number to your website it enables
the visitor to use the click to call
function on their phone when there's a
phone number on the website in addition
using the address schema can open up a
map when someone clicks on it to show
the location utilizing this schema
provides clear data to the search engine
that can be republished across a variety
of channels now specifically for
Google's business listings they give a
very wide range of content for
businesses to list so fill out as many
areas of the business listing as you can
business hours payment types accepted
phone numbers descriptions reviews from
Google and maybe even from your own
website you can link your social
profiles and any events or promotions
you have one of the biggest signals that
we've seen grow in importance are the
amount of pictures that you load into
your business listings in fact Google
provides a report as to how many times
the photos are viewed by Searchers many
times businesses that have many photos
will show up with more prominence than
those that have little or no photos so
take advantage of the listing
opportunities that Google provides
finally the same behavioral signals that
are used in search are also used in the
local search results and this is because
the search engines especially Google can
see how Searchers interact with your
local listing because it is in their
system the behavioral signals start with
how many people search for your business
this is directly related to your local
visibility and loyalty so don't forget
about your local offline marketing next
they measure how long someone views your
listing they count how many times the
phone number is clicked for someone to
call or when someone clicks to find
directions in addition there's a button
there for directions to be sent to a
searcher's phone if they're using a PC
or laptop all of these engagement
factors and buttons on a business
listing are counted as engagement and
task completion which increases the
behavioral signals for your business
as people save the listing check in or
even visit these all send important
behavioral signals of popularity and
loyalty which contributes to your
business's visibility and local search
if you are interested in pursuing a
career in SEO then simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below in today's video we are going to
talk about how to increase your website
traffic which is a very important aspect
of using a website to grow your business
or grow your brand
so we will talk about why this is
important to increase your website
traffic what are the techniques you can
use to achieve this what are the
benefits of doing it and as a bonus I
will share with you some tools and some
example websites yeah that will give you
a good idea of how they increase their
website so let's get on to this but
before I am our camp man I am your
digital navigator for this video and if
you like the video hit the Subscribe
button yeah so you can join our Channel
and if you liked the video you can also
click the like the like button so are
you ready let's get started let me give
you to start with some interesting stats
about websites as of 2021 there are an
estimated
1.7 billion websites on the internet now
the number of active websites though is
likely to be significantly lower but the
exact number of websites is constantly
changing as websites are being developed
every day and others are taking down now
the majority of the websites are hosted
on servers located in the United States
he had the top five most popular website
categories are business and industry art
and entertainment computers and internet
science and health and you know what the
most popular website in is in the world
well there's no surprise there it is
Google closely followed by YouTube and
number three Facebook now did you know
that the number of active websites is
the largest in the world in China
followed by the United States and Japan
there are over
4.9 billion web pages indexed by Google
to give you the best search results on
the Google search engine result paste
there are lots of domains in use yeah
now did you know the most popular domain
is the.com domain followed by dotnet and
Dot org
and to close this list of impressive
statistics that WordPress is the most
popular content management system used
to build websites over 60 percent of the
top 10 million websites use web use
WordPress to develop and to um to manage
their website and finally the average
website receives about 200 to 300 visits
a day
so now these numbers tell you that
websites of course are a key channel for
you to generate sales and to generate
awareness for your business so let's
have a look then how you can grow your
traffic on your website and how you can
generate more sales and higher awareness
for your business
here are some of the reasons why
businesses use your website they use it
for increased visibility for
cost-effective marketing for improved
customer service for increased sales and
for competitive advantage
yes so if you talk about increased
visibility a website allows you to reach
a global audience which is very
important these days because there is
internet connections around the world
which means you can increase your
awareness and thereby you can increase
your sales
a website is also very effective and
very cost effective to Market your
business because it can be updated it
can be updated easily it can be updated
quickly and it can be used to reach a
wide audience at a relatively low cost
compared to printing a brochure or doing
an advertisement
a website can provide your customers
with information about your products
about your business about your services
as well as how to contact your business
this can improve your customer service
and increase the satisfaction of your
customers
now many websites are being used as
e-commerce platforms yes so you can sell
your products and services online so a
lot of businesses they use their website
to sell actually and create a new sales
and revenue Channel
and finally yeah you they use a website
to create a competitive Advantage having
a professional good-looking
well-designed website can give you a
business a competitive advantage over
your competitors and
um if those competitors do not have a
website yeah it can help
establish credibility and trust with
potential customers so you will get many
benefits in having a website so let's
take a look at some of those benefits
first your website can be used to
Showcase your products and provide
detailed information including images
descriptions and pricing of your
products and of course that can help
your potential customers to make
well-informed purchasing decisions
you can set up an online store allowing
customers to purchase products directly
through your website thereby increasing
your sales and your Revenue
you can allow your customers to leave a
review and rating for your products
which can help you to build trust and
credibility with future clients who want
to buy your products
there's so much promotion the year that
you can do on your website and you can
link your website with your social media
so you can allow your prayer your
customers to promote and to share your
products from your websites with their
friends and with their followers again
another way to encourage reach and
visibility
you can help gather information about
your customers so you can use that data
to add to Target specific audiences you
can look at your website yeah sure you
can look at your competitors how are
they promoting their products on their
website yeah so a really good example of
a website that promotes products
extremely well is Amazon yeah so let's
have a look at the Amazon website Amazon
is an e-commerce platform that sells a
wide variety of products like books
Electronics clothing the website
features detailed product information as
you can see it features customer reviews
and it's a convenient online shopping
cart system
now Amazon also offers a whole range of
additional services like hosting like
Prime music video
Etc Amazon has really reinvented the
High Street yes so it's called the
Amazon effect and those businesses that
are not able to change and um and and go
online and and look into those new
online opportunities they may miss the
boat because the Amazon machined Amazon
train continues to ride and it's getting
bigger and bigger so a good way of using
your website is to promote to for you
for promoting of your products so the
next reason why you need to increase
your website is that it can help you
increase awareness
yeah there are many benefits to using a
website to increase awareness for your
products your service or your Brands you
can reach a global audience so you can
make it a very effective way to increase
awareness for your brands or products
wherever your customers are in the world
and a website can be relatively low-cost
way to reach that Global audience
especially compared to traditional forms
or advertising such as print or
broadcasting it's easy to to track the
success of a website-based awareness
campaign using analytics tools such as
Google analytics which can help you
understand why your audience yeah and
why they access your website and they
you can track the effectiveness of your
marketing efforts and your Market
data-driven decisions
so not a benefit that you can get for
this awareness is that your website can
be easily updated with fresh new content
and promotions making it easy to adapt
your marketing efforts to changing
circumstances in the markets so you can
really help you in establishing your
brand and create a consistent image and
message across all of your marketing
efforts
you can then use your website to
generate leads for your business by
capturing contact information from
visitors and follow and following up
with them through an email marketing or
other ways of connecting with them so a
well-designed and well-maintained
website can help to establish your
business as a credible and trustworthy
source of information which can help to
increase awareness and Trust among your
potential customers
now a good example of a website that
excels in creating awareness is tent.com
yeah Ted is a non-profit organization
that aims to spread an example of a
website that excels in increasing
awareness through its website is
stat.com
Ted is a non-profit organization that
aims to spread ideas through powerful
talks yeah their website features a wide
range of talks on various topics such as
science technology business and culture
the website as you can see is designed
to be user friendly and easy to navigate
with a clean and simple layout now why
do they excel in Awareness first of all
because high quality engaging content
that they feature on their website
yes so the the TED Talks feature on the
website they are carefully curated and
features some of the most inspiring and
thought-provoking ideas from experts in
the various fields they also have a
strong social media presence
yeah Ted uses social media platforms
like Twitter Instagram and YouTube to
promote it content and engage with it
audience
they have also got a very strong search
engine optimization yeah the website is
optimized for search engines making it
easy for people to find Ted Talks on the
topics that are interested to them and
the website is easy to share it's very
easy for visitors to share TED talks on
social media and on other platforms
which help them increase the reach of
their talks and thereby increase the
awareness of the Tet brands
finally the Tet brand has very
consistent branding yeah it features a
consistent brand and a consistent design
which helps building tet as a trusted
and credible source
so as a result ted.com I believe is a
great example of a website that excels
in increasing awareness through its
website and it has become one of the
most popular and well-respected websites
in the world
good let's move on here
yes so the next is that
um building your website traffic can
really help you in developing your SEO
ranking it gives you a higher ranking
for various reasons search engines use
website traffic as a signal of the
website's popularity and Authority yeah
if a website receives a lot of traffic
it is more likely to be a valuable and
authoritative resource for users which
can help improve the visibility in
search engine results
Now search engines also use a thing like
a click-through rate as a ranking Factor
if websites pages are appearing in
search engine results engines yeah and
in search engine results and they
receive a lot of clicks it is more
likely to be relevant and a valuable
resource for users which Google will
reward you with with a higher ranking so
that can improve your visibility in the
search engine results
service engines use also in fact like
bound trade as a ranking Factor yeah so
a bound trade is when people are getting
on a website on a web page and they
don't browse to any other pages but they
leave from the same page that they
arrive on
so a high bound rate in general is not a
good sign yeah you want to get your
bound rate low so many people many
people they click to other Pages as well
so if a website's pages are appearing in
search engine results and users are
staying on the website and visiting
multiple Pages it's more likely that
they find relevant content which is
useful which is valuable which can help
them to improve its visibility in the
search engine results
so search engines also use a thing like
backlinks as a ranking Factor the more
backlinks your website is pointing to it
the more authoritative and valuable it
is considered by the search engines so
if a website receives a lot of traffic
it's more likely to be linked by other
websites which can then help improve
your visibility in the search engine
results
social media signals also play an
important role in the ranking yeah if a
website gets a lot of shares a lot of
likes and engagement on social media
that is considered popular and
authoritative by the search engines all
in all a website that receives a lot of
traffic is more likely to be considered
valuable and authoritative by search
engines which can then help improve the
visibility in the search engine results
by getting a lower ranking on the search
engine results please now one example of
a website that is really good in
increasing a web in increasing awareness
through SEO is Wikipedia
Wikipedia is an online encyclopedia that
contains over 6 million articles in
various languages now the website is a
prime example of how SEO can be used to
increase websites traffic and awareness
so they are doing this in several ways
first of all by showcasing high quality
informative content
yes so their articles are are written by
a community of volunteer editors and are
carefully reviewed for accuracy and
completeness this ensures that the
articles are of the highest quality
which makes them more likely to rank
well in search engine results
now their pages are optimized for search
engines yeah they include relevant
keywords in the titles and The Meta tags
and by creating internal links between
the various articles
Wikipedia has a very strong backlink
profile which means that many other
websites link to its articles for
reference of course this helps establish
Wikipedia as a trusted and authoritative
source of information and again the
search engines they like that and they
reward that in giving it a higher
ranking and then Wikipedia's content is
regularly updated yeah so it's
constantly updated with new articles new
information which helps to keep the
website fresh and relevant
and finally Wikipedia is mobile friendly
it is optimized for mobile devices so
their articles are easy to read when
you're on the go that helps improve the
user experience and of course Google
like the user experience is another
thing that search engines will consider
when they decide on the ranking for for
different web pages and websites so as a
result of these SEO efforts Wikipedia is
one of the most popular and well
respected websites in the world and it's
a prime example of how SEO can be used
to increase your website's awareness and
traffic
good so let's look at the next one which
is about conversion
conversion is very important for your
website traffic because it measures the
effectiveness of your website in
achieving your goals and your objectives
yeah if everybody visits your website
but nobody is actually clicking on the
calls to action on your website then it
is not doing it's not achieving the
objectives that you may have set out now
a conversion is a specific action that a
website visitor can take which is
considerable considered valuable to your
website to the website owner such as
making a purchase filling out a contact
form or signing up for a newsletter so
when a website is able to convert a high
percentage of its visitors it means that
the website is effective in
communicating the value proposition and
make it easy for visitors to take the
desired actions
so why then are conversions so important
for website traffic first a high
conversion rate means that more visitors
take a desired action which can lead to
more sales for going through your
website
yeah a conversion is also important for
lead generation a high conversion rate
means that more visitors are providing
their contact information which can then
be used to generate leads and nurture
those leads with email marketing to for
them to become customers
a high conversion rate means that more
visitors are engaging with your content
and becoming aware of your brand which
can help in building trust and building
loyalty
and a high conversion rate means that
your website is optimized it is
effective in communicating the value
proposition and making it easy for
visitors to take the desired action
which could be used as a benchmark to
opt the website to optimize to websites
even further and make it more more
effective
a high conversion rate also means that
you are effective that you are
successful in reaching your target
audience and you resonate with them so
it will help you in better understanding
your audience and make data different
decisions so overall conversion is a
very important metric for the success of
your website and had done properly it
can really help you in increasing your
website's traffic because it is shows
you that you're achieving your goals and
objectives and they can provide you with
valuable insights into the effectiveness
of your website the far designed content
and the marketing effort
now here are two examples of websites
that are very effective in driving
conversions first of all is not this one
the first one is booking.com
yeah so booking.com is an online travel
agency that specializes in lodging and
reservations
are the websites user-friendly design
they're very clear call to actions and
easy to use booking process all
contribute to the high conversions they
experience on their website they also
offer a Rewards program for frequent
Travelers and that's a best price
guarantee which incentivizes user to
book through their website
zillow.com is another one
yeah they are a real estate website
they provide users with a wide range of
tools and resources to help them buy
sell or rent a property now the website
uses very friendly design
very clear calls to action an easy to
use property search and filtering tools
and these all contribute to a high
conversion
they also offer a wide range of services
so are like mortgage appraisal and Home
Improvement recommendations which makes
it a One-Stop shop for all your home
related needs which further enhances the
user experience and ultimately increases
conversions
so both of these websites Zillow and
booking have been designed to make the
process as easy and seamless as possible
for the user which helps it to increase
the conversions and drive website
traffic
the next benefit and the next reason why
you need to increase your website
traffic is that it can help you improve
trust by providing social proof
increasing brand awareness and showing
that your website is providing valuable
and useful information of products
your website can help you build that
trust in many ways yeah so when your
website receives a lot of traffic it can
be seen as a sign of popularity and
Authority
and if a lot of people are visiting your
website it can be issued that your
website is providing valuable and useful
information which can help to increase
that trust
seeing a high volume on your website can
act as a form of social proof which is
the idea that people are more likely to
trust something if they see others doing
it if your website is receiving a lot of
traffic it can be seen it should be
assumed that others trust your website
which can encourage others to trust you
more
yeah when your website receives a lot of
traffic it is more likely that visitors
are engaging with your content like
reading articles or watching videos or
leaving comments now this engagement
again can be a sign of your website's
credibility and Authority which can then
help in increase trust in your website
so a high volume of traffic can increase
brand awareness which can help to build
trust by making your brand more familiar
to users
a high volume of traffic can also result
in an increase of reviews and
testimonials which can help to build
your trust
positive reviews and testimonials can
help to improve your website's
reputation again which can lead to more
traffic and more Trust
and a website that receives a high
volume of traffic is likely to have
implemented measures to ensure the
security of the website and the data of
the users
yes so and again that can help build
trust among the users as well
one example of a website that drives
website traffic through positive
branding is Apple
apple.com is known for its iconic brand
and its high quality cutting-edge
products the website design as you can
see is clean
yeah it's minimalistic it's high quality
product photography and very clear
messaging and all help to convey the
Apple brand and its values of innovation
Simplicity and elegance
now Apple's website is also designed to
be very user friendly and very easy to
navigate making it easy for visitors to
find a product they are looking for
yeah their website also features a today
at Apple section which allows visitors
to find and register for workshops
events and creative sessions in Apple
stores around the world again that helps
to build a community around a brand and
enhances the users experience
so Apple's website is a prime example of
how a well-designed and user-friendly
website with very good branding can help
Drive traffic through this positive
branding and build a community around it
now after all this information about why
you should focus on increasing your
website traffic let's look at how you
increase your website traffic yeah we've
now looked at why it's important let's
look at the how to do it yeah so we
should put this in the context of the
three different types of digital
marketing that businesses can use to
reach and engage with their target
audience
yeah it's owned paid and earned
so owned digital marketing refers to the
digital marketing efforts that you own
and that you can control such as your
website yes such as your uh
associate your email list your social
media accounts this type of digital
marketing allows you to build a brand
and establish an online presence and it
gives you control over the message and
the audience
great digital marketing refers to
efforts that you pay for such as online
advertise advertising pay-per-click
campaigns and sponsored content this
type of digital marketing allows you to
reach a larger and more targeted
audience and can be a very cost
effective way to drive traffic and
increase conversions
earned digital marketing refers to
efforts that are generated by your
customers such as Word of Mouth customer
reviews and social media shares it's
also where other people other magazines
online magazines are writing about you
like online PR This is highly effective
because it is based on the trust and
credibility that others have in your
business
so each type of digital marketing owned
paid and earned has its own strengths
and weaknesses and businesses should use
a combination of all three to achieve
their marketing goals
own Digital model marketing can help you
build brand awareness establish an
online presence
pay digital marketing can help you to
reach a larger and more targeted
audience and earn digital marketing can
help you to build trust and credibility
yeah and all three together with the
optimum spot which you find in the
center is the perfect way to drive your
website traffic to grow your website
traffic so let's go into a bit more of
the details here yeah so the number one
way to increase your website traffic is
through search engine optimization
yeah SEO as it's called is the process
of optimizing your website to improve
the visibility and the ranking of your
website or web pages in search engine
results pages also called serbs by
implementing SEO best practices you can
increase the likelihood that your web
pages will appear at the top of the
search engine results for Relevant
keywords and phrases which can then
drive more traffic to your website
so here are a few ways that you can use
SEO to increase traffic to your website
first of all by optimizing your
website's content structure and
Technical elements you can improve the
visibility in the search engine results
pages so more people will find your
website and therefore more people will
click it and therefore more people will
go to your website
long tail keywords that you can specify
are longer and more specific phrases
that are less competitive and more
targeted
by targeting those long tail keywords in
your SEO practices you can drive more
targeted traffic to your website
a very important part of your search
engine optimization are the meta tags on
your web pages such as the title tag and
The Meta description they provide search
engines with information about the
content of your website
and by optimizing these tags you can
make sure that your website appears more
relevant and attractive to search
engines and users
now we know yeah that search engines
favor websites that provide the highest
quality and relevant content so when you
create an update content regularly like
a blog or other types of contents you
will attract more visitors to your
website because Google will feature your
fresh content in the search engine
results pages
backlinks are also very important yeah
they point from other websites to your
websites
search engines view these links as a
sign of your website's Authority and by
building these backlinks you can improve
your website's visibility in the search
engine result pages
so by implementing these SEO best
practices you can increase your
website's traffic by having a higher
presence in the search engine results
pages
the next way to increase your website's
traffic and we just referred to it in
the SEO section is create content
yeah this effect people use Google and
other search engines to D to discover
detailed and reliable responses to their
inquiries and your content has the
opportunity to feature among those
results so creating high quality
informative and keyword Rich content can
help your website rank higher in those
search and search engine results pages
and thereby more people see your pages
and thereby more people will click on
them
so sharing your content on social media
platforms and encourage people to share
them can of course help to increase that
reach and drive even more traffic to
your website
so very also important that you create
content that which is valuable and
informative that other websites will
want to link to where you get high
quality backlinks and again that will
help you in your search engine rankings
so creating a blog post on your website
is probably the easiest way to get
started with good content on your
website
when you launch a black blog make sure
that you regularly post high quality
content yep and that your blog has very
good sections yeah that you you use the
um the the category section in your blog
to give people access to your the
history of your blog posts as well
websites with blog posts often have over
400 percent more pages scrolled by
search engines and those websites
without
now another interesting fact is that
sites that publish more than 16 articles
per month they attract roughly three and
a half times as many visitors as those
that publish only one to four pieces of
content a month a month
another very important piece of content
that is highly regarded by the search
engines is video
yeah it's a great way for people to find
out what your business does and what
they do best
so here are some tips on how to use
video on your website and how it can
help you drive traffic to your website
make sure that you host your videos on a
platform like YouTube and then embed the
video on your website that can really
help drive more traffic to your website
create a landing page for your video it
will increase the chances of conversions
as the visitors will have a specific
call to action
maybe you could create a video sitemap
for your website it will help to search
engines to understand the structure of
your website and improve the visibility
of your videos
Google or YouTube automatically creates
transcriptions for your videos
now if you make sure that you
um you you proofread those
transcriptions and save them then Google
will actually index those transcriptions
so they can another way to help increase
your visibility of your videos and make
them accessible to a wider audience
make sure you add your video on your
home page integrate them in your blog
posts yep and it will make sure your
visitors stay on your website longer to
experienced video but don't forget the
key to increasing website traffic
through your videos is that they are
high quality and that they are very
valuable informative and engaging to
your audience
Nothing Stops you from updating old
content
yes so Google Dean does Google's
algorithm will also reward you when you
update existing or update old content
yeah so they want you to be the subject
matter expert in the topics that you
write about
so don't make don't Focus only on new
content but repurpose your old blog post
maybe repurpose them as an infographic
or an explanation video there are
several ways to update your old content
so first you can refresh the content
making sure that it is up to date and
accurate
you could add visuals to your old
content to incorporate images videos and
infographic to make them more engagement
you have to make them more engaging you
can optimize for SEO
yeah like adding the metadata you can
promote the content so you can share the
updated content on social media to drive
more traffic to your website you can
consider internal linking between your
updated content you can repurpose the
content so put it into another format
and don't forget to use Google analytics
to analyze which Pages perform well and
which Pages or contents do not perform
well
it goes without saying social media
marketing is a very powerful way to
increase your website traffic
each day the average person spends over
two hours on social media and business
is Now understand on how to capitalize
on those consumers and if they do
capitalize on the social engaged
customers they can use that to increase
brand awareness increase infinity and
loyalty and of course drive more traffic
to your website
now the key to being on social media and
being successful on social media as a
business is to be genuine
it's tempting to follow every Trend and
follow every fad but your scrollers see
right through this yeah they are not
impressed with that they want you to be
genuine so here are some suggestions to
get started share links to your website
and specific pages on your social media
profile
this will allow your followers to easily
access your website and the content you
want to promote and thereby it will
increase traffic
use relevant hashtags when sharing links
this will make it easier for people to
find your content when they're searching
for specific topics
remember we talked about owned earned
and paid media social media is no longer
a free game
you now need to pay to play so use paid
advertising on social media platforms
like Facebook yet to promote your
website and specific pages that will
help you in increasing your website
traffic
create content that is easy to share
such as infographic videos and images
people love to share infographics they
are cool they are Innovative yeah and
they are worth sharing so people will
share your content with their own
network thereby driving new website
traffic to your website
once people engage with your content
make sure that you respond to the
comments and the messages on your social
media profiles engage with your
followers because only then will you
build a community around your brand and
encourage more people to visit your
website
and of course obvious make sure that
your calls to action are informative
instructional and entice users to return
to your content Rich website
good
yep so I already mentioned that your
social media on its own isn't enough now
you need to supplement it with paid
advertising paid advertising is a
fantastic way to give your traffic to
your website a boost yeah it's a highly
effective way but it is important to
ensure that your ads are relevant and
well targeted to make sure that you get
the most out of your advertising budget
so pay-per-click advertising yeah which
basically means you pay when somebody
clicks on your ads it allows you to
place ads on search engines so it's a
switch like Google and other search
engines like Bing yeah and also in other
websites where they will be seen by
potential customers who are searching
for products and services when a user
clicks on one of your ads they will be
directed to your website which can then
of course Drive significant additional
traffic to your website and potentially
lead to more conversions
yes so if you compare this with seo seo
takes much longer to achieve as a
valuable source to increase your website
traffic but it's more durable where
pay-per-click advertising is a burst I
can switch on my pay-per-click
advertising that will lead to immediate
traffic to my website immediate
conversions but when I stop my pay
advertising if I run out of budget then
the traffic to the website stops
yes so there is a big difference between
paid and owned website traffic now there
are several factors that can affect the
effectiveness of your PPC ads for
driving traffic to your website first of
all it's the relevance of your ads and
the keywords that you're targeting if
your ads are not relevant they will not
be seen by the Right audience and
therefore they may not drive traffic to
your website
second Google will give your ad a
quality score which is a measure of
their relevance and their expected
click-through rates and for instance the
quality of your landing page a higher
quality score will give you a lower cost
for your ad and a better ad placement
okay dare boy more people will see your
ads more people will click on them more
people will visit your website the bid
amount for your web that you're willing
to pay for your ad is also very
important
of course if you want to pay more if you
pay more for your ads it gives you
better ad placement but of course it'll
give you higher cost as well
finally the ad copy and the headlines
are important factors for users to click
on the ads so make sure it is clear it's
concise and it's compelling
so overall pay-per-click can be very
effective in driving
short-term traffic to your website by
targeting relevant keywords creating
compelling ad copy and headlines placing
ads in relevant locations and direct
visitors to relevant landing pages
right so that is on the paid advertising
another and they often say one of the
highest one of the marketing instruments
with the highest return on investment of
any marketing channel is email marketing
yeah email marketing their one-to-one
pieces of content with your ideal
customers and you can automate that
process so which can really help in
driving quality website traffic
of course automation has made it simpler
to send out mass emails but it's the
personalization and the audience
segmentation that have made email
marketing so powerful but you can
because you can speak directly to the
concerns of your ideal customers
it can be highly effective to drive
traffic to your website but you need to
play the game properly yeah so here are
a few ways to use email marketing to
achieve this
include links to your websites in your
email
yeah include links to your website and
specific Pages this it will allow you
that will allow your subscribers to
easily access your website and the
content that you want to promote
use a clear and compelling call to
action in your email such as learn more
or visit our website so you want to
encourage your subscribers to click
through to your website
very important to personalize your
emails to make them more engaging and
more relevant for your subscribers
optimize your emails for mobile devices
so they're easy to read and easy to
click on and why not use email
automation to send targeted and relevant
messages your to your subscribers based
on their actions or engagement with your
website
you can also use this to segment your
email list based on their demographics
their behaviors and interests so thereby
you can send more targeted and relevant
messages to your specific audience which
will increase the chances of people
clicking to go to your websites
and finally use the email analytics that
you get to track the click-through rate
and the conversion rate of your emails
and adjust your campaigns accordingly
people love to win things yeah so when
you use competitions contests giveaways
it's a guaranteed way to drive and
increase traffic to your website you may
quickly enhance your popularity and show
appreciation to your supporters in doing
this so they could include photos or
video contests a quiz or a survey
contest comments on social media
contests a referral contests sweepstakes
puzzle puzzle or scavenger hunt a
caption or a slogan contest or a poll or
a survey contest
yeah and relevant giveaways they can
include a product giveaway a gift card
or a cash giveaway a membership giveaway
or a subscription giveaway an experience
or a trip giveaway an e-book or a white
paper giveaway or a free demo or a trial
giveaway
yeah so how can you use those contests
here are a few tips use your social
media platforms to promote your contests
or giveaways
you shave clear and very compelling call
to action on your website and in your
social media posts such as enter to win
or sign up now
to encourage people to visit your
website and participate and create a
landing page specifically for your
contest and competition and make sure
that landing page is optimized for
conversions with a very clear call to
action and information about a
competition
over a price that is valuable that is
relevant to your target audience
it's said if you're giving away an iPad
you'll it's a waste because you will
just get lots and lots of people who are
there just to win the iPads they don't
care about your product they don't care
about your service it is a waste so make
sure that your price is relevant and
valuable to your Rd audience
share the result of your contest or give
away on social media and your website it
makes sure that you're transparent but
also creates a buzz around your brand
use email marketing to promote your
competition or your giveaway to your
subscribers and encourage people to
share your contest or giveaway with
friends and family by maybe offering a
referral program
right so another way of creating website
traffic is by writing guest blog posts
yeah when you guest blog on another
website you can typically include a link
back to your own website
so these called backlinks they can help
improve your search engine ranking
making it more likely that people will
find the article that you that you wrote
they are particularly on relevant
websites they can give you exposure to
new audiences that may not have found
your website otherwise so it's a great
opportunity for you to Showcase your
expertise your brand and credibility
Yeah by guest blocking on websites that
are relevant to your Niche and Industry
you can attract targeted traffic to your
website so because those are the people
that are likely to be interested in your
product and your service so they are
likely to click thereby driving
um traffic to your your website
yeah make sure that when you Guest block
on other websites that readers can share
your posts on social media that can lead
to even more traffic and of course don't
forget to include a gold call to action
in your guest posts that encourage
readers to sign up for an email list
yeah or you can use guest blocking to
build an email list to drive even more
traffic to your website over time
so it's important to seek out high
quality relevant websites for guest
blogging yep and it graphs high quality
informative and engaging content that is
relevant to the audience of the website
reach out yeah to the guests to the
Publications where you would like to
guest blog and then when you reach out
and give them a good proposition and a
good topic for an article quite often
they will respond positively
an example of a very successful guest
blogging campaign that drove traffic to
the website was from buffer yeah buffer
is a tool that can help you in your
social media outreach they implemented a
guest blogging strategy which helps them
increase their website traffic by over a
hundred thousand visitors in just two
months
it was focused on targeting blogs and
websites that were relevant to their
Niche being social media marketing
they reached out to the website owners
pitching their ideas for guest posts and
offered them high quality informative
content that was relevant to Their
audience
they also included a call to action in
their guest block encouraging readers to
visit their websites to learn more about
their social media management tools
yeah so the result of this campaign was
a significant increase in website
traffic and that helped them increase
their brand awareness and credibility in
the markets
we talked about this earlier exchanging
backlinks is a very powerful way to
drive traffic to your website and you
need to make sure that you have a
backlink strategy
yeah so if they can drive traffic to
your website by improving your search
engine ranking which will increase the
chance that people will find your
website when they search for related
keywords
yes your backlinks are one of the most
important factors that search engines
use to determine the quality and the
relevance of your websites so having a
good backlink strategy is probably one
of the highest priorities in developing
your SEO strategy
they can also Drive referral traffic to
your website when someone clicks on a
link to your website from another
website they're being referred to your
website and that's why it's called a
referral referral traffic
they can help increase the visibility of
your website yeah it can help expose
your website to new audiences that may
not have found your website otherwise
yeah they help you in brand awareness it
can help expose your Brands to new
audiences it can help increase the
number of social media shares that you
receive
yep and a backlink strategy involves
identifying the high quality websites in
your Niche or industry and reach out to
them with a question do you want to
share my piece of content in one of your
articles
yeah and make sure that your content is
high quality and is likely to be shared
infographics is a really good example of
a content type that people really like
to uh to share
yep and there is other stuff that you
can do like Link roundups Link exchanges
and broken link building all in all it
asks for having a good link building
strategy
and finally
don't forget good old PR
ND media coverage refers to the coverage
that your brand or your website receives
from search from third party sources
like news outlets blogs podcasts and
social media influences they can drive a
tremendous amount of traffic to your
websites by increasing your visibility
and credibility of your brand and by
providing you opportunities and
potential customers to learn more about
your product and service
because when your brand or website is
mentioned in a news article or in a blog
post or a podcast it can help increase
the visibility among the their readers
their listeners and their viewers
so earned media coverage can really help
you in driving traffic to your website
yes so because it also helps you in
establishing trust and credibility so
when your brand is mentioned in a news
article yeah it can expose your brand to
new audiences that otherwise would never
have found you
yep so they include additional
opportunities like having a link to your
website included in the coverage so that
not only drives traffic to your website
but also helps you in your search engine
ranking
show lots of ways to increase your
website traffic and it's finding that
right balance of which tool to use yeah
and which way to increase your
activities to help in driving traffic to
your website
make sure that you set your website up
for Google analytics so they track
exactly where your traffic is coming
from they track the growth of your
traffic and they track the the places
where people are are coming from and
also other demographic factors like age
gender and what have you if if you are
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below search engine optimization has
been playing an essential role in the
success of various businesses for those
who are still looking for growth in the
industry and have search engine
optimization otherwise known as SEO as
their primary weapon then yes you are in
the right place this video on how to
rank number one on Google will give you
the best tips to get a higher ranking
without spending a penny but before we
begin subscribe to our Channel simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn so
before we begin I have a question for
you the process of getting the quality
and quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tenfold
so definitely we're going to take a look
at the best tips for ranking high on
Google but before that it is necessary
to understand why it's important to rank
high on Google
well we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business
the data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as serps allows
a business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales
it also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are numerous reasons which makes
SEO important to know more about SEO
check the complete playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below
to gain expertise in search engine
optimization get certified as a skilled
SEO professional with simply learns
search engine optimization training
course you can check the course details
from the link in the description box
below as we know how important it is to
rank high on Google so in the next 10
minutes let's get to know the top five
success mantras that will help you rank
high-end Google so the fifth tip on our
list is promote your content whether you
are a business owner or a blogger you
definitely need to promote your content
to get a good audience reach buy content
here we mean data on your website that
can be products services or even a
simple blog to do this find the relevant
groups on the social media platforms
like Facebook or Instagram and post your
content with an excellent call to action
context some blogging or article
submission sites like quora Tumblr and
hub pages may also prove helpful online
forums and communities can be a good
option to spread a word about your
content with people having similar
interests let's focus on our number four
tip internal linking a good site
architecture is always a happy bite for
web crawlers a website with good site
architecture and internal linking helps
web crawlers understand the website
structure and helps them to crawl the
site more effectively the more the pages
of your website are crawled greater are
the chances of getting indexed if pages
are successful indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting backlinks
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink building techniques in
the video how to build backlinks check
out the link in the description box
below and number two we have a tip which
is of utmost importance to win a good
position in the search results on page
optimization on-page optimization are
also known as on-page SEO is a process
in which we take essential measures to
improve the website or web pages
position in search engine rankings
on-page optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more
get the detail guide to learning on-page
optimization by simply learn
check the link in the description box
below and finally the best tip we have
is the most effective one and the one
that rules them all which is keyword
research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create
proper keyword research may prove a boon
to your business but it also has the
power to ruin your business so be wise
When selecting your keywords try
choosing long tail keywords if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Auto suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc
these fantastic and 100 practical tips
can drive your business to Heights make
sure you implement all these tips with
more detailed attention as SEO can make
and break you so what according to you
is the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below
about how to measure your SEO
performance so all that hard work you've
done with on-page SEO and coupled with
all the work you've done with off-page
SEO are eventually going to net results
and positive results and we want to be
able to measure that as you're actually
doing the work as you're putting forth
the effort on on page and off page and
so we want to be able to measure that
and so you want to be able to understand
what to measure and where to measure it
and so when we talk about SEO we really
want to hone in on three high level core
metrics and that's ranking traffic and
conversion so when we talk about ranking
traffic and conversion we can break that
down into this list here what kind of
traffic are we getting from organic
search what kind of traffic are we
getting from mobile devices remember
mobile is very important because as we
talked about with on page SEO as we talk
about with local SEO a lot of searches
start with mobile devices we want to
look at keyword ranking remember keyword
research is the first step in the SEO
process even before we do any work with
on-page and off page you know we want to
look at the local visibility if we have
local SEO results we want to look at
engagement metrics so all that traffic
we're driving from organic search we
want to be able to measure how they're
performing and behaving on our website
we also want to measure some form of
progress on off-page SEO and that's in
the form of backlinks so all of these
are different metrics we can measure
using different tools so let's talk
about how to go about looking at these
metrics and where to go look at them and
measure them and so really monitoring
all this Behavior will help us
understand how we're performing how SEO
is performing and so really what we want
to do is start with Organic traffic and
so we can look at that on a
month-to-month basis we can look at it
from a geographic perspective we can
look at it in terms of how many new
visitors we're driving versus returning
and then again more importantly
conversion rate and so to me the best
place to start to look at that traffic
from organic search is Google analytics
and Google analytics is a free tool it's
simply there to measure website
performance so if you go into Google
analytics we can actually go in and we
can look at all sorts of data based on
website behavior and so if I'm in Google
analytics and I go under acquisition and
then I go under all traffic channels
over a given period of time let's just
say the last seven days for a particular
website I can see what traffic is coming
from organic search and then I could see
the amount of new users that are coming
from organic service I can also see
engagement metrics bounce rate for
example so I want to be able to see if
somebody's typing in a query clicking on
our Link in the organic search results
and then coming to our website are they
actually engaging with their website or
are they leaving the website after only
visiting the page they landed on so
that's all in these are all important
metrics to measure and I can measure all
that right here in Google analytics if I
wanted to I can even take it a step
further and break that down by country
so if I type in country as a secondary
Dimension now I can see what country is
driving traffic from organic search so a
lot of your organic traffic information
is going to be centrally located in
Google analytics so we also talked about
Mobile Traffic a majority of searches
take place on mobile phones versus
desktop so Google basically is reporting
the nearly 60 percent of searches now
appear from mobile devices and so if we
go back to Google analytics and we can
also look at a mobile report so if I go
in Google analytics under audience under
mobile overview I can see a breakdown of
the amount of traffic coming from
desktop versus tablet versus mobile and
so you'll find as time goes on that your
mobile device is likely going to drive a
majority of the traffic from organic
search and so you can compare device
information with channel so if I just
type in Channel and Google analytics as
a secondary Dimension and look at the
default Channel groupings versus device
category I could see that you know
mobile from organic search driven
traffic over the last seven days this is
something you want to keep an eye on
because a lot of people tend to begin
their searches on mobile devices so
mobile ranking is different than desktop
ranking because with mobile ranking it's
based on a responsive website and with
that responsive website basically
response of being that the website's
going to adapt to the mobile device so
it's going to respond to the device that
somebody's on and so therefore the
metrics or the engagement metrics are
going to be different but if I look back
to Google analytics I can see again
bounce rate I can see pages per session
average session duration so if I look at
line three I could see all the different
engagement metrics compared to those
metrics from other devices and other
channels okay so you want to be able to
do a comparison because if behavior is
not up to par engagement is not the par
on mobile then you want to do something
about that so you want to hone in on
Mobile Traffic specifically from organic
search because the behavior is going to
be different you know people start their
searches on mobile this side's going to
be different and so therefore it's a
different experience altogether so make
sure you track the behavior and more
importantly make sure you track that
page speed so earlier we talked about
on-page SEO when we honed in on page
speed so just as a reminder if I'm back
in analytics and I go back under
Behavior then if I go to site speed then
if I go to overview I'll be able to see
the average page load time on my website
I can also look at specific page timings
and I should be able to see that by
device so if I type in device category
I'll just be able to see how each paid
loads per device and so this allows me
to understand which pages are loading
fast which pages are not loading as fast
and address those pages accordingly to
improve engagement metrics so we want to
keep an eye on page speed as well as
overall user behavior from mobile
devices you can also use other tools
that are out there like agency Analytics
there are plenty of tools out there I
tend to use Google analytics because
primarily it's free and Google analytics
is a Google product so it works with
other Google platforms like Google
search console we want to keep an eye on
ranking so remember when we do our
keyword research we're choosing keywords
that have high relevancy high volume and
low competition so we want to be able to
track keywords that we choose that have
high relevancy high volume and low
competition and so the tool we use or at
least I recommend using is Moz so I
mentioned Moz earlier with on page and
off-page SEO so if we go into Moz and we
know what keywords we're trying to rank
for we can go ahead and add the Namaz
and what Moz does they actually track
where these keywords Rank and so if I go
into Mods and I click on rankings I'll
be able to see on a weekly basis or a
monthly basis how how our keywords are
ranking and for what page is the ranking
so for whatever keyword I choose to to
optimize for I want to make sure I put
those keywords in Moz because when I put
them in Moz Moz is going to on a weekly
basis tell me where these keywords Rank
and for what URL they're ranked for so
that way I can keep an eye on ranking
over time because in theory the higher
you rank the more traffic you're going
to get and so we want to be able to see
the trend in which keywords rank okay so
if I click on a particular keyword in
Moz it's going to give me over a period
of time where that keyword's ranked be
able to see Improvement in ranking for a
particular keyword the whole idea behind
SEO is to choose keywords that are
relevant optimize for those keywords so
that you can be ranked for those
keywords in order to get the traffic and
conversions so Moz is a good platform
that helps us monitor rankings for
particular keywords now if you don't
want to use Moz as an alternative you
can turn your attention to Google search
console and so remember we talked about
Google search console earlier when we
talked about sitemaps we also talked
about mobile usability with search
console we also talked about links to
your site with Google search console so
Google search console is a good tool to
help you understand how you're
performing with Organic search and so
there's one tool in particular which is
performance that helps us understand
what keyword queries people are actually
typing into Google search and so here I
could see the actual query and so with
this particular website valleyfig.com I
can see that dried fig recipes over the
course of the last three months had
5414 Impressions that means that one of
my pages either one or multiple Pages
appeared in Google search engine results
5414 times and over the course of those
5414 Impressions I receive received 1100
clicks so Google search console is going
to be able to tell me not only you know
how many Impressions I received for a
particular keyword but they also are
going to tell me how many clicks and if
I wanted to add more metrics to that I
can add them like the average ranking
position for keyword the click-through
rate so I can add multiple metrics to
this report to give me an understanding
of hey or any of my target keywords
being used or queried and if they are
where am I ranking and I am I showing up
and am I getting clicks so search
console serves as a good alternative if
not primary tool or platform for you to
measure how your organic search results
are showing so for local visibility this
metric is important for you know
maintaining local SEO so remember on the
local SEO we talked about Google my
business so if I go back to Google my
business I I can go into my account and
so Google my business is going to be
able to show me some metrics so if I go
into Google my business and I click on
insights I'm going to be able to see a
number of different metrics over the
course of a month I can see exactly you
know what queries were used by how many
users and when I appeared so I'll be
able to see how many views I receive not
only on search results but on maps then
I can also see what actions people took
when they saw my results in maps or in
search did they visit my website did
they request directions that they call
so I can actually see engagement metrics
right in Google my business I could see
a Breakout by ZIP code I could see phone
calls by day of the week I could see how
many people even viewed my photos so
there's a lot of insights into local SEO
on Google my business so that gives you
an idea of how you're performing
organically on local search and remember
you want to be able to use Google my
business to hone in on your specific
audience so all these metrics help you
align with whether you're getting in
front of the Right audience and whether
that audience is actually behaving the
way you want them to meaning you know
are they actually contacting you are
they going to your website are they
calling you so local visibility and
understanding the metrics involved with
local SEO is very important so Google my
business is where you want to turn your
attention so overall engagement metrics
are important they play an important
role in determining rankings for example
we talk about bounce rate so bounce rate
is the rate at which people go from
organic search to your website and then
leave after a scene one page and not
going any further so if they land on a
page and then leave the website after
landing on that page it's considered a
bounce and so bounce or bounce rate is a
good indication of how people people are
receiving our website or the content
that they're reading on our website
there are other metrics involved like
average session duration or pages per
visit all of these are engagement
metrics and let's not forget about page
speed so page speed is also a good
engagement metric all of these metrics
affect or determine rankings so we want
to be able to make sure that if we're in
Google analytics and we're looking at
engagement metrics that our metrics are
good because if somebody comes to our
website from organic search and there's
a high bounce rate then what does that
tell us that there's a disconnect
between what that person's querying and
then the content that they're reading
and so we want to be able to address
those engagement metrics so that we can
continue to not only drive quality
traffic but keep the traffic engaged and
then in turn drive up conversions last
metric we want to look at is backlinks
so content having more backlinks from
good domain will effectively improve
your SEO performance we talk about
backlinks with off-page SEO and remember
quality over quantity and so we can
measure backlinks going back into Moz we
can use moz's Link Explorer tools so
remember if I type in a domain Valley
fig I can get some metrics related
off-page SEO including my domain
Authority but more importantly I can see
what links are pointing to my site in
this case valleyfig.com so I can see
they're 575 link domains I can see
there's 7900 inbound links and so just
by clicking on that I can get an idea of
the types of websites that are linking
to my site and their domain Authority
and their spam score Google search
console so if you go back into search
console you can also just click on links
and we should be able to get an idea of
you know what what websites are linking
to our site and more importantly we want
to be able to see not only what sites
but what pages they're linked to
remember we want our backlinks pointing
to Interior Pages not necessarily the
home page so here I could see the top
link page for valleyfair.com is slash
recipes so we want links pointing to our
interior page is not necessarily the
home page that's what's going to help
your performance your rankings for all
your pages not just your home page so
having quality back links pointing to
Interior Pages help boost the domain
Authority and the page Authority for
that particular page so again using Moz
it's link Explorer tool or using the
links report in search console are good
sources for you to identify backlinks so
when we look at these these reports we
want to look at the Domain authority of
these sites that are linking ours the
number of outbound links to the site or
specific pages on our site we want to be
able to look at the ratio of Link
distribution you know we want to be able
to look at how many follows and no
follows so most of this if not all of
these metrics are in Moz so if I go back
to Moz I can actually see you know which
ones pointing which ones are followed
the total quality of the link that's
pointing to our site again bam so Moz
link Explorer report tends to give us
all the information we need in order to
measure and get a sense of our backlinks
that help us with off-page SEO so there
are other tools out there there's hrefs
again search console there's other SEO
platforms out there that'll help you
measure backlinks if you're interested
in pursuing a career in SEO the simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below let's get started with keyword
research so basically what we want to do
is Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos so first thing is
search suggest so YouTube has a feature
called autocomplete so if you've done
any searches on Google it's very similar
if you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk a little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type and simply
learn here's their Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn if I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords words with the video so here
you can see Facebook marketing Facebook
ad strategy Facebook ads for beginners
so forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right clicking view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study you using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use it third party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from is
well aligned because it's in the title
it's in the copy and it's a line is a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction and machine
learning primary keyword is machine
learning Basics and then we supported
that video with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning is probably going to type in
that keyword and then introduction to
machine learning is a good secondary
keyword because it's explaining the
basics of what machine learning is all
about so primary keyword machine
learning basic secondary keywords what
is machine learning and introduction to
machine learning so that's the whole
idea behind choosing keywords you want
that keyword that really is going to
define the content and then support that
with those secondary keywords so
remember when you're performing your
keyword research choose keywords for
your videos that Google show those on
the video results page so what I mean by
that is your video can get more views if
you rank on Google as well so the whole
idea is not necessarily to be found on
YouTube it's also to be found on Google
so if I go back to Google and I just
type in data science for beginners and I
type in videos then you could see we're
ranked number one so even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for begin
scanners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video video
and it's educational in nature you know
use those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of a
hundred characters so we really have to
pick and choose really wisely so if we
look at the video that we were focusing
on a couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
those catchy words and numbers to gain
High click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same with our video
title because the video titles what's
going to show up in search so if I go
back to you know search here we could
see you know data science tutorial data
science for beginners so we want to make
sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choose using the
right words in your video title is going
to help you get that click-through rate
up remember click the rate is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up
and the search results on YouTube or
Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
here I can see this machine learning
Basics video will help you understand
what is machine learning so our primary
keyword is in the first sentence right
in the introductory of this description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if I
go back to my video I click show more we
have a lot of characters to really
describe what the video is about okay
there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else she
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using seen hashtags
in the description the combination of
all of that if we chose the right
keyword then we should find that our
video will eventually rank on YouTube so
just doing these small tidbits with our
keywords really help get our video to
rank so at the end of the day we want to
be able to use the tools available to Us
YouTube Itself by looking at our
competitors those extensions like vid IQ
the autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube if you're
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learn postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below so at simply learn if I go go to
YouTube and I just type in machine
learning you could see we're right here
is the first organic video on YouTube
for machine learning if I jump over to
Google and I type in machine learning
Basics you can see where number or
number one for machine learning Basics
under videos if I click on all we're
also ranked here as well under the video
section on organic search results
another example data science for
beginners we ranked number one for that
if I look at another keyword data
science interview questions okay we're
ranked number two for that so we're
ranking for a lot of videos and why are
we ranking for a lot of different
content and videos on Google Search and
on YouTube well we put a lot of work in
behind the scenes of creating the video
and that's what we want to show you so
part of that has a lot to do with you
know how our audience engages and sees
our video so for example we're looking
at the machine learning Basics video
here and we we can see that it has over
221 000 subscribers for this video 234
000 views we've had over 2 000 people
like the video and we have had over 270
plus comment on the video so when we get
our videos to rank then we can see
there's a lot of Engagement and so
that's the whole idea is when you do a
video and you want to show up on YouTube
you want people to enjoy you want people
to share it you want people to like it
you want people to comment on that and
that's part of the whole ecosystem of
YouTube It's you know we're going to
show you behind the scenes of what it
takes to get your videos to rank and
then we're going to show you some of the
metrics involved with some of these
videos to help you stay ranking so
without further Ado let's go into how to
get your videos to rank on YouTube so
we're going to talk about keyword
research for YouTube we're going to talk
about some ways to create high quality
videos so the importance of user
engagement just as I showed you with the
machine learning Basics video all the
shares all the commenting all the views
and subscriptions then we're going to
get into how to promote your content and
then we're going to just review a little
checklist for you and sum it all up so
let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
Center our keywords just like our
website we want to Center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so the videos on YouTube are no
different than the web pages on our
website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right in into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for your video then the chances
of you ranking higher increases on
YouTube so we're gonna share with you a
few easy ways to do keyword research
this is the most important step in
getting your videos to rank on YouTube
just like for those of you who watched
any of the SEO videos we produced it at
simply learn you know that keyword
research is so essential to getting your
web pages to rank on Google well it's no
different keyword research and choosing
the right keywords is just as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go into a few things
to do here to find the right keywords so
we have the search suggestion you can
look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in Google itself so
let's start talking about some of these
ways to really hone in and do some good
research on your keywords to align them
with your videos so first thing is
search suggest so YouTube has a feature
called autocomplete so if you've done
any searches on Google it's very similar
if you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns ranked
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search result so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing a
video on machine learning then you know
we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are key words that people are
using to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos I wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn if I
click on that video it's automatically
going to start playing but what I could
do is simply just look at you know the
content description so just by clicking
show more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to to look at the HTML
and so that means looking at the page
source so just like web pages what
YouTube does is they look at meta tags
so if you call from SEO in order to get
your pages to rank you need to have a
title tag and amount of tag description
so videos are no different what we're
doing for YouTube is aligning certain
keywords with the video so if you take a
look and do a search for keywords by
viewing the page Source you're going to
see all the keywords associated with a
particular video so for example if I go
back to YouTube and I look at the page
source of a video Let's just say this
video here Facebook's ad tutorial I'm
going to pull up the page source and all
I need to do is control F and type in
keywords and now for that Facebook video
I can see all the keywords associated
with the video so you can see there's a
lot of different keywords we're aligning
with this video and so why do we want to
do that because we want you know our
video you to show up for keywords that
people may type in and so if you use
that YouTube autocomplete it's going to
give you those ideas this most popular
keywords so if they're related align
those keywords with the video so here
you can see Facebook marketing Facebook
ad strategy Facebook ads for beginners
so forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you can see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to to rank for so let's
look at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video you're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube we're going
Google they're going to give you some
popular keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimized for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click click on it I'm
going to go to YouTube and so here I can
see this keyword we know humans learn
from is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's a line
is a keyword tagged with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction and machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning an introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google's
going to do is also put in the videos
here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key
termite really Google and YouTube like
and that's what is machine learning so
it's helping us Rank by having our
keywords in the title with that key
phrase what is okay so that's a good
tidbit on creating a good video title is
to align it with the right keywords your
primary and your secondary and so we
want to use those catchy words and
numbers to gain High click-through rates
just like you would on the title tag of
your web page we want to do the same
with our video title because the video
titles what's going to show up in search
so if I go back to you know search here
we could see you know data science
tutorial data science for beginners so
we want to make sure in this case you
can see data science in five minutes so
that was purposely done so that hey I
don't have time to watch a video I only
have a couple minutes data science in
five minutes okay great I'm gonna click
on the video and now I have an
opportunity to watch something and learn
something under five minutes so choosing
the right words in your video title is
going to help you get that click-through
rate up remember click the rate is
clicks divided by Impressions and an
impression is how many times your video
shows up and the search results on
YouTube or Google so we want to keep our
click-through rate high and in order to
do that we want to be able to write some
really good title tags for our video so
use catchy words like a number or how to
or what is because that's going to
resonate with people when they're
searching now for the description what
we want to do is we want to use the
target word at the beginning of the
description the title and the tags
itself so if I go back to my video here
machine learning Basics we know it's in
the video title and right off the bat if
I look at the description of the video
video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keyword Target keywords
and then using our primary and secondary
keyword in the title tag using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube that's our turn our
attention to creating high quality
videos and some of the best practices
around around that so along with
everything we mentioned about choosing
the right keywords we always need to
keep in mind that the videos we create
need to be of high quality so the
content itself in addition to the
keywords is a primary factor in ranking
so in order to have keywords we need to
have content and in order to rank we
need to have you know good content so
let's talk a little bit about creating
content and what's involved with that
and what we really mean by high quality
videos so if you have a video content
that is not informative or irrelevant to
the topic it won't rank so that's just
common sense so you need to create
content that's aligned with the topic
obviously and then that way you have
keywords that are aligned with the
content so but if you have content it
really isn't aligned with the topic then
you're not going to rank no matter how
much you've optimized that video so just
keep that in mind so there's a couple of
things we want to look at here air so
high quality content is determined by
really two metrics so we're not sure
about how good our content is and how
good of high quality video we created we
want to look at audience retention and
user engagement so audience retention
and simply the percentage length of your
video that the audience has watched It's
the percentage your audience has watched
so focusing on audience retention is
important for people who want their
videos to rank high so if you want to
rank you need to optimize for the
keywords but got to keep in mind content
so content is related to audience
retention and user engagement so
audience retention percentage length
your video of your video that the
audience has watched and for example it
can be both absolute in minutes or
percentages so audience retention can be
the average view duration or percentage
of the audience that watched then we
have user engagement so yours engagement
our viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
Engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's going to
have a longer audience engagement
audience retention so that's one of the
reasons you know from a metric
standpoint so even when viewers watch
you know both videos the time is going
to differ so we want to take into
account longer videos for primarily that
region is because you know it gives an
end user an opportunity to watch the
video longer and then it's going to help
us rank our videos longer so when we
talk about watch time so if one video
has higher watch time than the other
watch time is just the number of views
times the average view duration so
another tip is we want to plan our video
script so we want to keep the content
organized my recognition is you know
create an outline first and once you
create an outline of how the video is
going to flow then start populating with
content and so to me that's how you can
keep the the flow organized okay is
really with an outline starting out with
an impound there's no videos are no
different than say a presentation if
you've done a PowerPoint presentation
you always want to start out doing an
outline and then we want to upload a
high resolution videos high resolution
we don't want to create videos that you
know are small resolution like say you
know 400 by 400 resolution or something
you know something really small we want
to create something a very high res so
according to back or link Oaks more than
50 percent of videos on the first page
of YouTube are high definition so high
definition videos of higher quality are
going to be shown on the first page of
YouTube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos or examples of
creating high quality video we also want
to make sure that content is relevant to
the title so if we're talking about
machine learning Basics you know
obviously the content is going to be
about about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning then when they watch the video
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day the
user is going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to create high
quality videos so we want to be able to
you know use examples to clarify our
content so you don't be afraid to go
into another screen like I am I want to
I'm talking about video does jump into
the machine learning Basics video which
I've done throughout this session I can
simply do that by keeping the user
engaged here this video is about machine
learning Basics well the titles align
with the video we made sure that we have
a nice description about what the video
is about and we're aligning the
expectations so not only that I'm
showing you example within the video
itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like Shutterstock
or flat icon I mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to use high
quality images in your video give more
information to your audience okay giving
maximum relevant information can help
gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know the examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from YouTube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on YouTube itself but
you know when you're going to create a
video yeah you can create another video
about what is machine learning but just
make sure it has your own take on it
you're the subject matter expert when
creating the video create it with your
own original content have high audio
quality and video effects so just like
you see here on this video we have a fax
in it and the audio is of high quality
meaning no background noise no
Distortion and we want to be able to
speak clearly in the video so you want
to speak clearly loudly concise just as
I'm trying to do now so that you can
understand what I'm trying to say or
what the viewer is trying to to
understand when they're watching the
video so watching and listening are two
of the components and you want to make
sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
Point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content that go along with the video
that outline I referenced earlier in
terms of organization you always want to
have a Content outline so what topics
are you going to cover in the video
that's why you need the outline to point
that out confirm that before you
actually start creating the video okay
focus on the initial 15 seconds so
that's key you know somebody's going to
click the play button of your video and
if you don't catch them in the first 15
seconds then they're likely going to
pause the video or just go ahead and
close it out altogether so you want to
be able to capture somebody's attention
right off the bat and even before they
click on that play button you want to
make sure again you're exceeding
expectations that title is aligned with
the content so in your first 15 seconds
it basically needs to be catchy but also
setting the expectation of what the user
is expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention and YouTube so use
the options above the graph to view
absolute audience retention or relative
audience retention so audience retention
is basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning Basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example I can see you know
43 44 watch the video for at least two
minutes here I can see
28.6 percent wash it for six minutes
plus so that's the audience retention it
gives us an idea in terms of percentage
how many people or percentage of people
watch the video what length so that's
audience retention so we want to keep
that number high at the very initial
stage of the video and we want to keep
it high throughout and that's why you
always want to create high quality
content using those examples using
imagery making it organized content not
pausing you know going from one point to
the other those are all best practices
to keep the viewer engaged and then we
want to add resources from well-known
sites so throughout this video we've
used backlinko there are other sources
we've used so if you have a source go
ahead and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning Basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or you too can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by Auto playing the
next video so if you enable this feature
it's going to go from one video to
another pattern interrupts keep the
audience engaged so basically it allows
for your audience to stay within one
video without having any interruptions
involved and so going back to the did
you know audience retention report helps
you analyze how well your videos are
engaging to the audience so what do we
mean by that well if I go back again to
my audience retention report how
engaging was it well I could see 42
percent 43 percent watched it on average
of 3 minutes and 21 seconds so to me
that's pretty good of course we always
want a hundred percent of the video the
video is seven minutes long if almost
half of our audience saw over half of
the video then I would say that's pretty
good people were engaged so audience
retention just is a good report to start
looking at to help you understand how
engaging is my video and if your video
is not engaging you know you can always
go back and edit it or fix it or tweak
it so remember the average view duration
for all videos and top performing videos
listed by all time we can look at that
information as well in addition we can
look at demographics so we can get an
overview of the age gender and location
and we can look at playback locations
report and what the playback locations
report does is it helps us determine the
platforms where our videos are being
streamed from within YouTube look at the
traffic sources where did the viewers
come from devices did they look on
mobile or tablet and so if there's any
doubts you know if you have any
questions please drop a comment below
but especially if you have any doubts on
the metrics so if we go back into
YouTube we can look at Analytics and if
we're looking at analytics we can see
more and then this is going to show us
everything we need to see from device
type so if I click on more I can see my
playback location so this will show me
where the video is watched it was on a
watch page or a channel page I could see
the traffic sources I could see the
gender and age so if I click on the
viewer age report I can see the
percentage of views by age so I can get
a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where they come from all the
information they need to know okay so
it's all within YouTube analytics so
again if you have any questions about
that you know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to YouTube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to YouTube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at YouTube analytics
so let's talk about the importance of
user engagement event so engagement is
as we mentioned important because
basically we can't rank without
engagement our videos won't rank unless
we have engagement so that's why it's
important so engagement is somebody
liking the video commenting sharing it
or subscribing each one of these is
important to ranking so yes you need to
line keywords yes you need to have high
quality content so when you do both of
those and you upload your video then
it's up to the viewer and so the hard
work that you put out for the video is
hopefully going to pay dividends with
engagement so you want people to do one
of these four okay so let's talk about
what that means so how do I get
engagement so we already talked about
creating engaging content so there are a
lot of tips to creating engaging content
and so according to wordstream if your
content is entertaining then over three
quarters of the users are going gonna
share it so that's part of keeping a
users engaged just keeping it
entertaining is part of getting a high
quality video so remember on that high
quality video when we say entertaining
the audio portion has a lot to do with
it examples has a lot to do with it
quality of the video itself has a lot to
do with it so there's a lot of
components so all those components on a
high quality video are going to lead to
engagement so parts of what you could do
in your videos is conduct a quiz so
meaning the quiz itself is a way to keep
people engaged in your video so that
also help you get some more comments so
according to backlinku video comments
help and rank in your video higher so
just as I mentioned the last segment
about YouTube analytics and all the
different reports available on YouTube
hey if you have questions in those just
go ahead and add a comment so that's a
way to entice your users or your viewers
to add comments is if they have quite
questions because you know with videos
you're not going to be able to cover
every detail or every minute detail
about a particular topic you can only
cover in some cases the topic at a high
level so users are going to have
comments or questions naturally and so
the comments section is a good way to
remind viewers hey if you have a
question or comment go ahead and put in
the comment section because that will
lend to engagement as well so we want to
add sources from high quality websites
that'll help with engagement okay use
humor in your video we want to be able
to basically you know make it human
based we don't want to be robots so we
want to be able to sound like you know
we know what we're talking about but at
the same time talk to the viewer not
necessarily at the viewer or looking the
other way and just going through the
motions so adding humor adding
personality never hurts at the end of
the day we are all human adding that
clear call to action at the end of the
video will also lead to engagement so if
we win the video with hey leave your
comments on this video or hey feel free
to share this video with colleagues who
are interested then that's a call to
action that's likely going to lead to
more engagement reply to your comments
as well so if you have comments we
always want to reply to them likely
those comments are going to be questions
because again as I mentioned even in
this video about how to rank your videos
on YouTube okay there's a lot of
information and a lot of information
sometimes doesn't get covered in its
entirety and so we want to make sure
that if we miss something because we're
only human that we're able to respond in
the form of an answer to a question that
somebody leaves in the comments section
so more comments also lead to higher
rankings because it's engagement so when
you're getting high engagement and your
video starts to rank well you know
you're going to start feeling really
good and what is that going to do look
at that feel feel good is going to lead
to confidence which in turn is going to
probably lead to more videos and that's
exactly what we do at simply learn I
mean we're in the education business but
we're in it to not only educate but
making sure that our videos are shown to
as many people as possible so that we
can educate as many people as possible
so it's all it's contagious so getting
ranked feels good and then once you get
ranked then you know you probably have
good engagement okay let's talk about
how to promote your content so once
you've done all the hard work getting
your video done high quality content
optimized with keywords and then publish
to YouTube we want to let everybody in
the world know about it right so we want
to promote it we've done all the work we
want to promote it now so is it
necessary to promote it I would say yes
because once your video is published you
want to reach out you want to reach out
to your audience not necessarily on
YouTube but on different platforms so if
you're active on Facebook or Twitter
that's an opportunity for you to post or
tweet something about the new video so
when we say different platforms I am
talking about you know social media
platforms so it depends on what you're
active on so if you're active on
Facebook yeah go ahead and post some
you're active on Twitter go ahead and
tweet something it could be you know on
LinkedIn group if you're part of a
LinkedIn group about you know machine
learning then go ahead and post
something to that group to promote the
video so that's going to help Drive
traffic to the video and then help with
engagement so we want to engage with our
audience on those social media sites so
it really depends on what you're active
on so if you have a large following on
Twitter then go ahead and you know share
that YouTube video link on Twitter with
the Tweet that's going to drive traffic
from Twitter to YouTube Remember You
know you're going to be able to see
audience engagement or retention by
getting people to watch the video so
you're going to be able to see right
away by promoting the video and driving
traffic to the video how engaging it is
remember the more people you have
watched the video the more engaging it
becomes the better it's going to rain so
it's an ecosystem and promoting your
content is part of that ecosystem so it
all starts with social media if you're
active on whatever platform that is go
ahead and promote it so you can also
look at you know content based social
media sites or social media content
based platforms like Reddit or Flickr
for example so you can participate in a
forum discussion on Reddit so in this
example here it's about machine learning
so we want to be able to post something
about machine learning with the link to
our video so we can also go to
content-based sites that are q a uh
related like quora for example core is a
really good site where you know if you
go there post information about machine
learning or the basics of machine
learning with the link back to the video
it's going to help because not only is
it going to drive traffic but it's going
to signal to Google hey you get a lot of
traffic coming from Cora this is going
to bode well for this video in terms of
ranking so here's an example you know if
you find a question that you can post on
core then you're gonna get people to
click on your video and respond
accordingly on Quorum or you can act as
the person responding to a question
that's already there so somebody already
asked a question about what is machine
learning you can respond with your video
as the answer so you can just simply
embed your video URL as part of your
answer that'll help Drive traffic so you
can also create your own blog and embed
your video so in the case of machine
learning here we have an example machine
learning what is it and why it matters
so this goes nicely with the video so
here you can see the person the author
of this blog went ahead and embedded the
relevant video in the blog post so they
play off one another nicely you can also
opt in for influencer marketing meaning
hey you can reach out to somebody in
this example here you know Katie nuggets
posted information about machine
learning so in this case why choose
machine learning as a career well they
get information and then what do they do
they went ahead and embedded the video
about machine learning Basics and so
working with you know influencers in a
particular category or topic will help
Drive traffic to the video you can also
create a YouTube playlist so playlists
tend to rank high in YouTube searches so
if you find yourself doing a lot of
videos we'll go ahead and you know go to
your channel and simply on your channel
you can go ahead and create playlists so
when you create playlists basically what
you're doing is you're organizing the
content into different playlists no
different than say the music you have
set up on your you know your iPhone or
iPad or or iPod whatever it is you're
using so you're just creating different
videos in a particular category and it
you YouTube likes it it's organized it's
going to help you get your videos found
quicker and easier on YouTube Itself by
putting your videos in a playlist so
here you can see we have entire playlist
on machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing Big Data
digital marketing project management so
a lot of different playlists very
organized if somebody goes to the
channel they're going to be able to go
to the playlist that's interesting to
them and see all the videos there so it
allows not only the end user to find
what they're looking for but it's good
for YouTube because YouTube likes those
playlists so we want to engage our
Audience by posting your video link on a
community page so you could do that
within YouTube and you can prefer to
link your YouTube channel in your email
so you can also do that so for example
if I go back to YouTube and I'm looking
at a YouTube video you know I can always
Click Share so here I'm gonna get a
particular URL that's associated with
the video and I can just embed that so I
can embed the whole thing in my email I
can embed it on a web page or a blog
post so just by clicking share I can
also immediately share it onto the
social media platforms that we mentioned
Facebook LinkedIn Reddit okay Tumblr so
there's a lot of ways to embed the video
not just not a blog post or influencer
blog posts but in our email and on
social media as well so here's an
example of what we can do with a YouTube
discussion so we can also bookmark the
video on a popular bookmarking site you
know like stumbled upon or read it or
you know there's lots of other ones out
there so there's plenty of sites that
you'll be able to go to and bookmark
that content so that people can find it
and you can always opt for backlinks so
that means that hey if there's a blogger
out there that blogs about machine
learning you can always you know ask
that that blogger to create a link back
to the video and you could reciprocate
do the same thing so that helps increase
the authority of the video so a lot of
things you could do to promote your
video so let's do a quick review on
everything we talked about in terms of
ranking your video on YouTube it all
starts with the keywords so we want to
identify a list of keywords that are
relevant to the video so we can use
tools to choose our keywords but
remember we want to choose keywords that
have high volume and low competition and
so where can we go to choose those
keywords well we can use the
autocomplete on YouTube we could check
out our own competitors videos or you
know we could use vid IQ or tubebuddy or
any of these extensions in Chrome to
help us look at the keywords that are
tagged with a particular video so
remember we want to have a primary
keyword that's aligned with the content
then we want to choose LSI keywords as
our secondary keyword are keywords that
are related to the primary keyword so we
want to create high retention videos
meaning that first 15 seconds of the
most important but throughout the video
we want to use examples we want to keep
it interacting by adding quizzes imagery
good audio good video quality so we want
to focus on the user experience and we
also want to optimize our video content
what does that mean well those keywords
that we chose we want to use them in the
title we want to use them in the
description we want to use them as
hashtags we want to use them and tag
them with the video themselves so we can
add keywords to our meta tag okay we
don't want to overdo it but we want to
add a handful of keywords that are
associated with the video so we want to
be able to write eye catchy video titles
and descriptions so remember use some of
those key phrases like a number or a
question like what is machine learning
so we want to use relevant meta tags for
the videos and we want to use popular
YouTube tags so we want to be able to
tag our videos appropriately to watch
the length of your meta tags so there
are links involved remember keywords at
the beginning of the title Target
keywords in the title description and
tags we want to use interesting
thumbnails to increase our click-through
rate ensure that thumbnails are relevant
meaning when I say thumbnails I mean the
actual title tag itself or The Meta
description we want to use high res
videos we want to create you know videos
with good high audio quality don't be
afraid to put in video effects like some
animation don't be afraid to use
examples and then you know obviously
look at the draft of the video before
you publish it so does your video follow
an outline is it organized so these are
all the things to take into account and
there's there's plenty more you can do
you know you remember once you create
and optimize that video you want to
promote it you want to make sure that
you're sharing it on social media you
create a complimentary blog you know
generate backlinks from say other blog
posts so there are lots of things you
can do to promote your video so before
you promote it you want to organize the
content create good quality content
align it with keywords once you publish
it you know keep organizing it by
creating this playlists and then reach
out on social reach out on different
communities related to the topic and all
those things combined will help you to
get your YouTube video ranked so again
some key takeaways here use the keyword
research Available to You on YouTube you
want to basically you know watch your
descriptions you want to be able to
align your keywords with your title and
meta tag description you want to be able
to promote your content on social media
on social bookmarking though and I can't
stress enough create a high quality
video first 15 seconds are important but
you're gonna know if you have good
quality video because every video has
analytics associated with it so we want
to keep in mind find the engagement so
just by looking at the video itself so
here I can see this blockchain in seven
minutes it was just posted just
yesterday the 27th so basically already
42 likes 33 comments 378 views so these
are all engagement related metrics so
you'll be able to just look at the front
of any video and see how well it's
performing from an engagement standpoint
now when we're talking about the trends
there are significant shifts happening
in organic search the first of which is
machine learning uh that is more
artificial intelligence analyzing search
queries and developing new algorithms
within the machine learning to serve up
results determine intent which is the
primary goal of machine learning and to
return not only the results but the
information you need as well as
predicting information you might need in
the near future
uh the second is voice search more and
more voice assistants are becoming
popular through your smartphone through
your laptop through home assistance and
people are asking for information and so
it is completely happening at an
auditory level not in visual level and
so how that is happening and how that
affects SEO reporting is really going to
be a factor moving forward and then also
as I'm sure if you've been doing any
search engine optimization for any
length of time you are familiar with the
struggle uh that has happened ever since
Google decided to strip keyword data out
of any analytics reporting that took
away really the number one way that you
were able to measure the effectiveness
of gaining keywords in the search
engines
now to hit each one of these just to
explain them a little bit more so that
you know exactly what's happening and
what it looks like as it affects your
current level of SEO work as well as
reporting uh as an example of machine
learning uh if you go into Google
AdWords right now and you were to set up
a campaign looking at maybe like auto
body or Auto work or something like that
if you typed in a few keywords into
Google what's happening is Google is
only reporting one phrase that might
cover two or three or four phrases based
on
for example Auto Body being is it one
word or is it two words Google here is
providing it as two words so even if I
type in auto body as a single word this
is where the machine learning is coming
in realizing that these are the same
queries and so rather than treat them as
individual queries what is happening is
through machine learning is they are
trying to figure out what is the intent
of the search and then grouping the
intent into single categories or single
searches and then all the variations
would be included in that now if I do
keyword research at a third party such
as word tracker or something like that
now what I'm going to find are multiple
different ways that people search uh
they're going to put in locations
they're going to put in details they're
going to you know use one word two words
and so in a third party keyword research
format we're going to see a lot more
variations because those are tracking
what people are actually typing in what
Google is doing from the machine
learning standpoint is condensing
everything and trying to group it into
as I said similar forms of intent
now What's Happening Here It means that
phrases or words that are plurals
acronyms
typical variants uh
such as words that may mean the same
thing uh but then they're different
words so they're going to group them
together and then also as you saw there
words with spaces or without spaces uh
conjunction words as well as hyphens and
apostrophes a lot of these are going to
fall out of what you're able to bid on
also in the paid search side and it will
all go into a particular group of words
under a primary heading so that's where
voice search is taking us is really a
condensing of the language into intent
what are people searching for and how do
we give that their in how do we give
their information back to them now
obviously this isn't perfect I've worked
with a number of clients where
they may offer a service and because of
that service Google is trying to then
associate them with another service uh
and it's not relevant and so because of
that machine learning sometimes uh what
we're seeing is a difficulty in trying
to get unique businesses new ideas or
something that just isn't a part of that
overall big picture uh they're trying to
force it into neat little boxes but as
we know business is not full of neat
little boxes uh it's messy it's fuzzy
it's it's all kinds of different types
of businesses suppliers industries that
are going to have some level of
uniqueness about them so hopefully this
can continue to improve uh but it does
at this point still need some human
intervention
the second aspect is voice search and
maybe some of you have uh maybe the
Google home or the Alexa Appliance in
your home and you've been playing around
with it and seeing what it can do uh but
also everyone's phone uh and then also
Cortana is on uh any Microsoft operating
system desktop and so being able to
search from your phone simply by a voice
command uh now this is affecting our
ability to report because this does not
show up uh as a search now if you're
using Google now and you are searching
on Google or a Google app it will show
up as a search referral however if
you're using Cortana if you're using uh
Siri it's going to use the
search engine of the operating system
and so in that case and I'm going to
address this a little bit later it shows
up as a direct visit rather than uh a
search initiated visit and so this is
affecting the reporting of SEO metrics
uh but at the same time it is also
changing the search landscape entirely
right now uh Amazon is probably Google's
biggest competitor for most searches
especially for electronics uh especially
for uh what you would consider things
for home uh and garden Amazon and right
now it has taken about 40 percent of the
market share away from Google in terms
of electronics and Home Products because
people are going to Amazon first and
they're using Alexa to do this so how
voice search it really is going to be uh
a volatile industry to follow over the
next five years
and then as I mentioned before probably
the biggest frustration of anyone doing
search engine optimization or wanting to
measure the effectiveness of
optimization or where they stand in the
marketplace is the keyword not provided
uh now there's a number of reasons why
Google has gone about this the first
reason that they gave was for privacy
reasons uh that they wanted people's
searches to be private but at the same
time if you are doing paid search you
have full access to keywords and also if
you are advertising through Google you
can Target People based on their Search
terms so we know the Privacy thing uh
was really kind of a smoke screen I
think what's going on here is that this
was really the first step to getting
people away from thinking of individual
keywords or key phrases and focusing on
one or two phrases that there that would
describe their business by taking away
the vast majority of keywords that
you're going to see in your analytics it
will force you to look at other words it
will force you to think bigger picture
rather than those one or two words that
most people believe that's what my
business needs this is where I'm going
to focus my attention and in in so in
some ways this has been good by making
people forcing people to think Beyond a
single word or a single phrase about
their business and looking into the
bigger picture this also plays into the
machine learning because as I showed you
before machine learning is condensing
all of these keyword phrases trying to
determine intent and what better way to
really assist that than to start taking
away keyword data in the search engines
however when you take that away you have
then taken away the number one reporting
fact
of SEO and that is what keywords am I
ranking for what keywords are bringing
in not only visitors but business and so
by taking away the number one factor
we're forced to look at a number of
different methods that we can use then
to develop better campaign metrics
now one of the first things about uh
metrics is the expectations whenever I
work with a company I want to know
specifically what are your expectations
for the campaign what are you trying to
get out of it what do you expect uh I'll
never forget I was uh Consulting with an
agency about how they are developing
their SEO campaigns and how they were
reporting them to their clients uh and I
went with them oops to one of their
client meetings and after some of the
agency people left
um I asked if I could talk with a client
for a bit after the meeting and because
the main reason was on this white board
in the corner of their office they had
visits this month and visits last month
and the client asked me about the agency
um you know what I was doing for them
and what they what the agency was trying
to do and then they said that they had
concerns and the reason why they had
concerns is that the visits last month
uh were higher than the visits this
month and that over the past few months
the number of visits had been going down
and because of that they were having a
lack of confidence in their agency
now this was really kind of surprising
because this goes right to the heart of
client expectations
uh no when I had asked that client then
after that you know towards the end of
the conversation is how how is your
business how are leads how are your key
performance indicators how are the
conversions on the site
basically asking them how's business uh
and the response to that was well
business is great business has been
improving over the past few months
however the primary metrics they were
looking at was visits rather than the
business oriented metrics and so this is
where establishing expectations of what
campaign metrics we're going to follow
and what those campaign metrics mean to
a business this is a conversation that
must take place rather than just
reporting basic information the same
charts and graphs every month or every
quarter that really might not
communicate the information that
everyone needs and so a conversation
between agencies and clients about what
are the expectations of this SEO
campaign what do we want out of that and
what constitutes success that
conversation needs to take place and
then that will determine how the
campaign metrics are then developed and
presented and the discussion that will
happen around them
now one thing that I think has been uh
you know I would say both a struggle as
well as what needs to happen the the
first thing about SEO metrics is the
myth of the number one ranking once in a
while I'll still run into this where
someone will
hinge the entire success of a campaign
by seeing the number one ranking they
want a single word or a tooth word
phrase to rank number one in Google and
that is their only standard of success
uh unfortunately I you know anymore I
will not even work with that kind of a
client because it's an unrealistic
expectation and it also shows a complete
ignorance of how search works and what
it the power of what it can bring to
your business that this is much bigger
than a number one ranking and if that's
all you want then give me a budget we'll
pay for it uh but I would say for the
most part we've moved Beyond a number
one ranking uh and now what we have to
educate people on is that rankings are
really a personal metric that you the
rankings you see are probably going to
be slightly different than everybody
else and I'm going to walk through why
that happens and so you can help educate
people within your own organization of
why ranking is a personal metric now
rather than a universal metric
and then of course as I had mentioned
before it's on the expectations
campaign metrics need to focus on the
business objectives not just on the
external factors of rankings and and
somewhat invisibility uh we want to look
at the visibility of a company but
ultimately what we need to look at is
how is your search campaign
delivering on your business objectives
because that's the point of it all is
what are we what are we trying to
accomplish and how is it being
accomplished
see it's when I see charts like this
that still make me a little queasy and
still make me roll my eyes this was done
uh about two years ago asking people
what are you measuring and unfortunately
there hasn't been much change since this
initial survey that the vast majority of
people are measuring the number of
visits to the website
uh and then they're measuring social
sharing time on site and less than half
are still measuring SEO rankings
um now that still boggles my mind
because that's what I'm going to walk
through here is why we can't measure SEO
rankings it is a completely undependable
metric and so
what what really surprises me shocks me
is that 35 percent of people are
measuring subscriber growth and 27 a
little more than a fourth of businesses
surveyed here are measuring sales leads
this is what it shows so shocking and
surprising especially when we come to
campaign metrics and expectations of a
client and that is what are the business
objectives what is it that you want to
grow because the last column here sales
leads is what makes business grow that
is a direct contributor to revenue
and subscriber growth well that builds
my list and marketing to my list is a
direct contributor to revenue
and so as I said this is just so
mind-boggling because the two things
that directly contribute that have a
direct impact on Revenue are the least
measured in this survey the four things
that have an indirect impact uh meaning
that you can have is as I mentioned
before an incredible number of website
visits but absolutely no Revenue coming
in as a result of that
these are all key performance indicators
visits sharing time on site those are
key performance indicators they're not
business objectives and so part of the
expectations of developing campaign
metrics is understanding the difference
between a key performance indicator and
a business objective because it's easy
to get sidetracked especially with
search metrics especially with these
types of things of you know visits time
on site page views rankings but they're
all indirect which is why they are under
the key performance indicator uh
grouping whereas we want to look at the
business objectives of subscribers sales
leads downloads getting information into
people's hands engaging with them and
moving along the customer Journey when
we can develop metrics that focus on the
experience of a prospect or a customer
then
and tie that to our SEO performance now
we're developing how our Campaign Will
directly impact the business and the
customer
now I want to just go off to the side
for a little bit here and talk about
rankings and this is the whole concept
of rankings are personal not Universal
now you'll notice on this this is the
this is a uh a rankings report from 2008
and compared to 2006. I had to go back
really far to find this screenshot and
this is a uh if you were doing a search
for the keyword latest news this would
show you who ranked number one uh and
the change in the rankings over the past
two years and it also we're looking at
it in Google and MSN for some of you
this may look really familiar because
what this did is you put in the domains
that you were tracking the keywords
and you would get a report about who
ranks where for what keyword now this is
back in the day and even around 2008 uh
we were still seeing some or we were
starting to see fluctuations in rankings
based on where you are searching from as
well as some history coming in but we
weren't seeing it to the extent that we
see it today
you see now today your rankings that you
see are largely based on your search
history
it's based on past searches it's based
on content preferences uh what types of
content you tend to search on click on
or visit uh what business or industry
you tend to uh search on
as well as any behaviors such as your
predilection to click on ads paid ads
display ads or anything like that and so
what's happening here is this has been
actually going on for the past 10 years
is that more and more of your rankings
are going to be personalized to your
unique history and the words the sites
that you visit the words you use the
types of queries that you make all of
this is being developed in order to
provide you the most relevant personal
results
ultimately it's also being done in order
to focus the paid search ads
specifically to you and your behavior
and the industry that you're in because
that's how the search engines monetize
so the better they understand you and
what you're looking for and again it all
comes down to intent if they can figure
out your intent and provide you results
that are relevant both paid and organic
then that's the goal that's what they're
trying to do and so simply based on your
history we're seeing that rankings are
going to vary from person to person and
maybe even from computer to computer to
smartphone depending upon how you use
them
the second thing is Regional results uh
if you search for specific things in one
region
it's going to show up differently in
other regions if I search for right now
if I go to Google and type in Ford
dealership I'm going to see the one
that's near me and I'm not going to see
one that's out in another state or
another region because based on the
localization that search engines are
providing it's going to look at that
query as a localized result and serve it
to me specifically
So based on location now sometimes we
will see things brands are more Global
however if I'm looking for something
that is specific to my region that can
be based on my IP addressed my country
my city my state even into a zip code uh
local results targeted results can be
limited to a small area to only show to
people who are within that area or
searching in that area
and so more and more based on
localization we're seeing that affect
the results and that has been highly
impactful especially over the past two
to three years as local search has just
gotten miles better uh in all of the
search engines and it's only going to
increase as well
uh but then also based on the different
types of media based on language based
on the type of search uh the intent of
search or what words you might use uh as
well as here we have the machine
learning come in uh what you'll notice
here is simply if I do a search for
something in Spanish as compared to
English I get different results I get a
completely different results page uh
there's more videos on the Spanish
results uh from the Spanish search then
the English uh also the makeup of the
page is completely different
so the words you use how you structure
the query the language those are all
going to affect the type of results that
you see and then also you can see here
is that the organic results you know
we're seeing videos uh taking over
results how to's uh actual uh you know
multiple things happening in the search
engine results page and so it's no
longer just a list of 10 links and
running a ranking report to see where
you rank because What's Happening Here
is we're seeing multiple videos being
served prior to even seeing any what you
would call a traditional link or
traditional website snippet here showing
up in the search engine results page so
as you can see all of these things are
just completely transforming
a individual's rankings and so if you
were to measure rankings what you're
measuring is unreality uh you're you're
measuring something that doesn't exist
uh and as I like to say it's a it's
extinct before it's even run because no
person will ever see a ranking report
they will see that reflected in their
results it's going to be personalized
and unique
something also to throw into the mix
that even based on your device you are
going to see different results primary
reason is because if you're using a
smartphone it knows your location and so
you're going to have location results
mixed in also based on contracts with
different search providers with
different uh
uh you know licensing from Google
licensing from YouTube uh the results
will be different based on the phone you
use based on the provider that you have
and based on uh simply just being mobile
as opposed to desktop so results are
different based on the device so
hopefully if anyone uh was hoping to run
a simple ranking report as an SEO
campaign metric uh just this little side
light here has shown it's really a
non-starter anymore the traditional
ranking report is extinct and we have to
move beyond that so how do we move
beyond that because there's also now
that I just shared the the difficulties
of a traditional ranking report we also
have a couple other obstacles thrown at
us that are specifically uh both from a
search engine standpoint and from a user
standpoint
the first obstacle that we're running
into is from a search engine standpoint
this is what Google is doing if I do a
search for top car reviews in 2017 at
the very top of the results
I get a snippet of information
uh pulled from Consumer Reports now
what's happening here and you may have
seen this as well if you type a question
or something like that that Google is
not only displaying websites but they're
displaying the answers and they're
pulling the content from these websites
now when they do that that does not show
up as a visit and it doesn't show up as
a ranking to Consumer Reports Consumer
Reports has no method of tracking this
visibility and it's incredible
visibility
so at one point Google is providing
information to the searcher but the
owner of this result is having its
content displayed by Google without any
knowledge that it's happening unless
someone has gotten in in order to see
that so
this is a significant amount of
visibility that right now goes
unreported because there's no way to
integrate this into any metric
calculation uh other than a visual
inspection to see what's happening with
this
we're going to see more and more of this
Google is presenting more and more
answers through the search engine
results page rather than just the
website
the main reason is Google has seen the
more they do this the more they deliver
the answer in the search engine results
page rather than having people click
through to go to a website
they find that people are more likely to
come back and use Google again
and what's happening here is that Google
essentially is eliminating The Click
through they're trying to keep people on
the search engine results page as long
as possible think about some of the
searches you've done recently if you
search for weather information you
search for flight information if you
search for sports scores on Google uh
those types of things you're going to
get your answer in the search results
page you don't even have to click
anywhere else to get the information
it's right there
this is going to not only grow under
Google but this is really the big
question mark as to what is the whole
purpose of Google and what are they
doing and how does it benefit me as a
website being in these results when I
can't track this and when Google is
trying to keep people on their site on
their property as long as possible this
is the big question mark moving forward
for SEO metrics
the other side of this is from a
consumer standpoint and this is what we
call dark search dark search are
searches that originate from a
non-traditional search engine for
example if you do a search from your
computer for example Cortana or if you
do a search from your operating system
in uh in apple you can do a search uh
almost on the uh the desktop through the
spotlight search and it will bring up
search results
if you go through that uh it's using
basically the search engine capability
built into the operating system but it
doesn't get reported as a search engine
referral
instead what's happening is it sending
you to that site as a direct traffic so
anything that's from an operating system
a search that comes through an app now
if you're using the Google app this is
kind of a kind of a gray area
um but it does happen uh so you
basically have to install the Google
Search app or use something in the
browser but if you're in an app with a
search function and the app is not a
search engine app it will show up as
direct traffic uh your voice based
searches that's using the operating
system uh now you can use a voice based
search in the Google Search app and that
will show up as a search referral I know
this might get a little confusing uh but
this also is you know this is sort of
the dark search of what's going on uh
and then also Amazon like I said is
stealing a lot of business away from
Google but there's no way to really know
what your Amazon ranking is for a
specific product or query uh so in that
way you're kind of losing some of
whatever Amazon is taking we're also
losing some of that data
so those are some of the obstacles that
we're running into in terms of getting a
big picture of campaign metrics
so like I said
we need to start with a business goal
when we start developing campaign
metrics this is where the expectations
need to be very very clear uh and I kind
of like the acronym of clear here that
we need to clearly State what is the
business purpose what are we trying to
ultimately accomplish and how will
search help to accomplish that
based on that we create a set of goals
we lay out the goals of a campaign what
do we want people to do and then carry
that over into how does that accomplish
the purpose
we then explain how and define success
explain how success is accomplished as
people meet those goals how does that
fit into the customer Journey where is
that in the customer Journey how does it
move them from one stage to the next how
do we measure that and how do we Define
that as success then we align metrics to
that strategy we don't just start with
the metrics we start with the purpose
the goal defining success and then
aligning metrics
as we have our strategy and then the
final stage is the ideal customer
experience how do we relate that through
these metrics how do we explain that our
customer has seen this and then they did
this or they looked for this information
and it was a successful visit now what
will they need this is where we look at
the overall customer journey and how
search is a part of that Journey
now getting into some very specific
metrics that will assist this one of the
things that I like to look at and this
can be a part of the reporting if I'm
looking at just the cold hard facts of
of SEO campaign metrics one of the first
things I'm going to look at is that
audience overview and I'm going to look
specifically at my organic traffic now
one of the things I need to caution is
making sure and I'm I'm surprised I
still have to say this is comparing like
time frames you can compare year over
year if you're comparing the entire year
quarter to quarter example is I'm
looking at first quarter 2017 compared
to first quarter 2016. I want to compare
like time frames I am amazed at how many
businesses still look at month to month
to month to month and there's such a
drastic difference between month to
month you have to compare this quarter
to the same quarter last year this month
this year to let that you have to
compare the like time frames going month
to month is is a is chasing your tail
so from here I want to specifically just
look at my organic coverage at this
point what I'm looking at here is with
the audience overview I'm looking at my
total number of sessions this year
compared to last year and I can see that
it's higher uh and in some areas I've
seen some dips uh but then when I went
to go look at specifically in Google
this year or this first quarter compared
to first quarter last year where am I at
in terms of sessions new users bounce
rate conversion rate and transactions
that's what's going to help me as far as
getting the first step in my SEO metrics
the next is looking at total organic
visits this is anything that comes
through search now again this is part of
the conversation this is everything we
can track
uh because there are things that are
completely outside of this uh
this might be a good time to say this I
was talking to an analytics provider a
couple of years ago and in comparing
different analytics systems and I asked
them what makes your analytics more
accurate than your competitors it was
very interesting because this is the
lead engineer and he sort of shushed me
this was on the trade show floor and he
says in analytics we don't talk about
accuracy
he says what I like to say is that our
analytics are less inaccurate than our
class than our competitors
and that is really the case when it
comes to analytics if you've ever
compared analytics from two different
systems and looking at the same metrics
they never agree I'm always amazed at
how many people try to make their Google
analytics line up with their omniture
analytics and it will never happen or
they'll look at multiple different
packages or they'll tell me my agency is
reporting these numbers but these
numbers are what I'm seeing and they're
using two different systems
that's because
Analytics
it's tracking what it can track and what
is unclear an algorithm tries to
organize it or an algorithm tries to
assign things that are unclear to
different areas so each analytics
program kind of has its own methodology
of organizing the information and
interpreting it based on that that's
where you come up with the we're less
inaccurate than our competitors so when
we're measuring organic coverage we're
measuring what we can based on this
system it may not agree with another
system don't try to make it agree
because it just simply won't
now here I'm looking at my total organic
search visits and I can see compared to
the the year prior this quarter is up 18
in visits I can look at total
conversions and I can see that it's up
30 percent uh and then also what I want
to do is look at landing pages and my
keyword Concepts
now this is a sense because the search
engines don't provide us any keyword
data what we can do is look at our
landing pages and the amount of visits
those landing pages are generating
then it doesn't take much to kind of
look at those landing pages and see what
what are they basically about what are
those keyword Concepts now you can go to
Google Search console you can go to Bing
webmaster tools and you can see which
keywords uh are driving traffic to your
business through those webmaster portals
and you can get the concept of what
keywords are driving traffic now one
thing I do like about Bing webmaster
tools is that Bing webmaster tools will
not only show me which keywords I'm
ranking for and which ones are sending
traffic to my website but they will also
show me which Pages or the recipients of
those keywords so they are able to tie
together the keywords and the landing
pages and so I'll do that in bing uh on
also Google search console will do that
to an extent
but to some degree this is still a
manual process of looking at my landing
pages and comparing them to the keyword
Concepts as I said Google's trying to
push everything together into intent and
so evaluate your landing pages in terms
of intent what would someone be
searching on in order to get to this
page and utilize Google search console
and Bing webmaster tools maybe some of
your analytics in order to figure that
out
also what I like to look at are
comparative metrics uh when I'm looking
at the success of an SEO campaign as
tied to other types of campaigns I also
want to show the value of search engine
optimization and what it's providing and
so in looking at a source medium I'm
using Google analytics here uh what I
can do here is for this time frame look
at the overall numbers of sessions
generated through each Channel as you
can see there Google on its own is about
67 of all visits Yahoo is providing
about
[Music]
1.28 percent of visits and then we can
see a little less than 20 percent are
direct visits so comparatively I can see
where my search engine optimization is
contributing in comparison to all the
other channels and I can get a sense
there and terms of I can run a revenue
report by Source where I can see where
my search is responsible for the
greatest amount of revenue for the
greatest amount of orders and also when
I look at uh one interesting thing here
I can also do a value per session
breakdown and what this shows me is uh
the email campaigns those by far have
the highest value per session visitors
coming through the blog are next in
value per session and then we can see
our search visitors showing up there as
a significantly high value per session
um
and one thing it might jump out to you
there is you can see that Bing has a
four pound 27 value per session compared
to Google with a one pound 77 that's
normal I
over the past 15 years it has been a
really interesting phenomenon that
visitors from Bing or MSN have a higher
value even though I will get uh just
sheer numbers and higher revenue from
Google but they are higher value visitor
uh than Google visitors uh that's just a
phenomenon that we've just observed for
more than about 15 years and really kind
of interesting there uh so from a metric
standpoint I like doing comparative
metrics to see here's how search
compares to your other channels here's
what it's driving compared to your other
channels in terms of visitors in terms
of Engagement in terms of Revenue and
revenue per user
and again I I kind of mentioned this
associative metrics using Google search
console uh to see some of the keywords
that Google is driving uh Google my
business I'm going to show that uh as we
get into here before we wrap up Bing
webmaster tools as I said they will show
you the keywords as well as the
associated landing pages analytics uh
getting into analytics and looking at
your organic traffic I showed you a few
reports there uh but that is where
people need to live in order to
understand what's going on with their
search traffic and more and more
um alongside analytics I'm seeing a CRM
integration with analytics really
becoming a a different standard because
within the CRM integration I can then
look at the entire customer journey I
can track the initial touch point of a
consumer I can then see how that spreads
into different searches so maybe they'll
find me first from a paid ad but then
how does a subsequent organic searches
contribute to different touch points and
then maybe there is a retargeting touch
Point uh and so I really like what I'm
seeing with modern CRM systems and
tracking more of the customer journey
and how search is a part of it and that
really then gets to the point of looking
at that customer Journey that ideal
customer experience and it immediately
puts it in the context of the purpose of
the campaign uh and the goals of the
campaign focused around the user
experience
when I'm talking with a client laying
out expectations really my first
question is what makes you money because
that's what we want to track there's our
purpose we want to look at sales and
leads and so I want to look at this
prioritized outcomes this gets back to
what is the purpose of the overall
campaign
then we need to look at what are
performance goals now not all of these
goals
carry the same amount of weight what I
mean by that are inquiries support uh
people viewing videos on like chat
subscribes downloads those are all a
different level of Engagement than a
typical like or retweet or a pin
um that's what I call you know it
these are much more active if someone
makes an inquiry that's a lead if they
contact support if they're viewing
videos about new cars that's a
performance goal that means I'm engaging
somebody and I'm answering their
questions uh we can look at people
subscribing and asking for more
information downloading brochures
downloading information this is where
we'll attach different value to
different actions because some actions
will contribute much more in terms of
value in the customer experience than
others and so we want to look at the
performance goals and establish a level
of value around them and then explain
clearly the difference between a
performance goal and a performance
indicator
performance indicators visibility visits
time on site Pages viewed bounce rate
these are all good performance
indicators but they are removed from a
direct impact on the business goals it's
an indirect factor in fact they can even
be misleading if that's what you're
using because you could see that
business goals are excelling while these
numbers might go down or they might go
up and business goals go down because
it's what are you doing with the
information and how are you focusing
your efforts
I want to focus uh real quickly before I
wrap up here on uh Google my business
and this is something that Google has
done more and more of I'm using actually
a local landscaper that I've been
helping out simply because I love the
numbers that are showing up on this
um and it's really cool because you just
put your business in and then you set
the service area so it can be a zip code
it can be a radius uh and then you can
view the insights this is just on the
left side is the login panel and it will
show you how many searches your business
has shown up for in the past month as we
can see here we're over we're almost at
about six and a half thousand searches
where
people searched for uh their business we
we can see about 8.3
000 views of their local listing and
about uh 16
000 actions uh so we can see here this
now this probably right here is probably
going to be I think the future of SEO
metrics the main reason is this is what
happens when you do a search for a local
business and the business box shows up
in the results and the business box has
a picture of the business a description
hours uh pictures
and phone number and what can happen
here just like with the information
where Google is showing all the
information and you don't even have to
click through it this is tracking that
type of visibility this is showing you
how many times simply your business
information showed in the search results
and so now from here we can look
specifically on uh what customers how
they viewed your business and we can see
how many times the business showed up in
Search and how many times it showed up
on maps in the top graph in the lower
graph and this is where I think this is
I I think this where reporting is really
going to be moving is from that business
box in the search results
we're now showing in the past month how
many total actions people have taken and
that is how many people visited the
website from the the inbox information
box how many people requested directions
and how many people called from that
business listing and the far right graph
shows you how many people uh the dark
green so maybe a little over a fourth of
people were looking for the specific
business name
a little more than or a little less than
three quarters of people we're looking
for related keywords and because of that
saw the business information
so from a visibility metric standpoint
within Google search results I love what
Google my business is doing because it's
providing me a view of how many people
are seeing my listing without even
clicking on it but then because of the
interactions available through
smartphone searches local searches map
based searches I can track a lot of this
local activity and how people are then
integrating uh or engaging with my local
search result on google.com
uh so reporting has changed it will
continue to do so that is the only uh
that is the only hard and fast rule here
uh and so metrics need to focus on uh
emphasizing conversion rates optimizing
landing pages and it requires analytics
expertise much more than ever and
ultimately what we want to get to is a
measurement of the user experience like
I said that big picture of the user
experience did they find what they
wanted uh doing task-based user testing
where they have to find a specific bit
of information uh from the search to the
site uh and from that you can gather an
understanding of how quickly they're
able to find it how they can navigate
there both in a desktop and a mobile and
this gets to the the micro moment
assessment when people are searching for
things such as can I afford it uh show
me the new cars
where can I get Finance those types of
micro moment questions that people type
into the search box or speak into their
phone that's where we want to assess the
experience of what do they see what do
they find how easy is it for them to
accomplish their objectives and then
integrate that into a campaign
measurement uh reporting scheme if you
are interested
marketing created in collaboration with
University and meta blueprint is the
perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below in today's video we will be
talking about Google analytics 4 I'm
going to share with you what is the
difference with universal analytics why
you should go on to Google analytics for
as soon as possible how do you migrate
from Universal analytics to Google
analytics 4 and what are the key
features of Google analytics for also
known just ga4 so I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual like the video and if you
want to subscribe to our Channel click
the Subscribe button below but before we
start let me share with you something
new we have a new course a professional
certificate program in digital marketing
which is a number one digital marketing
course together with marketing land and
search engine Journal which we have put
together with Purdue University where
you can learn the top digital marketing
tools with online marketing course
featuring master classes from meta and
Purdue and Harvard's publishing case
studies so this course will set you up
for the meta blueprint certification as
well which is Facebook's leading digital
marketing and Facebook marketing course
where you learn how to use Facebook
advertising and managing your Facebook
page so click on this link if you want
to know more about this program but I
would really recommend you have a look
at this and sign up for this course
which is very good value for money but
before we go on let's move on to talk
about Google analytics 4. so Google
analytics was originally launched in
November 2005 as a free web service it
was based on technology from urgent
software corporation which Google had
acquired in April 2005. now the initial
version of Google analytics was a Sim
bold tool for tracking website traffic
tracking page views and basic user
Behavior
in 2007 Google released a major update
to Google analytics known as Google
analytics 2 which introduced new
features like custom reporting and
advanced segmentation
in 2009 Google acquired odometry a
company that specialized in online
attribution and advertising analytics
and it integrated its technology into
Google analytics in 2011 Google released
Google analytics premium in 2012 Google
did a very important announcement which
was the Google Universal analytics which
was a major overhaul of the Google
analytics as we knew then and it
introduced new tracking methods and
cross-device measurement capabilities
Google also in that year introduced a
Google analytics 360 Suite a suite of
Enterprise analytics tools that included
Google analytics premium as well as
other products for data management and
optimization
in 2019 with the growth in Mobile yeah
Google launched Google analytics app and
web a new version of analytics that
combined web and app tracking into one
platform and then in 2020 Google
launched Google analytics 4 the
successor to Universal analytics which
introduced new features such as
Predictive Analytics AI powered insights
and improved privacy control and to be
precise the launch date was October 14
2020.
so here is what we're going to be
talking about but before I go into that
let me give you a warning Google
analytics 4 is Google's next Generation
measurement solution and it is replacing
Universal Analytics
and it's very important to understand
that on July the 1st
2023 yeah Google will stop processing
data from Universal analytics properties
which basically means it will no longer
track data from websites that run on
universal analytics Google strongly
encourages you to make the switch to
Google analytics 4 as soon as possible
why because you will then start building
up a history of data and you don't start
completely from scratch yeah in 20 in
July 2023 so what's going to happen
beginning in March 2023 if you haven't
already migrated to Google analytics 4
Google will create one for you unless
you opt out this new property will be
based on the settings in your Universal
analytics property
yeah if you have already created a ga4
property and the property is connected
to a universal analytics property then
Google will copy over any configurations
like goals and audiences from your UA
property that you have not marked as
complete in your ga4 property unless
again you opt out
until July the 1st 2023 you can continue
to use and collect data and new data in
your Universal analytics property but
after July 2023 you'll be able to access
your previous process data in your
Universal analytics for at least another
six months
yes so bear in mind that it's only
um tracking it for another six months so
it's very important that if your
historic data is important for you that
you export your historic data during
that time otherwise it'll be gone yeah
so Google will provide a future date
when existing Universal analytics
properties will no longer be available
yeah so after that future date you'll no
longer be able to see your Universal
analytics reports in the analytics
interface or access your Universal
analytics data via an API
okay so it is very important that you
start setting up your Google analytics
as soon as possible and that's what
we're going to be talking about in this
video so here is the agenda we're going
to be talking about what is Google
Analytics
we'll talk about what is Google
analytics for we'll show you some of the
differences between Google analytics 4
and Universal analytics we'll look at
the June of Google analytics for data
model will give you a demo of Google
analytics 4 I'm going to give you the
top 10 tips and tricks and we're going
to close with a case study and for
convenience sake I'm now going to be
talking about ga4 for Google analytics 4
and UA for Google Universal Analytics
okay so before we go into Google
analytics let's talk about web analytics
for a second what is web analytics now
with web analytics refers to the process
of collecting measuring analyzing and
Reporting data related to your website
and the behavior of the people that
visit your website this data can be used
to gain insights into how your visitors
are interacting with your website which
pages are most popular how long visitors
are staying on your website or on a page
which channels are driving the most
traffic and a lot more data that you can
get from this
they typically provide a wide range of
metrics like page views unique visitors
bound rates conversion rates average
time on the page yeah and by analyzing
these metrics you can make Market driven
decisions yeah and data-driven decisions
about how to optimize your website for
better performance better user
engagement better user experience and
increased conversions and increase
revenues it can also be used to track
the effectiveness of your advertising
campaigns of your marketing campaigns of
your website designed or functionality
yeah and the impact of changes that you
make on your website over time so
overall website analytics is an
essential tool for a business or an
organization that has a website because
it provides valuable insights on how
visitors are interacting with your
website and it helps you drive the
improvements that you have to make to be
more successful with your website so
it's very important that you understand
that yes so now then what is Google
Analytics
yeah so
um now Google analytics is a free web
analytics service that's offered by
Google and that helps you to track and
analyze website traffic and user
Behavior
now it's important to know that to use
Google analytics you must install a
tracking code on your website on every
page of your website which allows Google
to collect data on that particular page
yeah on usage and on usual Behavior
this day that is then aggregated and
presented in a user-friendly dashboard
in Google analogytics where users can
access a wide range of reports and
analytics tools to gain insights into
the website performance and user
Behavior
so Google analytics is a powerful web
Analytics tool that provides a wealth of
insights into how users find and use
your website it gives a fantastic deep
understanding of the visitors of your
website including their demographics
their behavior their interests and other
metrics that they're getting
it provides a wide range of data and
insights like number of visitors to the
website where visitors are coming from
which pages are most popular how long
are visitors staying on a page which
channels are driving the most traffic
it also provides insights on visitor
demographics like age like gender like
location and interest which is
information that can be used to Target
your audience and tailor content to um
and optimize your marketing efforts
so the current version of Google
analytics is called Universal analytics
or Google UA
this data model is designed to help
website owners and marketeers understand
how users interact with your website
the data model is built around a
hierarchical structure that allows
website owners to collect and analyze
data from various user interactions on
the website at the top of the hierarchy
are the accounts
yeah they represent a collection of
websites or mobile apps owned by you by
a single entity by a user when each each
within each account there can be
multiple properties
they represent individual websites or
mobile apps
yes so each property has a unique
tracking ID that is used to collect data
on user interactions
within each property there can be
multiple views which represents
different perspectives on the data
collected for that property
yeah they can be used to segment data
based on specific criteria such as
geography device type or user Behavior
at the lowest level of the hierarchy are
the data collection objects which
represents the individual interactions
that user have with a website or a
mobile app
yes so these objects they include page
views they include events transactions
and other user interactions that are
tracked using Google Analytics
overall the universal analytics data
model provides a very flexible and
scalable framework for collecting and
analyzing data from user interactions on
websites and mobile devices
so Google analytics provides a wealth of
information about how visitors interact
with your website which is crucial for
marketing people to optimize their
website
yeah so the information can be used to
identify areas where the website is
performing well and where it is
performing well where it needs
Improvement for example if a website has
a very high bounce rate on certain pages
this may include that the content on
those pages is not engaging enough or
that there are technical issues
preventing users from accessing the
content
by identifying these issues you can make
data driven decisions to optimize the
website and improve the engagement so by
using Google analytics you can gain
insights into key metrics such as
traffic sources bounce rates time spents
on the site and conversion rates
it helps you to make informed decision
that lead to increased traffic
engagement increased conversion and
ultimately Drive business growth
now then what is Google analytics for or
ga4
ga4 represents a major update to the
Google analytics platform and addresses
many of the limitations of UA
while UA provided very valuable insights
into website performance and user
Behavior there were various limitations
to it that led Google to use ga4 one of
the main limitations of UA
was that it relied heavily on cookies to
track user Behavior
and with the right of privacy concerns
and the increasing use of ad blockers
cookies became less reliable as a
tracking mechanism leading to gaps in
data collection
also UA was not designed to track user
Behavior across multiple devices making
it difficult to gain a holistic view of
user interactions
GA has been designed to address these
limitations by providing a more flexible
and privacy friendly tracking mechanism
it uses a new tracking code that relies
off a combination of cookies and
server-side tracking to collect data on
user Behavior
and this approach provides you more
accurate and reliable data collection
while also addressing privacy concerns
so let's dig a bit deeper in Google
Analytics 4.
so ga4 is the new version of Google's
web analytics platform and it decides to
provide you more advanced features and
capabilities
as I mentioned at the beginning of
today's session it is set to replace UA
by July 2023
now there are three groundbreaking
features in ga4 that you need to be
aware of
first of all ga4 is an event driven data
model
it uses an event-driven data model which
means that it tracks user interactions
as discrete events rather than page
views as we saw in Eugene in Universal
Analytics
this gives you more flexibility it gives
you more detail in tracking user
Behavior as you can strike specific
actions that users can take on your site
or your app it also allows for more
cross device and more accurate cross
device and cross-platform measurements
as events can be tracked across
different devices and different channels
the second major Improvement is the AI
powered insights ga4 includes Advanced
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities such as Predictive
Analytics and user life cycle analytics
it helps you better understand your
users and therefore make better
data-driven decisions for example it can
provide insights on which users are more
likely to convert or churn and offer
recommendations on how to optimize your
website or app for better performance
the third major Improvement is the
improved privacy controls ga4 includes
new privacy controls and data retention
settings which give users more control
over their data and allow website owners
to comply with regulations such as your
gdpr and CCPA
for example you can choose to
automatically delete user data after a
certain period of time or provide
opt-out options for users who do not
want their data to be tracked which of
course helps to build trust with users
and this demonstrates a commitment to
responsible data use
so let's expand on this event-based Data
Tracking a key feature of ga4
in UA website owners and marketeers
could track user Behavior by tracking
page views which provided a high level
view of how users were engaging with a
website
however this approach had limitations in
terms of tracking more specific user
interactions such as clicks on a
particular button or filling out a form
ga4's event-driven data model allows you
to track a wide range of user
interactions and discrete events it
provides more flexibility in tracking
user behavior and allows for more
granular insights into how users are
engaging with your website for example
website owners and marketeers can track
user interactions such as clicks form
submissions video plays and downloads
among many other interactions
by tracking user interactions as events
ga4 allows you to Define custom events
and parameters there are a number of
default events that come with ga4 but
you can specify your own events as well
so you can track specific user behaviors
that are unique to your website and your
business goals
for example an e-commerce site could
Define custom events to track user
interactions with their shopping cart or
checkout process providing valuable
insights into how users are progressing
through the conversion funnel
through this events-based tracking ga4
provides more accurate and more
comprehensive views of user behavior and
allow you for better cross-device and
cross-platform measurement
ga4 also provides new privacy control
and retention settings which give users
more control over their data
it allows website owners to comply with
regulations such as to gdpr and the CCPA
for example you can choose to
automatically delete user data over a
certain period of time or provide opt
out of options for users who do not want
their data to be tracked
one of the key privacy features of ga4
is the ability for website owners to
Define their own data retention policies
this allows you to specify how long you
want to retain user Data before it's
automatically deleted
yep and that helps you with complying to
gdpr regulations which require data to
be kept for a limited period of time
and another key privacy feature is ga4's
ability to use server-side tagging this
approach to tracking user behavior in
false sending data directly from the
server to Google analytics rather than
relying on client-side tracking via
cookies
yes so it reduces your Reliance on
cookies which is a really important part
of the Privacy regulations
so Google analytics 4 also integrates
seamlessly with Google's other marketing
and advertising platforms such as Google
ads and Google's marketing platform
by integrating with Google ads ga4
allows you to track the performance of
your ads directly within the ga4
interface it makes it easier to measure
the effectiveness of your ad campaigns
and to optimize your campaigns for
better performance yeah so you can for
example use ga4 to track the key metrics
such as ADD clicks conversions and
revenues generated from your ads
by integrated with Google's marketing
platform ga4 allows you to gain a more
comprehensive view of your marketing
performance across multiple channels
this integration allows you to track
user Behavior across a range of
marketing channels including search
display social media and video
it allows for more seamless data sharing
between the platforms
yes so website owners can use the data
collected in ga4 to inform their Google
ads campaign or use data from the Google
ads to inform their ga4 reporting
right so having that done as an
introduction of ga4 let's look at some
of the differences between Google
analytics the universal the Google UA
and the ga4
so let's summarize these difference the
first one of course that we talked about
was the event-based tracking yeah so the
main focus of universal analytics is on
tracking page views and sessions which
may not provide enough detailed
information and can limit the depth of
insights that websites owners can obtain
with ga4 there is greater emphasis on
event-based tracking which enables you
to Monitor and track specific user
actions and events on your website or
app such as clicks form submissions or
video plays
the next one was the data model
yeah so the hierarchy data model used by
Universal analytics is based on
dimensions and metrics
and this can be less flexible and it's
more rigid in nature where ga4 uses
events and parameters to closely Monitor
and analyze user Behavior across various
touch points and devices
yeah so ga4 allows for more precise and
flexible Data Tracking giving you the
ability to collect and analyze data from
a wider range of touch points and more
devices
the next big difference was in the cross
device tracking
so the cross device tracking
capabilities on UA are limited which
primarily relies on cookies for this
purpose where in ga4 it's Advanced
tracking capabilities ga4 greatly
enhances cross-device tracking enabling
you to gain valuable insights into user
Behavior across various devices and
platforms
and then there were the Privacy features
one of the key differentiators of ga4
universal analytics does not offer some
data privacy features however they are
and those that they that they do offer
they are not as advanced as the privacy
and data retention settings available in
ga4
yeah ga4 provides automatic data Erasure
and built-in data controls which helps
you to comply with data privacy laws and
also gives users more control over their
data
and the next one was the integration
with Google ads and other Google
products yeah but particularly the
Google ads integration is important so
the universal analytics has a very
limited integration with Google's other
marketing products like Google ads while
there is some integration yes which is
the ability to link Google ads and
analytics accounts the level of
integration is not as seamless as you
will get in ga4
ga4 works much deeper has a much deeper
integration with Google ads the
data-driven model allows for more
granular tracking of AD performance yeah
enabling you to understand the best
um the the the results that you're
getting from your campaigns
so those are the key differences between
ga4 and UA and then let's have a look at
the ga4 data model in a bit more detail
because the data model ish
is fundamentally different than on UA
where on UA you had the um the
hierarchical model GA force model is
based on the event tracking
yes so the ga4s data model focuses on
tracking user interactions with a
website or an app as events
and therefore you get more granular and
flexible tracking of user Behavior
you can customize your tracking by
defining custom events parameters and
user properties enabling you to spec to
track specific actions and behaviors
yeah so the ga4 data model is designed
to provide insights into individual user
Behavior across multiple touch points
and devices
allowing you to give a better
understanding of your audience
so in the ga4 data model events are
specific actions that users take while
interacting with your website
these actions can be tracked as discrete
events providing owners website owners
with more granular and actionable data
events can be like clicks on a button a
form submission video place and other
types of user interactions by tracking
events you gain a better understanding
of user Behavior user preferences and it
makes you in a much better position to
make decisions on improving website
performance and user experience
the parameters they provide additional
context and information about the event
such as the value of a transaction the
category of a product Feud or the name
of a button clicked by leveraging
parameters you can get an even better
Insight you can get better segments in
your audience and you get more detailed
insights into user behaviors
so together events and parameters
provide you with granular understanding
of the user behavior of people visiting
your website
okay so enough about the theory let's go
and have a look at Google analytics 4 in
more detail by giving you a demo of the
most important functionality of it
so the best way to access Google
analytics 4 is through the marketing
platform.google.com about
and if you scroll down here you can see
that there is Advanced solutions for
large Enterprises and here you see
analytics for Integrated Solutions for
every Market here
so learn more about analytics that's
where we're going and here you accept
all the details that you need for your
Google Analytics
so there's two ways that you can go and
get your Google analytics setup you can
if you have already got a website on
universal Analytics
then what you do you sign in to
Analytics
that takes you to your existing
Universal analytics account and then you
will see how to upgrade to Google
analytics 4 or you can just start from
scratch with get started today but let's
go the route of signing to analytics so
if we sign into Analytics
it takes you to your existing website
and in my case this is my own website
yeah here you see it's already on ga4
because I've already created a ga4
account so I'm going to change this and
I'm going to take this to my UA account
okay so this is my Universal analytics
account
here when I go there you see immediately
because it is a UA account at the top an
important message that Google says on
the 1st of July 23 we will stop
processing data
Etc yeah and then here you can go to
manage the ga4 migration that's where I
click and now it takes me to my either
the process of turning my UA into a ga4
but since I've already done that it just
says go to your ga4 property
foreign
and by going to my ga4 property I now go
into the setup assistant and the setup
assistant will talk you through all the
steps like data collection the property
settings integration with Google ads
link to Google ads Etc and there is an
advanced setup as well but these are the
basic steps that we need to go through
and the first very important part that I
need to do is to need to collect website
and app data so I haven't started that
yet yeah so I am going to manage the
data streams
so here you see my ga4 property but I
need and I can add another app stream if
I want to or another website but I only
have my website so here I just click on
the details
and this is where I have my stream name
my stream URL My Stream ID my
measurement ID yep and here I see the
enhanced measurements which are the
events that I'm tracking yeah I can
modify event I can create custom events
and here I see my Google tag
instructions so here I can view the tag
instructions
yeah and here I can go
let me have a look
so here you see install your Google tag
and here I can get the installation
instructions I can install it with my
CMS
if that's on the list where I can just
copy the tag ID
so when I have WordPress for instance
there is a ga4 plugin and the only thing
I need to do is to add to plugin code
yep and that is this the tag ID or I can
install manually and that is the piece
of code that I need to install on my
website using Google tag manager now I'm
not going to demo that I'm just making
you aware of this yeah in the next
module next video we're going to be
talking about Google tag manager so
that's watch that video if you want to
know how to take this piece of code and
add it to your website
okay so that gives me all the data I
need to connect my my website to Google
analytics so it starts tracking the data
all right so that is how I can set up
the website for ga4 if I don't want that
I want to start from scratch yeah if I
go back to this site I said get started
today it will again take you to your
existing property
but it will then actually
show you here at the bottom continue
setting up your property try the
analytics demo account yeah or learn
more about data analytics
um yeah and get started with the Google
analytics four so lots of things that
you can get here and it makes it very
easy for you to migrate to your uh to
Google analytics form okay now
let's look into Google analytics for
itself I don't want to do that on my
website I actually want to go to the
Google analytics demo account Google has
a merchandise store and in this
merchandise store they've made the
analytics data available for people to
learn about Google analytics so that's
what we're going to have a look at we're
going to use the Google merchandise
store data to look at Google analytics
for
okay so when you go to Google analytics
for the home page as it were you see
this screen
yeah here you see your menu where you
have your home
yeah that is kind of your dashboards
it's top level reports personalized it
shows reports that you recently viewed
automated insights Etc
you don't have your reports in the
reports they show you pre-configured
reports dedicated reports how people
find your website the pages they viewed
if they convert it to demographics
details about the devices they use and
so on there is the explore in explore
you can create your own reports and
visualize data in different ways like
simple tables funnel visualizations
Etc
then you have your integration with
advertising it lets you feel dedicated
attribution reports see the
relationships between different channels
and how they lead to conversions on your
website and then there is the admin and
in the admin you can access additional
settings for accounts and for your your
property and this is also where you can
create your events your parameters and
your conversions
yeah so there are many reports in Google
analytics 4 which you don't have to use
them all yeah so
um but let's give you some of the
highlights yes so the home is your
dashboard so it gives you the last seven
days by default you can change that of
course you can change it last 28 last 19
you can do comparisons as well yes so
you can also see a trend line
for the selected item yeah so and then
here you see the last sort of the last
the users in the last 30 minutes
the report you've recently viewed and
here it shows you some suggested reports
and here you have to Google AI the
insights and the recommendations yes so
this is very useful information you can
get from Google in um additional
knowledge about what's happening in your
Google analytics so then let's look at
the reports there are multiple reports
the most important one to start with is
your report snapshots your report
snapshot is similar to your home report
it gives you users new users total
revenue yeah users in the last 30
minutes it gives you insights yeah so
basic reporting that you get here it's
your top campaigns users by country how
active users are active users trending
how well do you retain your users
Etc so lots of data that you can get on
this page
okay so that is your report snapshot it
then goes into real time real time we
saw that in Google Universal analytics
as well here you see it actually in a
much more extended version yep so it
shows the the people that are currently
viewing your website so it's very useful
to check where people are lending on
your website for instance when you run
an email campaign check if people do get
to the associated pages with your email
campaign each card include a bar chart
yeah and of course read the users per
minutes from right to left yes so
because this is now yeah and this is
sort of 30 minutes ago
okay so we can see the content people
are viewing you can see the pages they
are viewing the events that are being
collected you can also see the
conversions and the user properties that
people have been collecting
you can also see the granular details of
people so which is the view the user
snapshots
yeah that is a nice little gimmick but
it can also be very useful
it gives a breakdown of the actual
session in events
yeah so here you see uh on a Huawei
phone in Riyadh yeah so you see the
exact sort of event what is happening
they're scrolling they're viewing a
promotion yeah so and if you click on
there's the user engagement if I click
on that then that gives me all the
parameters and the user properties that
you want from that that session so very
useful to get
nitty-gritty data about user engagement
if you want another user just click on
this Arrow yep and if you want to close
this here is the exit snapshot so those
are the real-time overviews and then
here you have on the kind of the life
cycle yeah the reports from acquisition
to engagement to monetization and
retention four categories of reports
kind of following the buyer life cycle
first of all is the acquisition reports
so if we go to the overview it gives you
information about how people are finding
your website it gives you information
about the users it gives you information
about the traffic
so here you see the number of users the
users in the last 30 minutes here you
see users by default Channel grouping
like user analytics I can add an
additional Dimension as well for
instance first user source and medium so
you can say how they were communicated
to and where they were communicated yes
so really useful breakdown of the
information and here you see the
lifetime value that you get from a user
yeah so that's very useful information
so you can also change the date of
course of the report and you can again
compare with previous periods as well
which is stem similar like what we saw
in user Universal analytics as well the
user analytics shows you metrics how
users fund your website at their first
visit
yes so the different channels that they
used hereby
um by bars and by line yeah here you see
the different
um the different channels that they they
use you see a number of new users engage
session engagement rate engage sessions
per user the average engagement time
it's a very useful data that you can see
here and of course you can add a second
dimension as well for instance if you
want to see the way people found your
website combined with the landing page I
can pay put here for instance with the
page and Landing Page Plus query string
so then it gives you where they landed
on your website as well
so very useful the next one is the
traffic acquisition
the traffic acquisition shows you how
people found your website to start each
of their sessions it goes beyond the
very first time they found your website
it's based on sessions so we can see
session based metrics in the table again
you can change the dimension here and
add a second dimension using the plus
sign
we then go to the second category which
are the engagement reports yeah they
show you what people are doing on your
website the pages people are viewing and
the events that are automatically
collected using the enhanced measurement
feature and any other event you are
tracking
yes so if we select pages and screens it
shows you the pages people are viewing
on your website
yeah based Pages reported based on page
title ordered by a number of views
number of page huge number of users
change the default setting as well yeah
so I can add here more information so
page title and screen name I can add if
I want to so different things that I can
I can add yeah so here's the page title
screen class and I can add a dimension
for instance I can say page cream
landing page and query screen
so I can get more detail here yeah so
you can also get to the top level
summary in the overview report so events
shows you all of the events that have
been collected
yeah and you can get click on the name
of the event to get more details on the
event
and the conversion report
yeah yeah so you see the the details of
the event
okay the conversions
it's a total number of conversions for
the date range based on the events that
have been marked as a conversion
okay we then have the monetization
so in the monetization reports you have
e-commerce reports and reports for
in-app purchase and publisher ads these
two reports are to measure purchases and
add Revenue in mobile apps
yes so the total revenue from all the
events and the e-commerce revenue is
from transactions
yeah then you see the total number of
people who made a purchase and the total
who made the first time purchase
both are user-based metrics next to that
we see the average purchase Revenue per
year and the top items being sold
remaining cards are blank yeah because
Google decided not to implement
e-commerce tracking for item lists and
item promotions and coupons
okay so that is your
monetization you have e-commerce
purchases and you also have your in-app
purchases but we haven't got any uh app
integration here so there's nothing
there and then we have your retention
this group shows users in cohorts based
on when users view your websites shows
new and returning but this is all based
on co-words that you've that you've set
and then there is your demographics
report as well
yes so if I go to the user reports there
are your demographic and your Tech
reports demographic is where people are
coming from their location their age
their gender and what have you pretty
standards there's demographic details as
well and then you have your users by
country or by City
yeah and you have your Tech reports
yeah and the tech report shows you the
devices that they use and everything
else in relation to devices and
operating systems
okay so those are the standard reports
in
um Google analytics four yeah so let's
go to the next section and that is the
explore section
in the Explorer section you can create
additional reports
yep there is a library of reports
already available in here that you can
get yeah but you can create your own
reports as well there are blank reports
by clicking on plus there are free form
reports they can create any type of
chart that you would like there's funnel
exploration reports they let you
visualize particular steps you want
people to travel through like steps to
complete a lead form or steps to
complete a an e-commerce checkout you
can do path exploration reports they let
you visualize the path that people take
through your pages or other actions they
take on your website there is your
segment overlap lets you apply multiple
segments to see if users are included in
one or more of your segments there's
cohort exploration that lets you group
users based on the days weeks or visit
your website and then there is the user
lifetime reports they let you view
additional lifetime user metrics
yes so in your own property you will
also find user Explorer which lets you
drill down on the individual users that
isn't available in the Google demo
property yeah so click on any of these
options will pre-load a
um we'll load a pre-configured template
and then here of course you see the
reports that are used by other people so
if you want to create a report from
scratch you just go to the beginning and
you click on the plus
yep and that is basically it is the
Google data studio interface is very
familiar that you you get here yeah so
you can specify your segments your
dimensions and your metrics and by doing
that that is how you can create your
your report now I'm not going to show
you how to create a report yeah but at
least now you have the the route where
to go to create your own reports
okay then we have the advertising
options yeah that is the last section
here in your reports it shows the
relationship between your different
marketing channels
yeah so and they let you apply
attribution models so the snapshot
shows the top level summary of your
marketing channels you can see which
channels drove the most conversions and
it gives you automated insights based on
the Google machine learning
we can also see that be the most
important touch points that people take
leading to conversions there is the
model comparison report it shows you the
marketing channels on the left and on
the right we see the revenue and the
conversions per Channel
yeah so first is based on the
last click attribution model and the
second one is based on the the data
driven the cross-channel data-driven
attribution model so two different
models you can change those if you want
to yes so but this is where you want to
look for significant changes in the
report changes that have a positive
percentage means that we may be
undervaluing the marketing channel when
we use the last click model
changes they have a negative percent
means that they may be overvaluing the
marketing channel when we use the last
click Channel
yes so that is the um the model
comparison and then there is your
conversion path report that provides a
visual representation of the marketing
touch points people engage with before
converting here we can see how some Road
shows that some users are engaged with
our organic search listing multiple
times before converting
yeah people can go through multiple
touch points
yeah this helps you to understand the
relationship between your channels and
how they drive conversions on your
website
yeah you can customize the reports by
changing the dimension used for the pass
and you can change the attribution model
as well
okay so that is everything there is on
the reports as it were in the admin you
can configure your Google analytics for
and you see that here on the right you
can configure your data streams you can
configure your events your conversions
and your audiences
yeah so here you see the events that
have been created for the Google
merchandise store
and here you can add additional events
here you can say whether you want to
Mark the message conversion or not of
course I can't edit this because I
haven't got edit right if I go to the
conversions then here you see the
conversion settings
yeah that you can
and the conversions that you have set
you can specify your audiences
audiences is very important
yeah so you can create all the interest
to report on particular groups of users
this is your segmentation as we knew it
in Google Universal analytics yes so you
can for instance use we've made
purchases on the website or users who
haven't converted yet
or you can use it audiences to focus on
reporting you can also use them for
remarketing in your linked Google ads
account
okay so here are your audiences then
here you have your debug View
yeah so that is where you can test your
uh your events here you can have your
product links yeah so you have your
Google ads links ad manager links and
big query link
yes so bigquery is important
yeah where you can actually link to
Google bigquery where you can import
your data to get more
um reports more visualizations on your
data as well as the links with the
display and the video 360 links so lots
of Integrations
um in Google analytics four and that
concludes the Google analytics 4 demo
yeah so in next week's video you will
see we're going to talk about the Google
tag manager and that is where I will
show you how to add the the code the the
the tagging code to every page of your
website using the the Google tech
manager but for now this is all I want
to share with you on the Google
analytics demo
so I hope that gave you a better
understanding of how to use Google
analytics for and now let's close
today's session with giving you some
tips and tricks and share with you a
case study of a company that very
successfully used ga4 to achieve their
business objectives so let's start with
my tips and tricks number one use
conversion tracking conversion tracking
is vital in your digital marketing yep
and we're in Universal analytics you
could set up goals in um to to track
conversions in Google analytics for you
can track you set them up as events and
they enable you to measure the
effectiveness of your marketing
campaigns and optimize your websites
accordingly so very important to set up
the conversion tracking
Google analytics comes with a number of
standard events and parameters but I
urge you to use custom events impairment
parameters as well set up your own track
your own events yeah that will give you
additional insights in how your users
are acting on your specific website so
very important to um to do that tip
number three set up audience targeting
yeah ga4 allows you to set up
specialized audiences depending on user
Behavior yeah so thereby you can tailor
your message messaging and offering to
certain audience categories yeah so
they're very Advanced audience targeting
capabilities in ga4 so use those
tip number four use machine learning
insights don't overlook those in
Universal analytics they were kind of
Hidden Away in ga4 they are very clear
start using those yes they give you
insights into user behaviors and Trends
and you can really use that intelligence
to optimize your website and your
marketing campaigns
then set up custom reports the reporting
functionality in ga4 is really good very
extensive yeah lots of standard reports
already in there but create your own
reports thereby you gain a more granular
understanding of user behavior and of
course thereby you can optimize your
website accordingly
so use the data layer yeah that's an
important element of Google analytics
for it allows you to use a data layer to
track custom events and parameters and
gain more detailed insights into user
Behavior
setup data streams don't limit your data
to just your website yeah so set up a
stream for your website for mobiles for
apps yes so you can then track data from
different streams giving you a more
granular overview of how people are in
engaging and interacting with your
various platforms
use data import yes so ga4 allows you to
import data from other sources like
Google ads to better understand user
behavior and preferences
tip number nine is to use the big query
integration
ga4 integrates with Google's bigquery
data warehouse allowing you to export
your data for further and deeper
analysis and visualization
and then finally monitor your data
privacy yes so website owners can
monitor your data data provide privacy
settings to make sure that they are
compliant with privacy regulations like
gdpr and CCPA
good finally let's close today's video
but looking at a case study of how
McDonald's in Hong Kong use ga4 to grow
their business
show McDonald's Hong Kong were facing
challenges with its online ordering
system which resulted in low conversion
rates and the high bound rate they
adopted ga4 to get a better insight into
user behavior and preferences
and by using GA Force tracking
capabilities they were able to identify
the specific points where customers were
dropping off the ordering process with
this information they made several
improvements to the order flow including
simplifying the menu and making it
easier to customize orders
also they used a ga4's machine learning
capabilities to identify user patterns
and preferences and personalize the
ordering experience for each user
so they use ga4 to improve their mobile
apps performance and increase in-app
orders
by using the event-based tracking and
data analysis they were able to gain
insights into user behavior and make
data-driven decision to improve the user
behavior and as a result they saw a
significant increase in in-app orders as
well as improvements in user engagement
and retention
as I said they use predictive audiences
in ga4 to identify users who were more
likely to purchase within the app they
use machine learning models to analyze
user behaviors such as in-app purchases
time spent on the app and menu item
preferences to create these predictive
audiences and once these audiences were
created they used them to Target their
advertising efforts to these high value
users with personalized offers and
promotions
so as a result of all these changes
McDonald's Hong Kong saw a 550 increase
in app orders yeah as well as an
increase in customer satisfaction and
customer loyalty
the success of this case study
demonstrates the power of ga4 in
providing insights and actionable data
for improving customer experiences and
driving business growth
yeah so the link to this article of this
case study you will find in the um in
the
the the the notes by in the video yeah
and I highly recommend you read this
article to get more insights in how
McDonald's in Hong Kong use ga4 to grow
their their business if you're
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learn postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below are you looking for a way to cut
through poison identify the most
authoritative websites online for this
you will need to know the domain
authority of website domain Authority a
powerful metric that measures a site's
overall strength and influence in search
engine rankings so in this video we will
dive deep and get a detailed
understanding of domain Authority we
will cover all the aspects of domain
Authority like what domain Authority is
and the key differences between domain
Authority and Page Authority moving
ahead we will understand why domain
Authority is important and how websites
are benefited from domain Authority we
will have a look at domain Authority
score and understand whether it is good
score or not it is necessary to know
that domain Authority changes with time
and how we can calculate domain
Authority we will cover some tools that
may help in finding the domain authority
of the websites next we will have have a
look at five tips to improve domain
Authority for your website but before we
move ahead in this video have a look at
a professional certificate program in
digital marketing some key features of
the program include master classes by
Purdue ask me anything sessions industry
projects and more you will be benefited
from in-depth knowledge of search engine
optimization content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below so
here is a question for you domain
Authority is developed by Option 1
semrush option 2 RFS option 3 most an
option for backlinko
answers in the comment section below and
get a heart from Simply learn in case
you fail to answer stick to the end of
the video to learn more about domain
Authority also don't forget to subscribe
simply learns YouTube channel and never
miss any updates from Simply learn so
let's start by understanding what domain
Authority is
domain Authority is the term first
coined by Moose domain Authority or da
is the search engine ranking score that
shows How likely a website is to rank in
serps a search engine result Pages the
DS score is always between 1 to 100. the
more your website has a DS score the
higher the chances for it to rank in
serps so now you must have a question
what is the difference between domain
Authority and Page Authority the key
difference between domain Authority and
the page Authority is domain Authority
is the score for a complete domain or a
website however a page Authority is the
score for a specific page in the domain
or website moving ahead let us
understand is the domain Authority
important followed by benefits of domain
Authority importance of domain Authority
domain Authority is an important metric
as it is the easiest way to understand
the ranking potential of a website a
higher domain Authority score is
typically associated with the greater
likelihood of ranking well in search
engine result Pages which may lead to
increased traffic and visibility for the
website it can help in getting useful
insights from the competitors or
websites in the same Niche moreover
domain Authority also help in making
strategic decisions around the content
creation link building and overall
website optimization by focusing on
improving domain Authority website
owners can take a concrete steps to
enhance their online presence and
increase their visibility and
credibility in the search engine result
Pages benefits of domain Authority the
benefits of having domain Authority
include improve search engine rankings
with higher domain Authority your
website is more likely to rank well in
serps which can lead to increased
traffic and visibility for the site next
is increased credibility a high domain
Authority score can serve as an
indicator of a website's credibility and
Authority in your industry thus it
builds trust with users and potential
customers the next we have is
competitive Advantage domain authority
of competitors or other relevant sites
will help website owners to gain
insights and identify areas for
improvement giving them a strategic
advantage in the Online Marketplace more
backlinks websites with high domain
Authority scores are more likely to
attract quality backlinks from the other
reputable sites which can further boost
The credibility and ranking power better
user experience by optimizing for a
domain Authority website owners can
focus on creating high quality relevant
content that meets the needs of the
target audience leading to a better
overall user experience and increased
engagement now that we have known the
benefits of domain Authority let's move
forward to understand more about domain
Authority score the domain authority of
any website May lie between 1 to 100
considering one to be the bad score and
100 to be a good so say for example if a
website has da20 then it needs a serious
attention and there is a need to carry
out required SEO practices however do
you know that domain Authority may
change over time yes you heard it right
domain Authority depends on various
factors like links and content these
factors can change over time and as a
result a site's domain Authority score
can fluctuate for example if a site
acquire is high quality inbound links
from reputable sources or improves the
relevance and quality of its content its
domain Authority score May increase
conversely if a site loses inbound links
or its content become outdated or
irrelevant its domain Authority score
May decrease it is important to note
that domain Authority is a relative
metric which means that changes in
domain Authority score can be influenced
by the authority of other sites in the
same Niche or in our stream as such
changes in domain Authority should be
evaluated in the context of broader
Trends and competitors within the
relevant online space now let's find out
how domain Authority is calculated
domain Authority is calculated on
various factors like root domains the
total number of links quality links
content Etc after the update of domain
authority to 2.0 it is calculated with
the help of machine learning algorithms
the work goes as say if x website
appears in search results more
frequently than website y then website X
must have higher da compared to website
y let's now wrap up top 5 tips to
improve the domain Authority tip number
one create high quality relevant content
one of the most important factor in
domain Authority is the relevance and
the quality of content on the site by
creating original well-researched
content that meets the needs and
interests of the audience you can
attract quality inbound links and
increase your site's overall Authority
moving ahead with tip number two build
quality inbound links inbound links from
reputable High Authority sites are an
important factor in domain Authority
focus on building quality inbound links
through the tactics like guest blogging
a influencer Outreach and social media
promotion with inbound links it is also
necessary to have on-page optimization
of pages on the website on-page SEO
factors like title tags meta
descriptions and header tags can help
search engines understand the relevance
and importance of your content by
optimizing your sites on page SEO you
can improve your site's overall
Authority and ranking power with this
you also need to carry out good keyword
research keyword research can help you
to identify topics or freezes relevant
to your target audience by targeting
these keywords in your content you can
improve your site's Authority and
relevance the next step we have is to
improve the site speed and usability a
first user-friendly website can improve
engagement and help to build Authority
with both users and search engines focus
on optimizing site speed and usability
through tactics like image optimization
caching and responsive design moving to
the last step monitor your progress and
adjust strategy domain Authority is a
relative metric which means that it can
be changed over time based on the
authority of other sites in your Niche
or industry monitor your site's domain
authority over time and adjust your
strategy based on Trends and competitive
analysis well these tips will definitely
help you to improve your site's domain
Authority however here we have some
bonus tips for you tip number one
leverage social media social media can
be a valuable tool for building
authority and driving traffic to your
site focus on building a strong social
media presence and sharing high quality
content that resonates with your target
audience next audience engagement engage
your audience through comments social
media and other channels building
relationships with your audience can
help to increase engagement and build
Authority next is monitor your analytics
monitor your site's analytics to
identify area of strengths and
weaknesses use this information to
adjust your strategy and focus on the
tactics that are most effective in
building authority keep your site
updated regularly update your site with
fresh content and keep it up to date
with the latest trends and practices in
your industry the can help to maintain
relevance and build authority over time
now the question arises how we can check
whether the domain Authority is improved
or not we can do this with the help of
tools like most link Explorer ahrefs
semrush Majestic and Google search
console concludingly domain Authority is
a critical metric that can have a
significant impact on your website's
search engine rankings and overall
visibility by improving your domain
Authority these tactics like creating
high quality content building quality
inbound links and optimizing for SEO you
can establish yourself as leader in your
industry and attract more potential
customers to your site while improving
domain Authority takes time and effort
the benefits are well worth it with a
strong domain Authority you can increase
your organic search traffic improve your
Brand's visibility and drive more lead
and sales to your business so if you are
looking to improve your website's
Authority and take your online presence
to Next Level consider implementing some
of the tips and strategies we have
discussed in this video with the right
approach and commitment to building
quality content and links you can
improve your domain Authority and
Achieve long-term success online search
engines are the powerful tool that
allows user to quickly and easily find
information on internet they provide
access to the enormous amount of data
which would otherwise be impossible to
navigate and sort through manually from
research to shopping entertainment to
education search engines have become an
integral part of Modern Life the most
popular search engines use complex
algorithms to analyze and index web
pages allowing them to deliver relevant
results to users based on their queries
the process of ranking and displaying
these results is continually evolving
making search engine optimization also
known as SEO an essential aspect of
online business and marketing in this
era of information overload search
engines are indispensable for anyone
seeking to navigate the vast expanse of
Internet efficiently so hey everyone if
you are looking to grab such a golden
opportunity then you should definitely
look at the professional certificate
program in digital marketing some key
features of this program include master
classes by Purdue ask me anything
sessions industry projects and more you
will be benefited from the in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
research and more so what are you
waiting for hurry up and find the course
Link in the description box below listen
to what millions of users are saying
about our courses find the simple learn
course reviews Link in the description
box
so without any further Ado here we have
a question for you how many search
engine algorithms do you know list their
names in the comment section below and
get a heart from Simply learn also don't
forget to subscribe simply learn and hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn so without any further
Ado let's start by understanding search
engine algorithms a search engine
algorithm is a complex set of rules and
formulas used by search engines to
determine the relevance and importance
of web pages in response to a user's
search query the algorithms takes into
account various factors such as keywords
content quality website architecture
user behavior and many other factors to
determine the ranking of web pages in
search engine result Pages or Subs
search engines like Google Bing and
Yahoo regularly update their algorithms
to improve the quality of search results
and prevent the spammy or low quality
content from ranking high in search
results these updates are often
accompanied by algorithmic penalties and
algorithmic filters which can affect the
visibility and ranking of websites that
fail to meet the search engines quality
standard as a website owner or a digital
marketer it is important to stay up to
date with the latest search engine
algorithm updates and optimize your
website accordingly to improve its
visibility and ranking and search
results ahead in this video Let's
understand the types of search engine
algorithms there are several types of
search engine algorithms each with its
own unique approach to ranking and
displaying search results here are some
of the most common types the number one
we have is crawlers or spiders these
algorithms use both to crawl the web and
index web pages based on their content
keywords and other factors the next we
have is semantic search this type of
algorithm attempts to understand the
meaning of search query and the content
on the web pages to provide more
relevant search results the next we have
is pagerank this algorithm is developed
by Google and it assigns a score to web
page based on the number and quality of
links pointing to them the next we have
is personalized search these algorithms
take into account of a user's search
history location and other data to
provide search results tailored to their
individual's preferences
the next we have is natural language
processing this type of algorithm uses
machine learning and artificial
intelligence to understand natural
language queries and provide more
accurate search results the last one we
have is knowledge graphs these
algorithms aim to provide answers to
specific questions by drawing on the
structured data and building a knowledge
graph of entities relationships and
Concepts overall search engines use a
combination of these algorithms and more
to provide the best possible search
results to the users in this video we
are specifically going to focus on the
page rank algorithm page rank is an
algorithm developed by Google's
co-founders Larry Page in 1998 as a part
of their research project in Stanford
University the algorithm is used to
determine the relevance or importance of
a web page based on the links pointing
to it the basic idea behind pagerank is
that Pages importance is determined by
number of quality of other pages that
link to it in other words the more links
a page receives from other high quality
Pages the more important it is deemed to
be to calculate the page rank of a page
the algorithm considers both the number
and the quality of inbound links or
backlinks as well as the page rank of
the linking Pages it assigns a numerical
value to each page with higher values
indicating the greater importance the
algorithm works by treating each page a
node in a network with the links between
the pages representing the edges this is
an iterative algorithm to calculate the
page rank values for each page in the
network
here is the formula for the page rank
algorithm the basic page rank algorithm
is as follows it starts with a set of
web pages and assigns an initial page
rank value to each page next it
calculates the page rank of each page
based on the page rank of the pages that
links to it it updates the page rank of
each page based on the damping factor
which represents the probability that a
user will continue browsing randomly
rather than following a link
it repeats Step 2 and 3 until the page
rank values for each page covers stable
State page rank has become an important
aspect of Google search algorithms
although the exact detail of how it is
used are not publicly disclosed it is
also used in other applications such as
social network analysis and
recommendation systems in conclusion the
page rank algorithm is a crucial tool
for ranking web pages in search engine
results it works by assigning a score to
each page based on the number and
quality of links pointing to it patreon
considers the importance of not only the
links pointing to the page but also the
importance of pages those links are
coming from it uses a mathematical
formula that calculates the probability
would reach a particular Page by
following links from the other Pages
while the page rank has been modified
and improved over the years it remains a
fundamental part of Google's ranking
algorithm it is important for a website
owners to understand how page rank works
and to develop the strategies for
improving their website score this can
be achieved through various techniques
such as creating high quality content
obtaining backlinks from reputable
sources and optimizing the website
structures and metadata overall the
pagerank algorithm has had a significant
impact on the way we search for
information online and its importance is
likely to continue into the future as
search engines become increasingly
sophisticated if you are interested in
pursuing a career in SEO then simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you are looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below during our childhood we have heard
the fictional stories of robots taking
over various household courses making
the lives of humans easy peasy but if
you are not aware then these fictional
stories are turning into reality though
not in the form of physical robots but
yes in the form of computer programs and
apps with the help of artificial
intelligence and machine learning
Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way Chad
gbd is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a
as we discussed earlier Chad jpt is the
application of artificial intelligence
and machine learning if you are looking
to get certified into Ai and machine
learning then here at simply learn we
have a certification course for you
artificial intelligence is a growing
technology and the most trending jobs
these days if you are looking to get
certified have a look at artificial
intelligence master's program by simply
learning the course covers all the
details with the industry projects of
artificial intelligence if you see there
are number of tools covered in this
certification like numpy pandas sci-fi
spark Keras tensorflow R programming
python Scala Etc this artificial
intelligence course is in conjunction
with the IBM so what are you waiting for
have your own certification and get a
good salary hike a good career with
artificial intelligence you can check
the link in the description box below so
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to a channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn we know that SEO rankings
depends on various factors like on-page
optimization of page optimization and
more while using chat gbd we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
SEO ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chatgpt
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized uh blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we'll find some good
keywords
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just make good keywords to create a
blog
on which bank
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are few places like
Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for forces for for search rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in
goodbye
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to uh
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like a charge apt provides you the
facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to say every number of words
like if this Blog has two thousand or
five thousand words you can just ask
chat GPT to reduce it to two thousand or
thousand words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more keywords
to increase its reach
suggest
you
more relevant
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
title helps the user to click on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
add the best
suitable title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and
okay so it is showing the relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these factors
foreign
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me if you would
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these uh blog pages in
your website or if you have created any
of these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 pieces to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this blog
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generative
for all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
amount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and all tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
title and
Alt
tag
for
mount
Z image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
Fuji
Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
choose
the amount
you'll see image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
Mount Fuji
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us the suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of UNS and unsplash
pixels or Shadow stock to download the
image so we can really navigate to these
websites and download some of the
required image
for our blog
so we we have completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
or your blog page
suggest me
suggest
video ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
other idea is best match for my blog so
try to extract anyone from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization ideas
optimizations
foreign
video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
suggest me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another
users so the search engines by by these
search engines understand that your
content is really good and it is worth
of ranking so definitely getting a good
backlink from a very good authority
websites is fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the black background
I repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is uh which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
yes
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
top 10
places to visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so
uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate these kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO
optimized URL for the
above block
say so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four sharing
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common WhatsApp Shares are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a battling for from
your blog you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above
block so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that search engines are really in
love with the uni content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to charge
everybody is not able to identify the
duplicate content however it is
suggesting us some of the tools like
copyscape or sideliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the shared GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of a
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
if you are really interested to
create one of your chat gpts or create
some of these type of AI models which
will definitely reduce the manual work
then you really need to have the
knowledge of a good knowledge of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and so if you are interested
then definitely go and have a look at
simply learns
and machine learning course
so with these with this in-depth course
and the AIML certification you will be
definitely able someday to create your
own
AI models
if you see it is in collaboration with
IBM the course duration is just 11
months it is an online boot camps
and please don't delay because next
cohort is definitely starting on 16th of
February
you can see our some of the alumni they
are working in the top mncs like Google
Microsoft Amazon Deloitte LinkedIn and
much more
so what skills we are covering in this
certification is statistics supervised
unsupervised learning Python Programming
recommendation system natural language
processing deep learning reinforcement
learning and if you are aware when we
started chat GPT uh this video then it
is dependent on reinforcement and
reinforcement learning so definitely it
will help you to create your own AI
models the tools we are covering in this
certification are python tensorflow
Keras the Django flask opencv and much
more if you are interested please uh
check the link in the description box
below
is your website not ranking as you
thought it would
are there too many competitions out
there
is it getting difficult to capture
relevant audiences
are the solutions suggested too
expensive
do not worry in this video you will get
easy solutions to all your questions as
we have come up with a list of top 10
SEO tools that anyone can use
and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools Yes
you heard it right they are free of cost
and are very useful for anyone who wants
to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list
but before we do kindly subscribe to our
Channel simply learn and hit the Bell
icon to never miss on such interesting
and useful videos
to carry your best SEO practices the
first free tool on our list is the
Keyword Planner
Keyword Planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by Google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result Pages the
Keyword Planner will help to discover
new keywords estimate monthly searches a
keyword has
get the cost of ads for the keyword
you're looking for
and help to organize keywords let's
understand how to use Google Keyword
Planner
open your AdWords account
now
go to the tools section and select
Keyword Planner
now you can either add a keyword to get
new insights or upload a CSV file to get
search volumes of already known keywords
let's see how it works
click on discover new keywords
from here you can change the location
enter the key phrase for which you need
keyword insights
click on get results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword phrase
now to get the search volumes of already
known keywords go to the Keyword Planner
and click on get search volume and
forecast
now upload your CSV file from here
here you will get search volumes for all
the keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include
keyword tool dot IO and keyword
generator by RFS
to know trending ideas you can use
Google Trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free now let's see the next
tool in the bucket
Google search console Google search
console is a free webmaster tool
provided by Google
it is important to timely monitor your
website and make it error free this is
where Google search console comes into
the picture
it helps businesses to Monitor and
maintain their website's presence in
Google search results some features of
Google Search console includes
getting confirmation that Google search
engine can crawl your website
fix the problems in page indexing
sends Pages for re-indexing
can view Google search traffic data
records the number of times your website
appears in the search results
records the search queries for which
website appears in the search result
shows the list of sites linking to you
and many more
let's Now understand how to use Google
search console
here the total Impressions suggests that
number of times your website appears in
the Google search results
whereas the total clicks suggest that
number of times your website is clicked
from the Google search result page
from the covered section
you will get to know all the errors
occurred during the crawling
we recommend you to try Your Hands On
Tools like Bing webmaster tool and RFS
which is free for website owners
next up we have the used SEO plugin
used SEO plugin helps in improving your
search results ranking it helps you free
as well as a paid version as a beginner
you can quickly check the free version
it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out SEO analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at SEO plugin
from here you can add SEO title
from here you can edit the slug slug is
the part of URL you can add the
necessary keyword here in The Meta
description section you can add the meta
description
which all together looks like this
where this part is your slug the keyword
you want to add in your page should be
added in the Focus key phrase section
the SEO analysis section
shows the SEO improvements in your
content
now moving towards the readability
analysis
readability analysis shows Improvement
in the textual content of the page
if both the indicators are green then
your SEO and readability both are good
to go
for used SEO we have covered the
significant features and now we will
understand one of the essential SEO
tools Google Analytics
website tracking plays an important role
in SEO it helps in understanding the
user behavior on your website Google
analytics is an Analytics tool used for
tracking a website
the standard version of Google analytics
is free
we can integrate Google analytics with
Google ads
the main features of Google analytics
include tracking session duration of
users pages per session and tracking
website traffic and bounce rate of users
let's take a quick tour if you are
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below of Google Analytics
here you can see reports of users for
last 7 days
now go to the reports section in the
dashboard
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from here
go to retention
when you can see the number of new users
and the number of returning users to
your website
to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization section
here you can see the monetization data
for the selected time span
we will understand Google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail moving ahead
with the next tool which is
small SEO tools puljarism checker
duplicate content is hated by search
engines if not taken seriously this
could hurt your search rankings
the plagiarism Checker detects duplicate
data in your content and shows its
source
you need to open this plagiarism checker
here you can add your content manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a verification
and click on check plagiarism
and here we get the results the content
is hundred percent unique
in case if we get any duplicate content
we can check the sources from here
as our content is unique we are not
getting any results here
in case if you don't want to enter your
content manually you can upload document
file from here
note that this Checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lengthy content you can break
the content and then check for its
uniqueness in case you don't want to
purchase the pro version moreover you
can also add a page URL to check the
uniqueness of the content the page has
over here and follow the same process by
clicking on the check the general zoom
button
the plagiarism Checker by grammarly is
also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content
the next tool that we have in our bucket
is the paid speed insights
spur the data provided by Google the
bounce rate increases to 32 percent as
the page load speed increases from 1 to
3 seconds
page speed insights is the paid speed
check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by Google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to
paid speed insights and select the URL
of the website for which you want to
undergo the check
enter the URL and click on analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
I'll select a desktop device
just in few seconds you will get the
required results
another tool that we can use is
tools.pingdom.com which has free as well
as paid versions moving forward to a
next magic tool which is Sim Rush
to grow your business it is essential to
keep an eye on what your competitors are
doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis
semraj is the competitor analysis tool
that gives complete walkthrough of the
competitors data like keywords
backlinks top performing content
campaigns
Etc
it has free as well as paid versions
link to semrush is in the description
box below use this link to get a 30-day
free trial for semrush
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
login to your sem Rush account
here enter the URL of your competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location for which the analysis is to be
performed
by adding URL you get all the competitor
data here I have added sem Rush as a
competitor so we are getting so many
details of sem Rush The Organic keywords
the organic traffic paid keywords paid
traffic referral domains and Authority
score
we can add a competitor as well from
here
now here you can see the data of both
sem rush and RFS
other than sem rush you can use spyfu
which has some free daily trials now let
me tell you about an excellent auditing
tool
which is screaming frog
dear Learners it is essential to know
how your website is performing and for
this you need to carry out frequent
website audits
screaming frog is a website auditing
tool that works similar to web crawlers
it has free as well as paid versions
some features of free version include
finding broken links errors and
redirects analyzing page title and
metadata href Lang attributes auditing
finding duplicate content
Etc with a crawl limit of 500 urls
let's know more about it go to screaming
frog
now
from here download the tool on your
system
check various resources provided
on how to learn the tool from here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is seability where you can
enter the URL and get the audit reports
moving further with another free tool
which is rf's backlink checker
gaining high quality backlinks is an
essential factor for SEO ranking as it
shows the trust of other websites in
your content moreover it helps in
building the authority of your website
with the help of backlink Checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink Checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks top
5 anchors and top 5 Pages including
total number of backlinks and referring
domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check back link
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink Checker
are SCM Rush backlink Analytics tool and
seability
by signing up with these tools you will
get some free trials for your site last
but not the least let's know about the
mobile SEO tool which is mobile friendly
test
studies show that in year 2020 60 of
traffic was through mobile devices thus
it is essential to keep your website
mobile friendly as well
here is when the mobile friendly test
comes into action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly test
and enter the URL of your website
suppose I enter your www.wikipedia
.com
now click on test URL
here you get the results
we can see that the pages mobile
friendly
to check more details you can navigate
to your search console account
well if you think we are done for today
then then keep watching this video as we
have two bonus tools for you
so here comes the first one
the separator
search results vary with mobile devices
also your brand ranking May differ from
country to Country
to get reports on this circulator will
be your all-time companion it shows how
search results May differ for mobile
devices or locations
let's see how it works
go to separator
now
let's fill in the required fields
let's select the location
let's run the live test
and here we get the results
that's it daily you can run three free
live tests isn't this amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus tool
which is
the rich results test
you must have seen these kinds of search
results on search pages
let's dive deep into it
yes these type of results are known as
Rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for Rich results
go to Rich results test
and add the URL of your website let's
add the URL of Simply learn
now click on test URL
complete the verification
and check the report
so here we can see that simply learns
website is eligible for Google searches
Rich results
to monitor Rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console account
with tough competition to rank on the
search engines and app stores there is a
huge demand in industry for SEO experts
there are various types of roles in SEO
some popular ones are SEO associate SEO
analyst SEO executive SEO manager and
SEO expert
let's first talk about SEO Associates
SEO associate is responsible for
performing keyword research and
implementing SEO strategies to improve
organic ranking
the average base pay of an SEO associate
in U.S is between 1.59
000 to Dollar eighty thousand per annum
and in India is 2 lakh 28 000 rupees per
annum
next is SEO analyst SEO analyst is
responsible for keyword research
competitor analysis tracking organic
traffic and conversion rate the average
base pay of an SEO analyst in the US is
between dollar forty eight thousand to
Dollar 78 000 per annum and in India is
2 lakh 28 000 rupees per annum
understanding the responsibilities of
SEO executives
an SEO executive is responsible
for Gathering analytics reports
create an SEO friendly content and
implementing on-page and off-page
techniques
the average waste pay of an SEO
executive in U.S is dollar 39
382 per annual and in India is in
between 1 lakh 92 000 to 3 lakhs 62 000
rupees per annum
an SEO manager is responsible for
analyzing reports of the campaigns
developing content marketing strategies
managing a team of SEO experts fixing
technical SEO issues and more
the average base pay of SEO manager in
US is 1.72 652 per annum
and in India
is 8 lakh 79 000 rupees
moving towards the job responsibilities
of SEO expert SEO expert is responsible
for creating keywords and content
strategy link building strategies
competitor analysis and reports and
campaigning the average base pay of an
SEO expert in U.S
is in between dollar fifty three
thousand to Dollar 78 000 per annum and
in India
is 276 000 rupees per annum
some companies hiring for significant
roles under SEO are Microsoft Disney
Siemens
udemy and Deloitte if you are interested
in pursuing a career in SEO then simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint is
the perfect place to start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below SEO is an important part of the
marketing strategy in case your website
doesn't show up on the first page of the
search engine then you need to work on
it to solve all your SEO related
problems we've come up with a solution
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and today we will be discussing the top
10 tips that every marketer needs to
know so let's get started and see the
first step
the first step is voice search now voice
search will impact search queries in
2021 according to dialogtech.com
in the United States of America 55
percent of the households will have
their own smart speaker by 2022.
well that's a lot so if you're planning
to optimize your voice search consider
choosing wise keywords
find out longer phrases that Searchers
use in daily life conversation
voice search is a more suitable way for
searching long and more natural sounding
phrases creating detailed and relevant
answers are essential when optimizing
for voice search so always remember to
create Persona based content
next create web pages that can answer
FAQ use
because when Searchers ask a question
they begin their question with words
like who when whom what however there
are many reasons for using voice search
such as dictating text messages looking
for a video on YouTube calling a person
from your contact list asking for
directions
Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is reduced
now the second step in the process is
the mobile optimization
now you must already know how important
it is to make your site mobile friendly
for a better user experience but did you
also know that having a mobile friendly
application impacts your search engine
optimization
sem Rush confirms that by the year 2025
approximately 70 percent of Internet
users will access the internet through
mobile devices
Google's mobile friendly update has
resulted in a big change in search
rankings with the help of Google's free
mobile friendly test have a look at how
effective your mobile website is also
take a peek at the mobile usability
report in Google's search console
now let's talk about tip number three
that is Google's eight principles Google
has confirmed that content quality is an
essential factor for ranking on search
engine result pages
but what does quality mean to Google
well content that fulfills the Google
eat principle will rank higher each
stands for expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness
these elements will determine if a web
page has a useful quality content
Google uses the combination of
algorithms to deliver the best results
for users Google Panda is one of the
famous algorithms of Google which
emphasizes delivering high quality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have low quality and
duplicate content not just that there is
one more algorithm called rank brain
rankbrain is a processing algorithm that
uses machine learning to interpret
search queries that users search on
Google whereas the searched query may
not have the right keywords that were
searched for
for example
when you're searching for chocolate cake
recipes you will also get results for
chocolate truffle cake recipes on the
search engine results page Google Panda
and rankbrain send Bots to crawl each
and every website and as a result shows
high quality content on the top of the
search engine results page
next is our tip number four featured
snippet
these results are featured on the top
part of the page
Google programmatically chooses the best
answer from the third party website and
displays it on the featured snippet
here's what a featured snippet looks
like
according to ahrefs for a specific
search query almost 99 percent of web
pages shown in the featured snippet
already rank on serp's first page some
of the ways to optimize featured
Snippets are organize your content in a
structured way make sure one article
answers many similar questions use
eye-catching images and the last point
is to create answers with tables to
drive clicks and write dedicated
headings to answer featured Snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create Snippets plan on creating
question based questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at the Google search function that
is usually written in the blue color and
it reads out as people also ask so now
let's move to the fifth tip
image optimization according to sem Rush
image optimization will play a prominent
role in search in case the images on
your website aren't optimized make sure
to take care of them right now remember
to use high quality images relevant
images and use a suitable label for your
image file include images in your site
map as it becomes easier for the Bots to
crawl and finally use alt tags as
crawlers use it to classify the images
alt text is displayed on the web page
when an image fails to load on a user
screen it is also utilized by Google to
drive meaning from images
a well-optimized image can improve your
page ranking and increase the engagement
on it image optimization can help your
web page show up in the image carousels
on search engines
next we have semantically related
keywords
semantic search will have become an
important factor for ranking in the
future semantic keywords are linked to
the primary keywords they drive relevant
traffic on search engine result pages
a simple way to look for LSI keywords is
on Google serp
semantic search can be performed wisely
by writing content that targets the
question that your target audience is
looking for
remember to optimize content for topic
clusters instead of focusing solely on
keywords and finally use structured data
and pick your semantic keywords this can
also be done with the help of a
comprehensive keyword tool it finds out
semantically related keywords
next comes step number seven building
quality links
building quality links to your website
is important if you are aiming to manage
a successful and long-term SEO strategy
building quality links cannot be ignored
in 2016 Google declared that building
quality links are one of their top three
ranking signals always opt for quality
over quantity
as building quality links to your
content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in scrps
let me share a few effective strategies
that will increase the number of links
pointing to your website dramatically
the first one
earn backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content
finally get listed in the high quality
link directories this will help you
build links from authoritative websites
next number eight is local search
listings
local SEO is the practice of optimizing
a website in order to obtain traffic
from location-based searching it is the
best way to Market your products and
services to local customers
according to Google local results are
based on relevance distance and
prominence these factors help Google to
find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the internet
sem Rush confirms that local search
listings will play a larger role in the
SEO strategies
suppose you want to know how to get your
business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own
for this it is also important to have a
strong backlink profile
next we have number nine that is improve
the user experience
for the past few years ux has become an
important ranking factor for Google
however more and more SEO Specialists
have gained an interest in ux
ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor
consider the partnership of search
engine optimization and user experience
this way the search engine optimization
focuses on search engines and user
experience targets website visitors
so both share a common goal of giving
users the best result
this is what the content King app says
about the user experience
let me show you a few practices on how
to effectively leverage ux designs to
provide your site's SEO performance
simplify your site's navigation a good
site architecture helps to gain traffic
utilize ux design to SEO friendly
layouts which means make content easy to
digest infused images and videos
whenever possible use ctas very wisely
and finally optimize for site load speed
optimize for mobile responsive design as
more than 50 percent of all the traffic
is now driven by mobile search
in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement
and finally we come to our 10th and last
tip
that is using schema markup
according to search metrics 36 percent
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup
schema markup is microdata that every
individual can add to his website in
order to give an enhanced description to
users on a search engine results page
in simple words schema markup is used to
define website content
adding structured data will give your
website a significant SEO boost and
increase your rankings
some of the schema markup examples are
ratings and reviews image thumbnails
product availability and finally site
links
adding schema markup to your HTML is one
of the ranking factors if you are
interested in pursuing a career in SEO
then simply learns postgraduate program
in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint is the perfect place to
start
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignment you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in this
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learn
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
to learn more about this course you can
click the link in the description box
below thanks for you okay so the first
question that you might be asking an
interview is differentiate between do
follows and no follows okay so if you
take in or listen to my SEO courses on
YouTube for SEO we we talked a lot about
do follows and no follows and and simply
put I mean do follows are just signals
to the search engines to follow the link
so there's a link on site a pointing to
site B we're going to basically tell
Google Bing and some of these other
search engines hey go ahead and follow
that link now I know file is just the
opposite so no follow link doesn't allow
the search engine crawlers to follow it
so if we have a link on our site site a
pointing to site B we could put a
nofollow tag in there and what that's
going to do it's going to signal to the
Crawlers hey don't follow this link so
in the end if the Crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so Google is
not going to give you read it or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the Crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow tags so just a
reminder link juice is the reputation or
Equity pass from one website to another
so if you have a link on another website
and that website is of high quality
meaning their page Authority their
domain Authority is high they have a lot
of content you know they're not spammy
they're really rich and they're relevant
then you may want to make sure that the
link pointing from that site to your
site is a no follow so that way that
Google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a no
follow well it just pens I mean really
depends a lot of social media platforms
like Facebook have no follows if you
have a lot of content you may not want
to be pushing out a lot of do follows it
can actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link choose onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an SEO perspective if I have a site
and I have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites I'm
going to be particular about who I allow
the search engine to follow and what
links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that no file there they're
not going to follow that link and vice
versa if there's a link on another site
pointing to yours and there's is a no
follow there you're not going to get
credit the search engines aren't going
to pick up that link okay so question
two what is 301 redirect and how is it
different from a 302 redirect so 301
redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we don't have a
page anymore but we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so for 301 redirect
is permanent then a 302 is temporary so
we want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
that page agent and search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would Google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they may remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place Google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three three why are backlinks important
in SEO well we kind of hinted on that a
bit with the nofollow because if we have
a link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from quite quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get a more of a Lion's Share of
the traffic for certain keywords that
are our pages are found for and if our
pages are found in getting traffic then
because we have increased rankings we're
likely going to have increased traffic
and then it's just a snowball effect so
more traffic leads to more engagement
and conversions so the whole idea for
SEO is remember you have an on-page
strategy and an off-page strategy
building external links is part of an
off-page SEO strategy and we want to
make sure that you know we are relevant
in the form of a link or in the form of
content on other high quality sites
being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain Authority Google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really good
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO because videos are
found YouTube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on YouTube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so make
sure you go ahead and follow the best
practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing a video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty IE low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high value am you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
gonna like it and then other people are
gonna see that engagement they're gonna
see how many people liked it or how many
subscribers you have so promote your
videos to help you with the ranking of
the video on YouTube so that does play
into it so go ahead and promote it so
other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first indexing this is a
a really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so with that
smartphone bot goes to your website and
starts crawling what do you think
they're looking for their smartphone bot
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't designed for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asks this question you can even take it
a step further and say look I'm going to
measure how friendly my Walt my website
is for mobile devices and Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
Bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mobile usability
report okay number six list down the
most important local SEO ranking factors
okay so organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say Google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or you're looking for a coffee
shop so what you want to do is you want
to create a web page for every product
and service okay you also want to opt
for your business listings on Google my
business and and there are plenty of
other local business directories out
there like Yelp for example or Bing even
has one so go ahead and also make sure
you have a business listing as well but
since Google in the United States has a
huge market share you want to start with
Google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so you want to
make sure that that's current and
consistent so if you have a number on
your website make sure it's the same
number on Google my business okay you
can embed a Google map on your website
it could certainly optimize The Meta
tags and content not only on your web
pages but within your Google my business
directory so you can add your business
to other local directories like I
mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews The Hat you
have the better off you are okay so I
always say this with with local search
three of the main factors in showing up
for local search on say Google is
obviously the keyword the second is the
proximity of where that person is and
then third is the reviews so you can't
really control the proximity but you
can't control the key word and you can
control the reviews to some degree so
work hard at getting reviews for your
business but at the same time you can
certainly work in some keywords let's
just say for your product and service
pages on your website but also you can
translate that over to Google my
business okay so working in those
keywords making sure your your number
your address your name they're all
consistent and and really just spreading
your the the business out on other
directors that's really all these are
really key factors for local SEO okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just SEO 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this and having go
Google penalize us by again setting up a
301 redirect remember three or ones are
permanent we can also use what they call
canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and the third option is opt for
preferred domain and Google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page page or you
can go through search console okay
number eight what are the tactics to
increase a web page speed okay so what
are some of the tactics well when you
build a site especially for mobile you
want to keep it as simple as possible
and what I mean by simple as possible
really I mean hey use a simple website
design don't get overly creative if you
will most websites all websites have
images you're not going to be able to
get around that but just make sure you
optimize your images made in other words
don't have such a large image size if
you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
GoDaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimize minifying
when we see mimifying we mean get rid of
some of the Redundant code if you have
CSS you know get rid of chop some of the
get rid of the JavaScript you're not
using so that's what we mean by
optimizing code readies redirects okay
ideally you just want to have one
redirect in place you don't want to
create a daisy chain so to speak of
redirecting and redirecting after that
that's never going to bode well and it's
going to slow things down as well enable
browser caching so if you name browser
caching basically if somebody comes back
to the page they've been on say two days
ago they're probably going to see a cash
version of that page and then opt for
the content delivery Network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to Google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google is going to analyze
the URL for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see Google gives a
score so we could see the score from
wall ball and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here I could see some of the issues
that the site may be having in terms of
page load time for their desktop if I
flip over the mobile you know here I can
see some other issues for example they
have a server static assets with
efficient cash policy now if you're not
sure what the heck that means you can
always just click on it and you can see
some specifics here anyway you can just
always Google it as well uh here you got
to reduce the impact of third-party code
okay so that's another thing uh reduce
JavaScript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
made about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should we'll tend to slow
down the site okay so you can use page
bin insights you can always get a
glimpse of how pages are loading simply
by also going to for example Google
analytics under Behavior okay you can go
to site speed and if you click on
overview okay Google what Google does is
they do a sampling of pages over time
and in this case based on 89 nine page
views they have an average page load
time and so you can get a sense of how
quick specific Pages load your site
overall simply by looking at the site
speed overview report in Google
analytics to get a sense of how quick
your pages are loading now there are
certain factors that do affect load time
so obviously the way the page is built
with the code the images Etc but also
the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know Ivory Coast in Africa okay so
it really depends on the network you're
on so and also the page every page is
built differently so you want to get a
sense of what pages are loading quicker
and which pages are not you can simply
just go to page timings and and Google
analytics you get a sense of what pages
do not load fast and which ones do and
maybe hone in on the pages that aren't
loading fast and address those pages
first okay so you have two tools at your
disposal one Google analytics and one
page speed insights okay so let's look
at question number nine here so when
should an individual Target short tail
and long tail keywords okay so remember
short tail are usually one to two
keywords very Broad in nature long tail
keywords or maybe three four keywords in
a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower uh volume but also lower
competition but the great thing about
long tail keywords the conversion rate
will tend to be a little bit higher than
say a short tail because it's less vague
and more specific so you can use short
tail keywords if you're trying to drive
a lot of visitors because those keywords
are going to be vague or Broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
Pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific at the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
some they'd say long tail where hey
maybe you're just honed in on a few set
number of products and you're not care
you don't care a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody asks me this
question in an interview what am I going
to focus on while developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be indexed with Google
smartphone bot so mobile usability is
very important so we need to make sure
our website is responsive for mobile
just some basic practices when it comes
to site architecture navigation we want
to have a simple URL structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and eat okay if you have
five products okay maybe you have a your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end User it's
probably going to be complicated for
Google you always want to create a site
map now what is that site map a site map
is simply just a formatted file with two
that includes all your URLs and assets
your images and your videos they're
going to be sitting on your server as
well so you want Google or these these
Bots to be able to find your pages and
assets and by the way you want to take
it a step further and make sure you
upload that site map which is sitting in
the root directory meaning domain.com
sitemap.xml okay you want to take that
site map and make sure you input that
site map location in Google search
console that way Google search console
has a one-way ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a website is having a robot's
text file and all A robot's text file is
it's like a lock I always say to a house
so if you lock a door in your house
nobody's going to be able to get in that
door so it's all about robots text file
is you're telling Google and these other
Bots that are coming across your site
what's locked and what's not locked
meaning what they have access to what
they don't have access to so you want to
be able to make sure you have a robot's
text file if you're trying to non-index
specific pages of your website because
if you tell Google don't crawl these
Pages or this directory they're not
going to get crawled and if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and why
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website and I'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so there are a lot of reasons
to have robots text files that's the
main reason sitemap you want Google to
get these pages and assets quickly okay
you want to make sure that your site
architecture navigation is in order you
want to make sure your site is mobile
friendly and you also want to make sure
you have content on your website that's
the key because that's what's going to
keep people on the website and engaged
and when I say content I don't
necessarily just mean words I also mean
videos I also mean images you know
something interactive okay you want to
keep people engaged that's the key
behind it trust me if if an end user
finds your site engaging Google is
likely going to find your site engaging
okay so those are good brownie points to
bring up if somebody asks you this
question in an interview so just a recap
here some important to have a better
site structure so the Bots can easily
access in the next content okay with a
responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your site's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages are on your website and where they
located along with the videos and images
okay and then the robots text just
instructs the search engine crawlers to
understand what pages should not be
indexed okay this is simply just a text
file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
then give it that way and this was all
for SEO bootcamp hope you guys found it
informative and helpful if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn